[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hello everyone it's seven o'clock you're
watching Sky News break first he's one
of the prime minister's most loyal
supporters now Dominic Robb's fate is in
the hands of Rishi sunak would he stay
will he be removed or will he quit lots
of questions this morning as we await
the PM's decision after reviewing
allegations that his Deputy bullied
officials will ask the transport
secretary Mark Harper about that report
plus we have the remarkable story of 15
children taken from Ukraine to Russia
who've escaped thanks to one exceptional
woman
it's Friday the 21st of April
awaiting his Fey Dominic raab's future
in the balance as Rishi sunak considers
a report into bullying allegations
against his deputy
it's all eyes on Downing Street this
morning as Richie soonack decides the
fate of one of the people who helped him
into power
charges are dropped against Alec Baldwin
over the fatal shooting on the set of
the movie rust
taken at gunpoint out 15 Ukrainian
orphans escaped from Russia and the
thousands of others left behind
ready to run President Biden will
formally announce his 2024 re-election
campaign as soon as next week
Sudan's paramilitary rapid support
forces says it's agreed to a 72-hour
truce in the fighting on humanitarian
grounds
I'm in central London where thousands of
climate activists are getting ready for
a four-day protest that'll cause huge
disruption they're calling it the big
one
Marathon motivation I'll speak to one of
the world's greatest athletes Elliot
chip choge about the London marathon and
a campaign to get kids moving
and they called it
[Music]
and I'll be joined by the pop Legend
Donnie Osmond who's touring the UK for
the first time in six years
[Music]
thank you
foreign good morning to you Dominic Raab
is awaiting his fate this morning the
prime minister is deciding on Mr Robb's
future after the conclusion of a
long-awaited investigation into bullying
allegations against his Deputy well the
report was handed to number 10 yesterday
morning Mr Raab has promised to quit if
he was found to have bullied staff
so let's get the latest uh political
correspondent Rob Powell is in Downing
Street for us this morning so Rob the
prime minister's had this report for
some time now and yet still no decision
yeah no real updates from number 10 this
morning simply saying that the Prime
Minister has the report that he wants to
consider it carefully and they won't be
commenting
um officially while that process is
ongoing I think given the nature of this
report and the form it's taking it was
always more likely that some sort of
delay might creep into this and that's
because Adam's Holly the Barrister that
has been interviewing Witnesses and
putting this together was asked by the
prime minister to put this together he's
not reaching a judgment on whether
Dominic Robb broke the ministerial code
he's just establishing the facts so it's
now for Rishi sunak to pour through that
report and decide if he believes that
his Deputy can carry on in position and
given that this was an investigation
that took several months to put together
several witnesses you imagine there will
be a lot of detail in there that the
Prime Minister will want to go through
it differs from previous inquiries
similar to this like the Nadim zahawi
inquiry because that was carried out by
the ethics advisor and they actually
reached a judgment on whether he wrote
the code law and that was why the Prime
Minister could act quite quickly in that
case but since to be taking his time in
this case I think though it is fair to
suggest that if there had been something
completely absolute undeniable egregious
in there that definitely did break the
code you would have imagined Rishi sunak
would have felt that he could have acted
straight away and potentially removed
Dominic Robb from his position I think
maybe though that speaks to really the
nature of this whole story that whilst
yes a lot of civil servants have spoken
a real really strong terms about how
Dominic Ra's Behavior they believe has
affected them you talk to other
officials who say actually maybe this is
more nuanced that yes he's a difficult
person to work with that he has his own
particular way of working but does that
amount to bullying I think it's that
ambiguity that means there's real
political risk for issue like if he
decides to keep his Deputy he may well
face a backlash from civil servants in
the ministry of Justice if he decides to
sack him then he may well face questions
about why he didn't act sooner and why
he waited for this report of course
there's a third option he could ask his
standards advisor is Advan on the
ministerial code to take a look at this
and to give him his judgment on this but
of course if he did that I think he may
well be accused of kicking this further
into the long grass
yeah still so many questions Rob this
morning aren't there we'll catch up with
you again later on but for a moment
thanks very much indeed
now let's just bring you a bit of
breaking news now on the economy and
retail sales have fallen in March
they're down 0.9 percent after Rising
about a percent in both January and
February analysts had been expecting a
drop that this is even worse than
predicted uh lots of analysts blaming
that exceptionally wet March which was
the wettest on record that figure though
just another layer on a pretty tricky
picture for the economy inflation
stubbornly high at 10.1 percent that
came out earlier this week
let's go back to your top story and that
a weighted decision on Dominic raab's
future by the Prime Minister Amy
levisage is the assistant general
secretary of the civil servants Union
the FDA and she joins me now as you can
see a very good morning to you Amy at
levisage thanks so much for talking to
us
first of all I wonder whether you'd seen
this report at all a number of your
members may be involved in some of the
allegations and if you've not received
it have you been given an indication of
when you might get to see it
um no
um the the members who've um put in
complaints and haven't seen the report
so they had an agonizing day yesterday
as they were informed basically by
watching the news that a decision was
going to come from the Prime Minister
um and then they had to just sit there
and wait for it and the only
um updates that they would be getting
was exactly the same way that we were
through uh through the media and and
it's really um shoddy way to treat and
to treat people you need to show balance
in these sorts of cases and fairness to
everyone
um involved but we've got obviously we
had the sort of extraordinary decision
and then to delay making a decision we
think that possibly might come today but
we we're just going on on kind of the
same information that you get really and
and we've got no idea and that's been an
agonizing weight for uh for everyone
that's you know after five months of
going through a complaints process which
I could be grueling in themselves and
that's for some of those people they've
waited years to be able to put in their
complaint
and then I've had to sleep this night
ahead of them and we still don't know
what
um what's going to come and I do think
that um you know the Prime Minister
could have showed a bit more compassion
to to everyone involved and in making
the complaint and and You Know spoken to
them personally about what they um you
know what they could expect and and when
they could expect it and yet the Prime
Minister might say he owes it to the
complainants and to Dominic Robb to give
this due consideration by all accounts
it's a long report it's certainly been a
long investigation he should take his
time and make sure that he makes the
right decision
absolutely I mean these these decisions
and do need to be made carefully and and
obviously there is a lot of evidence
considering that there are eight
complainants oh there's eight complaints
with 24 complainants and uh in the
report there's going to be a lot of um a
lot of evidence there and I mean the
Prime Minister didn't have to announce
that he was going to make a decision
yesterday and I think that's what
um obviously fueled all of this and it's
really difficult you know if you're a
civil servant and involved you've you
have no right of reply publicly you're
employed by the Civil Service you can't
and you can't publicly defend yourself
so you've got other um people you know
making comments and about what might be
in the report you know allies of of the
Deputy Prime Minister making those
comments and you've got no right of
replying that's a real power imbalance
and which we've seen all the way through
this
so neither of us have seen this Rapport
but from what you've heard from your
members about this what do you think the
Rishi cnx decisions should be
well that is a matter for Rishi Zina he
has designed this process so he is the
only one that can make the decision and
because he didn't have um an independent
advisor in place when this came to light
which is why Adam Tolley was appointed
and they wrote terms of reference
specifically just for this
um complaint and as we heard before in
uh from German Street and they have
designed those terms of reference so
Adam Holly was just Gathering the facts
and he wasn't going to make any
determination he did this amount to
bullying so but she's doing that not
only has to make the decision about
whether there has been a breach of the
ministerial code he's also got to
determine did this amount of bullying
and he still made the decision after he
appointed sir Laurie Magnus his
independent ethics advisor that he still
didn't want any
um independent advice and partial advice
um on this case so he's made it so he's
the sole Arbiter of this which is the
problem that we have throughout the
um that we've been saying throughout
with any complaint against a minister
that the decision is always solely the
prime ministers okay and they don't only
act as judge and jury but they're the
ones that get to decide whether there's
even an investigation in the first place
um
sorry to cut in I just want to be clear
on what your view is though do you think
that Dominic Robb should be sacked are
you happy to make that call now or do
you want to wait and see the report
well look we've got to wait to see and
see the report of course you know we're
always gonna and uh side with our
members of course we are I'm not
independent and that's why I'm not um
sat as judge and jury we've got to see
the report and we've got to wait for it
this is your next decision but he has
got to justify the decision that he
makes
and he's got to give the rationale for
why he has made that decision based on
the evidence that's in the report and
that's the important thing it's got to
be based on evidence it cannot be based
on any other considerations like the
political the politics involved and it
must be based on evidence and fairness
and there have been reports that some
civil servants might be minded to to
quit if Richie soon act does decide to
keep Dominic Raab on have you heard the
same thing do you expect resignations if
that was the case
I think it's incredibly difficult in any
of these cases for a person who's
putting a complaint to be able to remain
um in the workplace and this is what
we've seen you know throughout that
actually people don't put in complaints
because of this um this really
dysfunctional process that we have and
because the only way to make a complaint
is to go straight to the Prime Minister
and there's all those politics involved
and what we actually see is civil
servants leave their department they go
they go to a different department or
they leave the Civil Service altogether
rather than make their complaint
and what we saw
um after Boris Johnson's
um uh decision around pretty Patel
whether they're reported upheld that she
had bullied but he kept her anyway that
that actually had a chilling effect
across the Civil Service where people
thought well what is the point in
putting in a complaint that proves that
the system isn't fair it doesn't
um you know consider the evidence of of
these matters it just considers the
politics and that's what I think people
are going to be fearing uh last night
and today that what we're going to see
is history repeat itself we're going to
see political considerations come first
and and
that will then have a chilling effect
across the Civil Service and you know
this isn't uh you know we this isn't
just one or two bad apples here we had a
report that showed that one in six
senior civil servants had witnessed the
unacceptable behaviors just in the last
year alone and this these behaviors are
really quite widespread and we do need
to have a moment where we say this isn't
appropriate in no other workplace in the
land would you get away with this kind
of behavior
okay well Amy uh levisage no doubt we'll
get your reaction when we do get a
decision but for the moment uh we
haven't got one but thanks very much
indeed for your views this morning we do
appreciate them thank you
now prosecutors have dropped involuntary
manslaughter charges against the actor
Alec Baldwin over a fatal shooting of
the set of the movie rust the decision
came after new evidence emerged on the
gun that fired the shot the killed
cinematographer Helena Hutchins is our
us correspondent mother Kellner
in the place known as Montana's Paradise
Valley a project resurrected production
on the film rust is restarting 18 months
after Helena Hutchins was shot dead on a
set hundreds of miles from here as the
film's star Alec Baldwin did final
rehearsals he was told involuntary
manslaughter charges against him in
connection with hutchin's death had been
dropped Alec Baldwin and other members
of the cast and crew of rust were doing
last minute preparations here when news
came through that those charges which
were filed in New Mexico had been
dropped a preliminary trial was due to
starting just two weeks time so this was
an incredibly dramatic intervention
and for those preparing to resume
filming a note of relief so Alec is a
consummate professional and I think we
had every confidence in his ability to
act within the movie regardless of
what's going on in any aspect of his
personal life I would say probably
um for everyone else it's a good outcome
in the sense that we feel that justice
has been served Baldwin posted a picture
with wife Hilaria on Instagram I owe
everything I have to this woman he wrote
and to You Luke he put in Brackets
presumably a reference to his lawyer
Luke Nikas
the top of the Spire of a church is all
that's visible of Yellowstone film Ranch
from the public Road
a poignant reminder that it was while
rehearsing a scene in a church that
Helena Hutchins was shot dead the bullet
lodged in the shoulder of the film's
director Joel Souza a year and a half
later he returned to the set alongside
other members of the original cast and
crew
as part of a wrongful death settlement
Helena Hutchins widower Matthew Hutchins
has become an executive producer on Rust
there are still at least five
outstanding civil lawsuits against
Baldwin and the other producers of rust
but the Hollywood veteran will now
finish this film an actor and not a
criminal defendant Martha calners Sky
News Montana
now then still to come here on the show
this morning I'm going to be joined by
the transport secretary Mark Harper as
the Prime Minister Ponders the future of
his Deputy Dominic Raab also ahead we'll
compare traditional demonstrations with
the more radical climate protests that
we've become used to with a former Tory
special advisor Lauren mckevitt and
climate campaigner Danica McCarthy
and I'll also speak to a breeder and
owner of rare pigs about the shrinking
UK pit population and The Wider Pig
industry crisis
that's all coming out first though 15
Ukrainian orphans I've told Sky News how
they were taken at gunpoint by Russian
soldiers removed from their Homeland and
illegally transferred to Russia before
making a remarkable escape to freedom
and to safety our International Affairs
editor Dominic wyckorn reports now on
Ukraine's missing children
thousands of children have been taken
from Ukraine by the Russians in this war
this is the story of 15 who escaped
their clutches
their ordeal lasted five months and took
them a thousand miles but they have
finally reached Freedom thanks to one
remarkable woman
Natalia was the director of their
orphanage in southern Ukraine when
Russian forces arrived one is
we know from CCTV footage taken in
another orphanage how the Russian
military has searched for children in
this war Natalia begged the Russians to
let her children go
foreign
the day the soldiers came was filmed by
Russian State tv the footage doesn't
show what the children say happened that
they pleaded not to be taken and the
Russians fired their guns to make the
move
14 year old Dasher describes those
frightening moments
um
they say they were moved against their
will at gunpoint a clear violation of
the laws of war taken from their
orphanage to another in the village of
stephanievka 150 miles Behind Enemy
Lines then the Russians move them again
as they retreated across the danipra
river fifteen-year-old stas says he
feared for the worst
so maybe
[Music]
he was right to be worried they were
heading for Russia taken through one
city after another in Russian occupied
Crimea then across the Kirch Straits and
over the Border
Natalya's worst fear to come true
this is the Fate that could have awaited
them Sky News has found evidence of
Ukrainian children being deported deep
into Russia some are given to Russian
families in these pictures in a city two
and a half thousand miles from home
oh this is sent to camps where we know
children are indoctrinated in putinist
ideology and trained in the use of
weapons
and they're being exploited for
propaganda purposes too in events
presided over by Vladimir Putin himself
the children being made to hug this
Russian soldier are from mariupole a
city destroyed by Putin's military
the Russians say they're rescuing
children from war
but both Putin and his children's rights
commissioner have now been indicted by
the international criminal court for the
war crime of deporting children charges
they've both rejected foreign
but this British war crimes investigator
whose senior evidence says moscow's
claims do not stand scrutiny this is a
clear conditioning of children for
nefarious purposes I think it goes to
the overall criminal plan which is to
extinguish extinguish Ukrainian City so
we're talking about cultural genocide
and we're also talking about physical
genocide
our 15 orphans Journey ended an escape
from Russia slipping across the border
and finding sanctuary in Georgia
they recall the moments they made it to
Freedom
is
they're now waiting until it's safe
enough to go back home against the odds
Natalia has kept her word and led them
to safety is
foreign
Sky News to Blissey Georgia
now also making the news this morning
Sudan's rapid support forces have agreed
to a 72-hour ceasefire it'll coincide
with Eid and the group claims
humanitarian corridors will be open to
allow civilians to evacuate the foreign
secretary James cleverley has cut short
his specific tour to focus on
coordinating Britain's response to the
Sudan crisis
the school swatchdog ofsted has said
it'll make changes following the suicide
of head teacher Ruth Perry in January
but his Chief Inspector has refused to
bow to pressure to drop one word
assessments which range from outstanding
to inadequate
blue ticks for verified Twitter users
have started to be removed from accounts
that don't pay for the site's premium
Subscription Service the company has
gone ahead with the plan despite
concerns that it would lead to a rise in
misinformation Cristiano Ronaldo Oprah
Winfrey and Pope Francis are amongst the
notable figures who've lost their tick
let's go back now to our top story and
the Prime Minister deliberating over the
future of his Deputy Dominic Raab after
receiving a report into allegations of
bullying well the transport secretary
Mark Harper joins me now very good
morning good to see you has the Prime
Minister made a decision yet on Dominic
Rob's future no he hasn't um he's taking
his time to consider the report he did
only receive the report yesterday and of
course it's a report produced after a
five-month inquiry so
um I'm assuming it'll be no doubt an
extensive report and the prime minister
is a man who want to take the time to
read the report in full go through the
detail before he reaches a conclusion
this is an important matter it's
important both for the complainants that
have made complaints about Dominic Robb
and also for Mr Rob and the Prime
Minister will want to make the right
decision and be fair to both groups of
people
when will he make his decision will it
be today well look he wants to he'll
want to reach a conclusion as quickly as
he can this is an important matter but
he'll also want to take the time to get
it right and as I said he only received
the report yesterday and it's a report
produced after a five-month inquiry by a
senior KC so you know there's a balance
to strike here about taking the time to
get it right and of course as you've
reflected in your report there are lots
of other things that the Prime Minister
has to focus on as well as this so I
think it's important he takes the time
but he will want to reach a a swift
conclusion after taking the time to to
go through conclusion can you give us a
rough time frame when we should get a
decision by will we get one by the end
of today and that's all you can use any
idea I'm not going to speculate about it
look I haven't read the report myself
um the prime minister is doing that and
he will obviously want to reach a swift
conclusion but I said he did only
receive the report yesterday and it is
as a result of a five-month inquiry so I
think it's people are being reasonable
about it I think people would want him
to take the time to read the report in
full himself before he reaches a
conclusion and that would be fair
actually to those that have made the
complaints as well as to the Deputy
Prime Minister is is it fair to say that
if this report was conclusive there'd be
a decision by the Prime Minister by now
does this imply that the report is
finally balanced well look I I don't
think people should read anything into
it that's I've read those reports but I
think that's speculation you know I
haven't read the report myself I I
prefer to I think due process is
important in these matters you know the
Prime Minister set up an inquiry with a
very credible serious KC to do the
inquiry and I think actually if you're
going to do justice to the process
um you should he should take the time to
read the report and actually we
shouldn't speculate now I certainly as a
member of the government shouldn't
speculate about it I think we should
give the premise of the time to make
decision he'll want to reach us with
conclusion but as I said he only got the
report yesterday okay and it's for the
prime minister to make the decision you
talk about due process but is he minded
to show the report to his ethics advisor
Laurie Magnus well look fundamentally
this is a decision for the Prime
Minister the the Casey that he appointed
Adam told his job was to established the
facts was to talk to the complainants to
talk to Dominic Raab to talk to other
people who could throw light on the
circumstances involved and that means
the Prime Minister will have all of the
facts in front of them but fundamentally
it's a decision for him about who serves
in the government so it's a decision for
him and and he'll take that decision you
know in the careful meticulous way that
he reaches all his decisions okay and
Dominic Robb promised to resign if the
report conclusively showed that he'd
bullied staff he hasn't resigned he
continues to maintain as we understand
it that he behaved professionally that
would imply the report is inconclusive
doesn't it well well look I haven't
Dominic Rob as far as anywhere hasn't
said anything himself
um since
the report was received he has I think
all through the process he's been very
clear that he would fully comply with
the the process which he has and I know
when I've seen him being interviewed
he's been very careful to respect the
process and not try and prejudge it and
not speculate about it so I think that
that's the best solution so I think it's
better if people just wait not speculate
wait for the outcome of the process
um and then and then until people have
actually seen the contents of the report
I know it is difficult when when none of
us have seen this but I just wonder what
your reaction is to the fact that
Dominic Robb as we understand it he's
seen the report but he hasn't quit well
I think you're trying to draw me into
speculating about what the contents of
the report are which I completely
understand and I completely understand
people you know wanting to know what the
promises decision is going to be but as
I said it's I think after a five month
inquiry I think also you've got to
remember there were serious complaints
that were made and I think it's also
worth remembering this you know the
media reporting obviously focuses on the
future of the Deputy Prime Minister but
you know there were people involved here
who have made serious complaints and I
think you've got to be fair to them as
well and I think it's by treating this
seriously the premises taking the time
to read the report in detail before
reaching conclusion it's putting proper
weight on the complaints that have been
made as well as on the future of the
Deputy Prime Minister has the Prime
Minister spoken to Dominic role
I don't know I haven't spoken to the
Prime Minister uh I don't know whether
he has spoken to the Deputy Prime
Minister but actually the right thing
for the prime minister is to read the
report to understand the facts the the
whole point about why Adam Tully was
asked to do the inquiry was to establish
the facts to listen to the complainants
to talk to Dominic Robb and to other
people involved in the process and it's
it's the report that will then set out
for the Prime Minister the facts and
it's on the basis of those facts that he
can then reach a conclusion asking Stan
does the Prime Minister still have full
confidence in the Deputy Prime Minister
well look you're trying to draw me into
a conclusion the prime ministers the
prime ministers had the report and he's
in the process of going through what
will no doubt be an extensive report
after a five-month inquiry
um he will then reach a conclusion
um I understand he hasn't yet made a
decision and he'll set that out in in
the usual way and then and we'll know
what the position is and I think you're
trying to draw me into speculating he's
in the Pro process of reaching that
conclusion and he'll set that as soon as
he's able okay I think a lot of people
just have a lot of questions that's all
but let me but let me move on to another
subject because today marks the start of
four days of protests by Extinction
rebellion and other groups in London
um How concerned are you about
disruption well I'd say a couple of
things first of all the big event this
weekend with the marathon I I would be
appalled if that was disrupted you know
there are thousands of people that take
part in that race who are who will have
trained all year who are raising money
for charity and I think it would be
appalling if it was disrupted so that's
the the first point the second point is
the protesters I think have got
completely the wrong target here they're
making very serious points about climate
change Britain is one of the countries
in this government is one of the
governments that's leading the the fight
against climate change we only just a
few weeks ago main Department published
our zero emission vehicle mandate about
how we're going to decarbonize Road
Transport we published our details about
how we're going to make Aviation more
sustainable by using sustainable
aviation fuel now this government is
actually leading the fight globally
against climate change actually just up
all protesters would be much better
spent going and protesting in countries
where they don't take this seriously
rather than actually disrupting the
lives of millions of ordinary people who
are trying to go on about their lives in
a country which is led by a government
which is taking this very seriously do
concerns as transport secretary for the
transport system are you confident it'll
be running smoothly as usual this
weekend well look we obviously look at
potential threats to our Public Services
you know we obviously look at the
intelligence that's out there and we
obviously take all the proper steps to
make sure that we can keep the transport
system running that we can always see
prevent disruption and I know if anybody
does break the law then you know we will
use all of the forces at our disposal to
make sure that we can protect ordinary
people going about their lives and
people that are you know for example
running in the marathon or raising money
for charity and I just hope people use
their Democratic processes and they
don't try and break the law or disrupt
ordinary people going about their lives
okay well Mark we appreciate you coming
in with that we'll talk to you again
when we do get eyes on that report thank
you thanks very much
let's take a look now at what the
weather's up to
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the next few days look colder and
more unsettled but Northern parts will
stay largely fine today it's mostly dry
out there now if chilly but cloud and
rain is spreading across the South that
rain will Edge further west across
Southern Britain during the morning with
sunshine and showers following but
Cornwall should stay fine elsewhere
expect plenty of sunshine but the south
of Ireland will see some increasing
cloud
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
now coming up on Sky News breakfast
[Applause]
Elon musk's huge Starship spacecraft
gets off the ground but not for terribly
long
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
rocket ever made destined eventually to
take NASA astronauts back into space
[Applause]
[Music]
well after an aborted attempt earlier
this week the SpaceX Starship lifted off
from Texas to huge cheers carrying its
next Generation Starship Cruise vehicle
it was on calls for a 90-minute uncrewed
test flight and all was going well for
the first phase of the flight
the entire Starship stack continuing to
rotate we should have had Separation by
now obviously this is uh does not appear
to be a nominal situation
but as you can see it exploded four
minutes later and it fell back to earth
when two sections failed to separate
Elon Musk and the SpaceX team say
they've learned a lot and have hopes
that it'll one day be used to take
people to Mars
[Applause]
now President Biden is set to finally
announce he'll run for a second term as
soon as next week officials say no
formal timetable has yet been confirmed
but they've looked they're looking at
the 25th of April the anniversary of Mr
Biden's 2020 campaign announcement our
U.S correspondent Mark Stone has the
details
yes well it is surely one of the most
anticipated announcements here in
Washington DC for weeks and weeks and
weeks now there's been so much
speculation over whether or not
President Biden would seek a a second
term he's hinted so many times that he'd
like to but he would consult with his
family I think some expected that that
consultation with with his nearest and
dearest would would um perhaps mean that
he'd decide not to run again after all
he is 80 years old now
um that certainly is an attack point for
Republicans it is without doubt a
concern for Democrats but the
expectation now from sources is speaking
to our colleagues at NBC News it does
seem clear that next week Tuesday we
will discover that yes Joe Biden does
seek a second term yes he does believe
he has got a lot yet still to accomplish
and no he does not believe he is too old
crucially I think he has made a judgment
that the possible probable Republican
Party candidate will be Donald Trump Joe
Biden knows he beat him before he thinks
he can do it again so all eyes all is on
Tuesday next week
days of protest by Extinction rebellion
and other groups gets underway today
dumped the big one tens of thousands of
campaigners are expected to gather in
the capital all weekend so let's find
out what's planned our correspondent
Rachel venables joins me now from
Central London so Rachel what exactly
are these groups
planning to do and what do they want to
achieve
well Extinction Rebellion hoped that
somewhere between 40 150 000 activists
will turn up at some point over the next
at various points over the next four
days for this huge protest which has
been many months in the making and it
started at seven o'clock this morning
although it really gets underway in a
few hours time they've got an opening
ceremony planned at around mid morning
10 30 outside Parliament there'll be
speeches and events and debates and
discussions really what they're trying
to achieve with this I think is to
demonstrate to the British government
just how many people support them and
their aims not just individuals but
organizations as well they say for the
first time they've had a number of
different groups sign up to support
their aims and actions including Friends
of the earth Greenpeace and the PCS
union now you'll be able to see a bit of
activity behind me here I'm stood
outside defra at the department for
environment food and Rural Affairs and
what they've been doing is what they
call People's pickets so outside
government buildings throughout
Whitehall you'll be able to see small
pockets of extinct Rebellion activists
this morning they're adamant they're not
doing anything disruptive they're not
stopping people from going to work but
they are trying to speak to civil
servants and approach any ministers who
happen to be coming in and out of work
today and now it's important to remember
of course Extinction Rebellion the group
who we know have in the past caused huge
disruption to Central London they've
blockaded bridges in 2018 they parked a
big pink boat in Oxford Circus and we
also know they want sprayed fake blood
all over the treasury but back in
January they made a statement saying
that they were pausing those widespread
disruptive actions acknowledging that
they hadn't worked so I'll have to wait
and see whether they stick to that
promise over the next four days it must
be said they've stressed they have no
plans to disrupt the London Marathon
which is taking place on Sunday just
stop oil and other climate activist
group and animal Rebellion who recently
have disrupted the likes of the World
Snooker Championship and the Grand
National respectively also putting out
statements saying they have no plan
plans to affect the race
okay Rachel thanks very much indeed
now when you call a restaurant to make a
reservation you don't expect a prince to
answer the phone but that's exactly what
happened to one unsuspecting customer
who called an Indian restaurant in
Birmingham or The Prince and the
Princess of Wales were visiting
[Laughter]
yeah is that does that work for you not
right now no apparently
well when the customers arrived at the
restaurant an hour later they said they
had no idea that it was William that
took the call but they did say it was a
nice surprise
now then the UK's traditional Pig breeds
are at risk of dying out as the British
pork industry continues to shrink the
rare breeds survival trust has worn that
the future of the UK's native Pig breeds
is becoming increasingly insecure so
let's discuss this a little bit further
I'm joined Now by Susan Tanner who's an
owner and breeder of rare pigs a very
good morning to you Susan Tanner thanks
so much for talking to us um now as I
understand it you've got Oxford Sandy
and black breed pigs is that right tell
us a little bit about those breeds and
why you've chosen to rear them
yes they are a rare breed traditional
and I chose them because they are a very
good pork producer but also they're very
docile and um they're very very pretty
to look at
well yeah and we've seen these reports
that there is a risk that those classic
traditional British Pig breeds are dying
out why is that and how worried are you
about it
well the the pig industry is difficult
at the moment anyway but for Rare Breed
breeders you're often very small very
niche market and pig food has gone up in
extremely you've got other costs the
same as other pig breeders but straw and
everything has gone up and also I think
people don't realize that if you buy
rare breeds you have to eat them to keep
them so we rely on the public to buy our
pork and buy the wieners so that we can
actually carry on breeding these these
really traditional breeds
well yes and why is the pig industry in
a difficult situation as you put it it
is shrinking isn't it why do you think
that is
it
it's very difficult to generalize across
everybody but but for us I think it's
that the pig prices
um for food and all the things that you
need have gone up so much and people I
think don't value that Rare Breed meat
and Rare Breed registered pigs are
actually very valuable and the prices of
them sometimes don't reflect that and I
think we have to sort of increase you
can hear them in the background can you
you can need to reflect that and it's
important that we carry on breathing
leads these particular pigs
it sounds like your pigs want to have a
word and join in the conversation you
talk about them being valuable and how
much does their survival matter to our
environment the ecosystem as well
very much so because a they are a
traditional Rare Breed we've had them
it's like Heritage buildings we've had
them for centuries Oxford Sandy and
blacks are the pigs that um have been
around as cottager pigs for centuries
you you need to keep them and preserve
them and also they are very sustainable
we work very carefully um with the land
we work in a in a good environment so
they are important they they are really
good for re-fertilizing land and also
um producing excellent meat low food
miles and Brilliant taste
okay well Susan Tanner and very good to
talk to you I don't know if you are able
to tilt your camera down just so we can
see your pigs who are wanting to join in
hmm
you can't see them at present
are we gonna see a pig
there we go
sorry we can see them now lovely um I
feel satisfied now Susan Tanner thanks
very much indeed for talking to us today
we do appreciate it thank you
now then time to give you a sports fix
Alex has got all the details Alex
this Sky News sports bulletin is brought
to you by Vitality getting more people
more active live life with vitality
foreign
coming out of University in the summer
of 20 2011 like I could see Reeves
corner on fire from my house I lived in
Croydon
um and then the rhetoric coming out from
the like the meteorites and stuff was
very much around like these young people
being bad kids and they're born this way
and it's like lock them up throw away
the key so it was almost like a Eureka
moment of I mean we need to do something
here we need to implement something to
try and help help the young people
change the rhetoric of what society's
believing about these young people I
come with the clinic when I was
15 16 years old to be found no I never
really liked School
wasn't of Interest I was more like a
practical more Hands-On
so um I wanted to get like more serious
into football and uh hopefully make it
pro it's always my dream because um
where I'm from as I have like two Roots
as I ever like
because I'm from a council estate so you
couldn't imagine her there's there's not
really uh no one really makes it out you
know Broken Dreams and a lot of us come
from broken Homes single parents and
things like that so I think it's
important that if it's like kinetic
hopefully there's a lot more like
kinetic can get a lot of people like me
out and help us along the way and
hopefully progress
if a young person is very talented they
typically won't value their education
particularly much when they're younger
sometimes in my opinion professional
clubs reinforce that by having day
release programs from very young Ages
which devalues an education for a young
person and then so when they might get
released or whatever age it is they're
also potentially not have much to fall
back on because they've kind of pinned
all their hopes on being being a
professional footballer when releases
happen and inevitably they do more often
than not from young people in clubs like
a Young Person's lost it they've lost
their identity and they're very
vulnerable so students that will come to
us or players that will come to us will
be releases over at 14 15 that come into
evening Community sessions
um maybe a bit lost on their pathway
maybe feeling that they're not good
enough and picking those kids up and
giving them regular training to get into
the groove again I suppose and finding
their love of the game but that the
education does come first and and that's
our end to every student as soon as they
come through the door is education this
guy News sports bulletin is brought to
you by vitality
foreign
breakfast we'll get more on those
protests in central London this weekend
[Music]
thank you
I'm Becky Johnson a Sky News
correspondent part of the teams based
here in the Midland
allegations of exploitation in
leicester's clothing factories aren't
new in fact it's been an Open Secret in
this city for years
[Music]
made for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain world
more and more stabbing and essentially I
think it's more my younger children
because a team we're not really
surprised by anything these days
so it's reports of a male who can stand
repeatedly in the leg
here in the diverse industrial heart of
England we hear from people who have
real stories to tell
our parents are going to complain like
this and schools better get ready for it
these protests are being organized
primarily by people who aren't parents
at the school
so some patients aren't going to survive
this we have to be prepared that
patients will die from from this illness
staff here at are currently identifying
wards that could be turned into in areas
where patients with covid-19 could be
isolated
[Music]
the river seven is still rising and
people here in Ironbridge have been told
it could go up by another meter before
it starts to go back down
it's going to be a long slow process of
putting it back together again we aim to
be the best and most trusted place for
news
foreign
[Music]
now climate protests have become
increasingly disruptive as activists
move away from more traditional
demonstrations resulting sometimes to
shock tactics to draw attention to their
cause so let's discuss this a little bit
further here with me is a former
conservative special advisor Lauren
mckevitt and environmental campaigner
donica McCarthy so welcome to both of
you good to see you both Danica to you
first of all you're a member of
Extinction Rebellion as I understand it
is that right um I'm a supporter a
supporter so what do you know of what
the plans are for the protest over this
week
um what they're doing is a mass peaceful
protest in London thirty thousand two
hundred thousand people they've got two
main major demands certain assemblies
and most importantly the top demand is
the government should stop investing in
new fossil fuels the UN General
Secretary has said investment in new
fossil fuels is economic and moral
Madness so therefore what the what this
protest is doing is pulling the
emergency court and saying to the
government stop turbocharging not say
oil because it's actually a a
threatening the survival of humanity
okay so that's the message what about
the London marathon though on Sunday
because as we understand it the the race
organizer said he's received unique
assurances from uh Extinction Rebellion
that it won't be targeted that's what
you understand that's been a non-story
for for six to eight months they have
both agreed there wouldn't have been any
protests it's not an issue but what's
the actual doing they're actually saying
of course the the London Marathon has
many people running it who support
climate action and who support the the
aims of the today's protest and wish
that the government should take action
the idea that the government is actually
what is done since inacc has become um
Chancellor and prime minister it's
actually getting huge tax breaks to
North Sea oil and put a windfall tax on
Renewables and band we're the only
country in the world that spanned
onshore wind now that is surely criminal
Behavior okay and and the government
would no doubt if they were here defend
their record on those climate issues but
on the issue of a protest and what's
effective Lauren mckevitt do you welcome
the assurances from Extinction Rebellion
that they will leave the London Marathon
out of their protest this weekend
well I think it's probably one of the
most sensible things that they've done
because frankly what I think extension
Rebellion have ended up doing to
themselves and just stop oil are in the
the same category as this is they've
alienated a huge chunk of people within
middle England who actually
fundamentally agree with a lot of what
they're saying people who live in for
example rural communities who say well
you know what I have noticed the climate
changing my farming neighbor has changed
200-year planting schedules on the basis
of rains changing so of course I
recognize that the climate has changed
but super gluing yourself to Motorway or
bringing London to a standstill neither
of these are options that actually win
over heart and Minds to your argument
particularly when you abuse statistics
to the extent that Extinction Rebellion
do they often point to the 8.5 RC RCP
figure which is not a forecast it is a
model being used by ipcc if nothing
changes then indeed coal consumption
goes up so as long as Extinction
Rebellion are using study statistics and
are blocking up Hospital routes in
central London my own father was blocked
by 20 minutes going into a diabetic coma
going to a hospital by Extinction
rebellion in 2019 so I can't stand these
people because they put him at risk and
I think many people are in the same camp
as me what would you say to that well
the lady says she is concerned about
people in ambulances absolutely right
orbitatory government's record and
ambulances hundreds of people every
month dying because of lack of ambulance
services so this is this is a Canard the
any protest will occupy a street any
protest will actually cause a
interruption in a city so the idea that
that's a Canard what we need to focus on
is actually for example the 30 million
people in Sudan facing death from
starvation and the 33 million people in
Pakistan suffering from from flooding so
that's where the real concern should be
sorry yeah the UK the UK the UK's carbon
emissions globally are 0.93 at the end
of 2021 as percentage of overall carbon
emissions the cannot here is pointing to
ambulance times in the Tory government
and not extinct to Rebellion blocking
ambulance Roots
is also going to Sudan and not the UK we
only have 30 seconds Lauren what does
make effective protests then just just
Marching In the Street peacefully the
politicians actually listen to that very
briefly
no they don't Lobby your members of
parliament bring them legitimate
statistics that you're concerned about
don't start falsifying ipcc's models
instead of actual legitimate forecasts
bring logic and reason to the table and
don't just you know participate in what
is extended performance art on the
Streets of London okay we are social to
time but Danica and Lauren we really
appreciate your time thanks both so much
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hello everyone it's eight o'clock you're
watching Sky News break first he's one
of the prime minister's most loyal
supporters now Dominic Robb's fate is in
the hands of Rishi sunak would he stay
or will he go lots of questions this
morning as we await the prime minister's
decision after reviewing allegations
that his Deputy bullied officials the
transport secretary Mark Harper told me
the PM will want to reach a swift
conclusion but he won't commit to a time
frame we'll have Labor's reaction later
on this hour
plus we have the remarkable story of 15
children taken from Ukraine to Russia
who've escaped thanks to one exceptional
woman
it's Friday the 21st of April
awaiting his fate Dominic Robb's future
in the balance as Rishi Suna considers a
report into bullying allegations against
his deputy
all eyes on Downing Street this morning
as Rishi sunak decides the fate of one
of the people who helped him into power
the promise for taking the time to read
the report in detail before reaching
conclusion it's putting proper weight on
the complaints that have been made as
well as on the future of the Deputy
Prime Minister
charges are dropped against Alec Baldwin
over the fatal shooting of the set of
the movie rust
taken at gunpoint how 15 Ukrainian
orphans escaped from Russia and the
thousands of others left behind
ready to run President Biden will
formally announce his 2024 re-election
campaign as soon as next week
Sudan's paramilitary rapid support
forces say it's a reached an agreement
on a 72-hour truce in the fighting on
humanitarian grounds
I'm in central London where thousands of
climate activists are getting ready for
a four-day protest that'll cause huge
disruption they're calling it the big
one
Marathon motivation I'll speak to one of
the world's greatest athletes Ilia
chipchogi about the London marathon and
get a campaign to get kids moving
and they called it
oh I guess they'll never know and I'll
be joined by the pop Legend Donny Osmond
who's touring the UK for the first time
in six years
and why I love a song
[Music]
hello a very good morning Dominic Robb
is awaiting his fate this morning the
prime minister is deciding on Mr Robb's
future after the conclusion of a
long-awaited investigation into bullying
allegations against his Deputy the
report was handed to number 10 yesterday
morning and Mr ramp has promised to quit
if he was found to have bullied staff
well earlier I spoke to the transport
secretary Mark Harper and he told me the
PM would want to reach a decision as
quickly as possible but he wouldn't be
drawn on when
there's a balanced strike here about
taking the time to get it right and of
course as you've reflected in your
report there are lots of other things uh
that the Prime Minister has to focus on
as well as this I think also you've got
to remember that there were serious
complaints that were made and I think
it's also worth remembering this you
know the media reporting obviously
focuses on
um the future of the Deputy Prime
Minister but you know there were people
involved here who have made serious
complaints and I think you've got to be
fair to them as well and I think it's by
treating this seriously the Primus for
taking the time to read the report in
detail before reaching the conclusion
it's putting proper weight on the
complaints that have been made as well
as on the future of the Deputy Prime
Minister
well I also spoke to the assistant
general secretary of the civil servants
Union the FDA Amy levisage she thinks
some people are going to question the
point of making a complaint if the
system doesn't seem fair
and that's what I think people are going
to be fearing uh last night and today
that what we're going to see is history
repeats itself we're going to see
political considerations come first and
and
that will then have a chilling effect
across the Civil Service and you know
this isn't uh you know we this isn't
just one or two bad apples here we had a
report that showed that one in six
senior civil servants had witnessed the
unacceptable behaviors just in the last
year alone and these behaviors are
really quite widespread and we do need
to have a moment where we say this isn't
appropriate in no other workplace in the
land would you get away with this kind
of behavior
well let's across the Downing Street now
a political correspondent Rob Powell is
there for us this morning so Rob
um 24 hours on essentially and still no
decision from the prime minister
yeah no update no guarantees from Mark
Harper that that report will even be
published along with Richard sunax
decision by the close of play today Mark
Harper saying that the Prime Minister
would want to come to a swift conclusion
but was also taking the time to make
sure that he gets this right I think the
nature of the report that's been
compiled by the Barrister Adams Holly
means that a delay like this was always
more likely than in other inquiries of a
similar nature that's because it's only
setting out the facts of what happened
he's spoken to a couple of dozen uh
complainants eight complaints in total
so it's likely to be an extensive piece
of work and then it's for the prime
minister to make his mind up about
whether the ministerial code has been
reached and whether Dominic Rob can stay
in his job so it's different to previous
inquiries where there has actually been
a judgment taken in the report about
whether the code has been broken which
of course allows which is sunak to act a
bit more swiftly it does though suggest
I think that this may not be completely
clear because while we've heard
anonymous from several civil servants
that have alleged that Dominic Raab as
they view it definitely did bully them
others have said that yes while he may
be a tricky customer actually they've
questioned whether it amounts to
bullying or just being a difficult and
demanding boss I think that ambiguity
really raises political risk for Rishi
sunak though because if he decides to
get rid of his Deputy Prime Minister
people will question why he brought him
into government in the first place if he
doesn't then he potentially faces civil
servants from the ministry of Justice
quitting their jobs or even speaking
publicly I thought it was interesting
though that Mark Harper very much
downplaying the idea that Rishi sunak
could essentially commission another
investigation get his ethics advisor to
advise him whether the code has been
broken Mark Harper the transport
secretary saying that fundamentally this
was the decision for the prime minister
okay Rob we wait for that decision still
and we'll be back to you if it comes for
the moment though thank you
and in the meantime let's get a view on
this I'm joined Now by former head of
press at Downey Street Giles kenningham
a very good morning to you thanks so
much for talking to us so the Prime
Minister has had this report as we
understand it since yesterday morning
and yet still no decision on Dominic
raab's future what do you make of the
delay I think it says two things one
that it isn't clear-cut the report
um and it's very long he's working his
way through it and two that he's trying
to find a way of keeping Dominic Robb
but he is facing his big political
conundrum I mean Rob is one of his
closest political allies one of his
staunches supporters and you know
remember Rob stuck with him during the
leadership campaign with trust when it
was clear that trust
um was was going to win so yeah very
difficult decision to remember if Rob
has to go this will be the third cabinet
resignation since sunac took over
um you know which by anyone's standards
is is pretty problematic
well yes and you mentioned the fact that
uh Dominic Raab has been a staunch Ally
of the Prime Minister how mindful then
do you think the Prime Minister will be
of that when he makes this decision and
also about the reaction more broadly
within the conservative party and
perhaps mindful of how different
factions might react yeah exactly like
he'll be wanting to show that
um Rob has been given a sense of natural
Justice that he hasn't been thrown under
the bus
um I think the indication that this
isn't a clear decision is kind of
brought out by the fact look how quickly
he got rid of Nadeem Sahari
um uh after the report came back there
he was gone I think you know within a
few hours so I think other issues for
for sunac is really this is happening it
seems to be in a bit of a news vacuum
it's leading news bulletins
um you know there is intense scrutiny
from the Press so
um you know I I think he's going to um
probably have to come to a decision
today otherwise you're going to have two
or three more days of this this brought
out and effectively you know the draft
from the work of government
how much of a test is this for Richie
sinak making this call
yeah no it's a big test that he has said
that you know that he wanted to bring
back Integrity accountability
transparency back to government so you
know everything he's got to do have got
to be consistent with those values so
you know I think the fact that this is
taking them a while this is taking them
a long time would suggest that it's not
clear-cut and they want to keep keep
wrong but as you said
um we don't they're all the unknowns in
this you like you say we'll do it you
know buy these civil servants are going
to speak out
um what's in there are they going to
publish the report is he going to face
pressure there as well
um uh and clearly you know there's
pressure on him to come to a decision
he's not been given an answer one way or
another all this report is done it's
just laid out the facts for him to make
a judgment call
and if he decides that Dominic Robb does
have to go how damaging would it be to
him and to the party I mean Dominic Rob
will be the third Minister forced to go
in richly soon like it's very short
tenure if that is the way that the Prime
Minister decides to go
yeah I'll tell you these drip drip drip
uh stories these resignations you know
do tarnish the brand
um you know at a time when
um Cena was you know very much trying to
sort of carve out a fresh start a fresh
a fresh mandate for the party and it
will be you know
um it will be a free hit for the labor
party so it is very difficult but as you
said there are lots of different
considerations here as you said the Tory
party is a series of Delica coalitions
of course if he does go is the prime
minister a little bit more weakened yes
because you know this is a deputy prime
minister this is as I said one of his
political
um closest political allies you know
this is a person who soon brought back
into government so if he does go the
questions will be asked why did you
bring them back when these allegations
were swirling in the background
okay well Charles Cunningham very
interesting to get your take on it all
as we await that verdict from the Prime
Minister thanks very much indeed thank
you
now prosecutors have dropped involuntary
manslaughter charges against the actor
Alec Baldwin over a fatal short shooting
on the set of the movie rust the
decision came after new evidence emerged
on the gun that fired the shot that
killed cinematographer Helena Hutchins
he's our U.S correspondent mother
Kellner
in the place known as Montana's Paradise
Valley a project resurrected production
on the film rust is restarting 18 months
after Helena Hutchins was shot dead on a
set hundreds of miles from here as the
film's star Alec Baldwin did final
rehearsals he was told involuntary
manslaughter charges against him in
connection with hutchin's death had been
dropped Alec Baldwin and other members
of the cast and crew of rust were doing
last minute preparations here when news
came through that those charges which
were filed in New Mexico had been
dropped a preliminary trial was due to
starting just two weeks time so this was
an incredibly dramatic intervention
and for those preparing to resume
filming a note of relief so Alec is a
consummate professional and I think we
had every confidence in his ability to
act within the movie regardless of
what's going on in any aspect of his
personal life I would say probably
um for everyone else it's a good outcome
in the sense that we feel that justice
has been served Baldwin posted a picture
with wife Hilaria on Instagram I owe
everything I have to this woman he wrote
and to You Luke he put in Brackets
presumably a reference to his lawyer
Luke Nikas
the top of the Spire of a church is all
that's visible of Yellowstone film Ranch
from the public Road
a poignant reminder that it was while
rehearsing a scene in a church that
Helena Hutchins was shot dead the bullet
lodged in the shoulder of the film's
director Joel Souza a year and a half
later he returned to the set alongside
other members of the original cast and
crew
as part of a wrongful death settlement
Helena Hutchins widower Matthew Hutchins
has become an executive producer on Rust
there are still at least five
outstanding civil lawsuits against
Baldwin and the other producers of rust
but the Hollywood veteran will now
finish this film an actor and not a
criminal defendant Martha calners Sky
News Montana
still come here on the show I'm going to
be talking to the Ukrainian MP Kiera
ruddick about a special report on how 15
Ukrainian orphans escaped from the
Russians
also ahead of Harper's aide I'll be
joined by the shadow Health secretary
Wes streeting
and I'll be joined by an autistic
athlete competing in Sunday's London
Marathon who's raising awareness about
the condition
foreign
also making the news this morning
Sudan's rapid support forces have agreed
to a 72-hour ceasefire it'll coincide
with Eid and the group claims
humanitarian corridors will be opened to
allow citizens to evacuate the foreign
secretary James cleverley has cut short
his Pacific tour to focus on
coordinating Britain's response to the
Sudan crisis
the school's Watchdog ofsted has said it
will make changes following the suicide
of head teacher Ruth Perry in January
but its Chief Inspector has refused to
bow to pressure to drop one word
assessments which range from outstanding
to inadequate
Ruth Perry's sister Julia Waters said
that the Watchdog failed to provide a
meaningful response to calls for change
She's accused ofsted's Chief Inspector
of attempting to defend the indefensible
Olivia Pratt corbell's murderer Thomas
Cashman could have his 42-year prison
sentence increased after complaints that
it was too lenient the 34 year old fired
shots into nine-year-old Olivia's family
home in Liverpool in August last year
during what prosecutors described as a
ruthless pursuit to execute another man
now retail sales have taken a big hit in
March down 0.9 percent after rising in
both January and February well our
business presenter Ian King joins us now
from the city so in how much of a
disappointment will these figures be
I think you have to uh take this into
context down and don't forget that March
was incredibly rainy it was uh arguably
the rainiest March in 40 years going
further back it was actually the sixth
rainiest March in records going all the
way back to 1836 so clearly uh whenever
it rains very heavily that is not good
news for retailers and that appears to
have been what happened in this
particular case the office for National
statistics making clear that uh sales in
in Outlets such as department stores and
garden centers were particularly uh
badly hit now we're talking here about
retail sales volumes which is the amount
of stuff that fell by as you say 0.9
compared with uh February uh growth of
0.6 retail sales values which is the
value of items being bought well they
also contracted by 0.9 having grown by
1.1 percent during February so I think
that's actually quite interesting I mean
that potentially tells you that there
may be a a sign or two of inflation
coming down because volumes and values
by the same amount and that was
certainly not the case in in February
where they both Rose at a differing
degrees so an interesting little detail
to pick up on there in terms of the
breakdown food volumes were off by point
seven percent non-food by 1.3 so again
that really tells you that the weather
was playing a part in terms of stopping
people getting out to outlets such as
garden centers these figures of course
come before the Easter period they go up
from the from the 26th of February to
the first of April so they don't take in
to account the school holidays around
the Easter break we'll get more on that
uh next month of course but I think what
it does tell you as well is that things
are quite tough out there but clearly I
think I think the weather was a a key
factor here on the plus side uh for the
first three months of the year now uh
retail sales volumes actually Rose by
0.6 and that was actually the first
quarterly rise in retail sales volumes
going all the way back to August 2021
and that confirms really what we knew
already that January and February
actually were probably better for the
retail sector than there had been uh
previously anticipated and that uh soggy
showing in March didn't really uh bring
the numbers down for the whole quarter
as a whole
okay Ian thanks very much indeed
now 15 Ukrainian orphans have told Sky
News how they were taken at gunpoint by
Russian soldiers removed from their
Homeland and illegally transferred to
Russia before making a remarkable escape
to freedom and to safety our
International Affairs editor Dominic
wyckorn reports now on Ukraine's missing
children
thousands of children have been taken
from Ukraine by the Russians in this war
this is the story of 15 who escaped
their clutches
[Music]
their ordeal lasted five months and took
them a thousand miles but they have
finally reached Freedom thanks to one
remarkable woman
was the director of their orphanage in
southern Ukraine when Russian forcets
arrived because
we know from CCTV footage taken in
another orphanage how the Russian
military has searched for children in
this war Natalia begged the Russians to
let her children go
foreign
the day the soldiers came was filmed by
Russian State tv the footage doesn't
show what the children say happened that
they pleaded not to be taken and the
Russians fired their guns to make the
move
14 year old Dasher describes those
frightening moments
um
they say they were moved against their
will at gunpoints a clear violation of
the laws of war taken from their
orphanage to another in the village of
stephanievka 150 miles Behind Enemy
Lines then the Russians move them again
as they retreated across the danipra
river fifteen-year-old stas says he
feared for the worst
so maybe
[Music]
he was right to be worried they were
heading for Russia taken through one
city after another in Russian occupied
Crimea then across the Kirch Straits and
over the Border
Natalya's worst fears have come true
this is the Fate that could have awaited
them Sky News has found evidence of
Ukrainian children being deported deep
into Russia some are given to Russian
families in these pictures in a city two
and a half thousand miles from home
now this is sent to camps where we know
children are indoctrinated in putanist
ideology and trained in the use of
weapons
and they're being exploited for
propaganda purposes too in events
presided over by Vladimir Putin himself
the children being made to hug this
Russian soldier are from mariupole a
city destroyed by Putin's military
the Russians say they're rescuing
children from war
but both Putin and his children's rights
commissioner have now been indicted by
the international criminal court for the
war crime of deporting children charges
they've both rejected foreign
but this British war crimes investigator
whose senior evidence says moscow's
claims do not stand scrutiny this is a
clear conditioning of children for
nefarious purposes I think it goes to
the overall criminal plan which is to
extinguish extinguish Ukrainian identity
so we're talking about cultural genocide
and we're also talking about physical
genocide
our 15 orphans Journey ended an escape
from Russia slipping across the border
and finding sanctuary in Georgia
they recall the moments they made it to
Freedom
is
they're now waiting until it's safe
enough to go back home against the odds
Natalia has kept her word and led them
to safety is
foreign
Sky News Tbilisi Georgia
let's get some reaction to that report
Ukrainian MP Kara Roddick joins us now
from Kiev thanks so much for joining us
Akira Roddick what do you make of this
report
hello Anna thank you so much for having
me you know it's very hard to keep and
hold of Tears when you're watching
something like this since the beginning
of the full scale Invasion
um we confirmed that over 150
um Ukrainian children
uh were deported unlawfully to Russia
and uh 308 children have been returned
recently using all our uh all kinds of
diplomacy and exchanges and it is
extremely significant that these
particular crimes of Putin and his
Ombudsman of human rights have been
documented and were a reason for the
warrant for the arrest not the total
Destruction that Russia creates in
Ukraine not uh the full list of war
crimes that they the Army have committed
here but the fact that they are
unlawfully taking children and it's not
something that you can hide it is
something that it has been proven this
person Mariah she was proud that she has
adopted a Ukrainian
teenager from mariopo and she was very
open about that and how she have taken
him she said well I just took him and
this is why all her claims that the
crimes cannot be proved they can be
proved particularly by her own words so
this is one of the most frustrating and
heartbreaking
aspects of the war the children who
cannot defend themselves protect
themselves are being taken against their
will to be raised as Russians and this
is something that my nation would not be
able to recover in Generations because
uh most of these kids they have their
life parents that are searching for them
they don't know what happened with them
and they have no access to to their kids
that are right now in Russia have new
names have new families and it will take
decades for us to restore the Justice in
this matter
Russia isn't denying that they're
transporting children into Russia but
they say they're doing this for the good
of the children they're offering them
Sanctuary from the horrors of War
well the country that have started the
war that have come to destroy us is
saying oh but we are saving the children
this is uh this is like does not come
into my mind does not add up at all uh
and uh we are doing everything possible
from our side to evocate children from
the war zones or potential War zones to
keep them saved however when Russia is
occupying particular City this is the
first thing that they are doing they are
taking children and uh and moving them
back to Russia this is one kind of the
crimes and war crimes and goes against
the rule of War however we know that
Russia does not go with any of the war
rules that
um that uh exist right now and we do not
have very high expectations on that they
will try to commit to them
I'm just getting a little bit of
breaking news I'm being told that Yen
stoltenberg of NATO has said that NATO
allies have agreed that Ukraine will
become a NATO member that's news just
saying I understand that that's what he
says what's your reaction to that oh
there's a this fantastic news it's a
very high hope of Ukrainian people the
um the ability to be a member of EU a
member of NATO is something that is
written in Ukrainian Constitution
however I will be very interested in
timing we understand that European
security uh is and the world Democratic
security is impossible without Ukraine
right now especially that we do have the
largest army that have an experience in
full-scale work in fighting however the
question is what would be the process
and when would this happen I have no
doubt Ukraine will join NATO but we need
for it to happen earlier rather than
later and we need to see a clear path to
that
okay well Kira Roddick thanks for your
reaction to that news and we appreciate
your time this morning thanks very much
indeed thank you and glory to Ukraine
don't check on the weather now
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the next few days look colder and
more unsettled but Northern parts will
stay largely fine today it's mostly dry
out there now if chilly but cloud and
rain is spreading across the South that
rain will Edge further west across
Southern Britain during the morning with
some sunshine and showers following but
Cornwall should stay fine elsewhere
expect plenty of sunshine but the south
of Ireland will see increasing cloud and
it's going to be colder than recently in
the South still on the warm side for the
North
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
with this coming on Sky News breakfast
[Applause]
Elon musk's huge Starship spacecraft
gets off the ground but not for terribly
long
[Music]
foreign
rocket ever made destined eventually to
take NASA astronauts back into space
[Applause]
well after an aborted attempt early this
week the SpaceX Starship lifted off from
Texas to huge cheers carrying its next
Generation Starship Cruise vehicle it
was on calls for a 90-minute uncrewed
test flight and all was going very well
for the first phase of the flight
entire Starship stack continuing to
rotate we should have had Separation by
now obviously this is uh does not appear
to be a nominal situation
thank you
but as you can see it exploded four
minutes later and fell back to earth
when two sections failed to separate
Elon Musk and the SpaceX team say
they've learned a lot and have hopes
that it'll one day be used to take
people to Mars
now four days of protest by Extinction
rebellion and other groups gets underway
today dubbed the big one tens of
thousands of campaigners are expected to
gather throughout Central London all
weekend including on the day of the
London Marathon well earlier the
transport secretary told me disrupting
the marathon would be unfair on those
participating
I would be appalled if that was
disrupted you know there are thousands
of people that take part in that race
who are who will have trained all year
who are raising money for charity and I
think it would be appalling if it was
disrupted so that's the the first point
the second point is the protesters I
think have got completely the wrong
target here they're making very serious
point about climate change Britain is
one of the countries in this government
is one of the governments that's leading
the the fight against climate change
well let's cross to our correspondent
Rachel venables now so Rachel what
exactly are these protesters planning
then this weekend
well they've called it the big one this
is a protest that has been many months
if not years in the planning Extinction
Rebellion are telling me they hope that
somewhere between 40 and 50 000
activists will descend on Westminster
the streets around Parliament over the
next four days for this huge protest
which they say is designed at really
getting a message across to the
government they want the government to
commit to ending Reliance on fossil
fuels and also to work closer with them
when it comes to tackling climate change
into the future now this is the group of
course in the past who have caused huge
disruption not just here in London but
across the country they've blockaded
Bridges they've sprayed government
buildings with fake paint they've
smashed the glass windows of major Banks
and they've also we know in the past
Parts a big pink boat on Oxford Street
and blockaded that major shopping area
in central London that was back in 2018
but in January they announced the end of
their public disturbance and they didn't
want to keep at causing a nuisance to
members of the public and they said
instead they were they've taken really a
message on board and instead they were
going to be focusing on really the
corridors of power and that's why
they're here starting early this morning
outside defra the department for
environment food and Rural Affairs
you'll be able to see a few dozen people
gathered here they called it a people's
picket and this scene is repeated
outside government buildings throughout
Westminster as they're standing outside
trying to engage with civil servants and
ministers as they go in and out as
you've been mentioning already of course
the London marathon is also happening
this weekend that is on Sunday there
have been real concerns that the
marathon could be disrupted but
certainly so far Extinction Rebellion
have been pledging and promising no
plans to disrupt that Marathon
hey Rachel and thanks very much indeed
well let me bring in now Labor's Shadow
Health secretary Wes streetings here
with me very good morning good morning
good to see you let's start with
Extinction Rebellion shall we they are
planning four days of protest as we have
from our correspondent there across the
capital this weekend do you support them
I I think like most people in this
country I want to see more action on
climate change in fact Labor's got a
bold and ambitious plan that would
deliver hugely towards achieving Net
Zero but also helping bring down
people's bills deliver our energy
security by racing towards
um a net zero bubbling a green energy
superpower and I think I think those are
the sorts of solutions our country needs
I think what some of those tactics and
some of those protesters do is actually
really self-defeating because I think
most people in this country are worried
about their bills they can see the
argument as to how building more
renewable energy new nuclear uh you know
expanding Britain's energy domestic
energy Supply and production would
deliver more jobs and bring down bills
and help achieve Net Zero I think the
case the argument's one certainly as far
as labor is concerned and when people go
about disrupting other people's lives
rather than building a bigger tent with
more supporters they end up alienating
people and that's my problem with their
tactics presumably you support peaceful
protests though so what's your message
to them this weekend I I think there are
ways of grabbing attention without
causing disruption to people's lives and
when they do that they actually alienate
people and push people away from a cause
which I think is crucial to our
country's future to our planet's future
so I you know any campaigner worth their
salt will be thinking how do we build
the tent of support how do we grow the
coalition to force decision makers into
action that's how pressure groups can be
most effective what what they're doing
it may sometimes grab the headlines but
often for all the wrong reasons and
alienate people from the cause and
that's not surely not what they want and
briefly if you can because you've got
lots of other things to talk about are
you worried about the London Marathon
being disrupted I really hope it's not
people train for the London Marathon
whether they are Elite athletes or
people who were doing it to set a
personal Target or to raise money for
brilliant causes right across the
country so don't disrupt the marathon it
goes right back to the heart of what I
was just saying you know Marathon
disruption it might dominate the
headlines it will turn people off in
terms of the cause and let down all of
those Runners and their supporters
cheering them on who want a great day
out and an opportunity to raise loads of
money for good causes and I should say
Extinction Rebellion says that they
won't we'll see what other groups decide
over the weekend but let's move to what
we have as our top story today and this
is the prime minister deliberating about
a Dominic rap his deputies future having
received the report that's been drawn up
over the allegations of bullying against
him what do you make of the fact that
we've had no decision even though as we
understand it the prime minister's had
this report since yesterday morning well
it tells us there's certainly a case to
answer I've got to say rishi's doing
that it's got no one to blame but
himself these allegations were hanging
in the air when Dominic Robb was
appointed Deputy Prime Minister indeed I
would argue Dominic Robb shouldn't have
been given the the job on the basis he
was on a sun lounger during the
evacuation of Kabul when diplomats and
members of armed forces working really
hard to have to to evacuate people from
Afghanistan so I don't think Dominic
Robb should be in the job and I think
you know the day that Rishi sunak has
spent deliberating on the future of one
person is a day he should have spent
deliberating on how to tackle the
biggest crisis in the history of the NHS
or how to deliver Justice on Art streets
or or how to tackle the cost of living
crisis which is which is soaring in
terms of food prices and the pain in
people's pockets well there are clearly
a lot of issues that he is dealing with
however it's not unreasonable is it for
him to take his time over what is no
doubt a detailed report after all Adam
Tolley has spent five months drawing it
together and it also involves the career
of of somebody he works with it's fair
enough that he should take its time
isn't it I think certainly the process
has got to be fair to the individual and
to the people who put in complaints
certainly my anxiety is that what Rishi
sunak is deliberate writing on isn't the
substance of the report but the politics
of this whether or not he's going to
stand by what he said outside Downing
Street about restoring trust and
standards in public life or whether or
not he's going to be strong enough to
stand up to people in his own party he
would he would inevitably upset if he
sacks Dominic Rob and I do think Rishi
sunat's got form for weakness he
appointed swella Braverman as Home
Secretary even though she had been fired
for a national security breach this is
not a strong leader able to stand up to
the right of his party would you like to
see the prime minister's ethics advisor
Laurie Magnus take a look at this report
that that may be helpful to the prime
minister in informing his judgment But
ultimately the Prime Minister has got to
make a decision he can't keep on
dithering and delaying or passing the
buck to someone else ultimately it's
it's on him it's his judgment as to who
he points to high office and who he
dismisses and I'm afraid he's got a
really poor track record of putting
people who are not good enough in some
of the highest offices in the land well
Dominic Rob has maintained as far as
this issue is concerned that he's
behaved professionally throughout as we
understand that he continues to maintain
that do you think you've seen any
evidence to dispute that uh well
obviously I I don't have the pleasure if
that's the right word of working with
Dominic rub in the in the ministry of
justice but those allegations as I say
were hanging around when he was first
appointed I do think we need to take
issues of of bullying in the workplace
seriously and I've never worked in an
environment where if people are bullied
you they get you get the best out of
them any good leader any good manager
will tell you that the best workplaces
the most productive workplaces are those
where people feel supported and
motivated inspired to do their very best
work and that never happens in a in an
environment where they're subject to
bullying or intimidation okay well no
doubt we'll get your reaction when we do
hear the uh prime minister's decision
and we see that Rapport but for the
moment worst treating thanks very much
thank you
now President Biden is set to finally
announce that he'll run for a second
term as soon we think as next week
officials say no formal timetable has
yet been confirmed but they're looking
at the 25th of April which is the
anniversary of Mr Biden's 2020 campaign
announcement our U.S correspondent Mark
Stone has the details
yes well it is surely one of the most
anticipated announcements here in
Washington DC for for weeks and weeks
and weeks now there's been so much
speculation over whether or not
President Biden would seek a a second
term he's hinted so many times that he'd
like to but he would consult with his
family I think some expected that that
consultation with with his nearest and
dearest would would um perhaps mean that
he'd decide not to run again after all
he is 80 years old now um that certainly
is an attack point for Republicans it is
without doubt a concern for Democrats
but the expectation now um from sources
speaking to our colleagues at NBC News
it does seem clear that next week
Tuesday we will discover that yes Joe
Biden does seek a second term yes he
does believe he has got a lot yet still
to accomplish and no he does not believe
he is too old crucially I think he has
made a judgment that the possible
probable Republican Party candidate will
be Donald Trump Joe Biden knows he beat
him before he thinks he can do it again
so all eyes all is on Tuesday next week
let's find out what's happening in the
Sports World here's Alex for you
the Sky News sports bulletin is brought
to you by Vitality getting more people
more active live life with vitality
coming out of University in the summer
of 20 2011 like I could see Reeves
corner I'm far from a house I lived in
Croydon
um and then the rhetoric coming out from
the a lot of media acts and stuff is
very much around like these young people
being bad kids and they're born this way
and it's like lock them up throw away
the key so it's almost like a Eureka
moment of we need to do something here
we need to implement something to try
and help help the young people change
the rhetoric of what society's believing
about these young people I come with the
connect when I was
15 16 years old to be found I never
really liked School
wasn't of Interest I was more like a
practical more more Hands-On
so um I wanted to get like more serious
into football and uh hopefully make it
pro it's always my dream because um
where I'm from as I have like two Roots
as ever like
because I'm from a council estate so you
couldn't imagine her there's there's not
really uh no one really makes it out you
know Broken Dreams and a lot of us come
from broken Homes single parents and
things like that so I think it's
important that if it's like kinetic
hopefully there's a lot more like
kinetic can get a lot of people like me
out and help us along the way and
hopefully progress if a young person is
very talented
um they typically won't value their
education particularly much when they're
younger
um sometimes in my opinion professional
clubs reinforce that by having day
release programs from very young Ages
which devalues an education for a young
person and then so when they might get
released or whatever age it is they're
also potentially not have much to fall
back on because they've kind of pinned
all their hopes on being being a
professional footballer and when
releases happen and inevitably they do
more often than not from young people in
clubs like a young person has lost it
they've lost their identity and they're
very vulnerable so students that will
come to us or players that will come to
us will be releases over at 14 15 that
come into evening Community sessions
um maybe a bit lost on their pathway
maybe feeling that they're not good
enough and picking those kids up and
giving them regular training to get into
the groove again I suppose and finding
the love of the game but that the
education does come first and and that's
our angle to every student as soon as
they come through the door is education
comes first we will provide you with
everything that you want and need on a
football pitch but you need to commit to
the the Sky News sports bulletin is
brought to you by vitality
foreign
first I'm going to be joined by an
autistic athlete competing in Sunday's
London Marathon who's raising awareness
about the condition
[Music]
thank you
I'm Becky Johnston a Sky News
correspondent part of the teams based
here in the Midland
allegations of exploitation in
leicester's clothing factories aren't
new in fact it's been an Open Secret in
this city for years
[Music]
made for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain world
we're getting more and more stabbing and
essentially I think it's more my younger
children because the team we're not
really surprised by anything these days
so there's reports of a male who can
stand repeatedly in the leg
here in the diverse industrial heart of
England we hear from people who have
real stories to tell
parents are going to complain like this
and schools but better get ready for it
these protests are being organized
primarily by people who aren't parents
at the school
so some patients aren't going to survive
this we have to be prepared that
patients will die from from this illness
staff here are currently identifying
wards that could be turned into in areas
where patients with covid-19 could be
isolated
the river 7 is still rising and people
here in Ironbridge have been told it
could go up by another meter before it
starts to go back down
it's going to be a long slow process of
putting it back together
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
now the London marathon is on Sunday
with tens of thousands of Runners taking
their marks now amongst them is the
autistic athlete Sam holner it's not
just a marathon runner but also an Iron
Man and triathlete and Sam and his
father and coach Tony join me now
welcome to both of you Sam first of all
tell me a little bit about how you
started doing Iron Man and Triathlon
events right I started we're doing a
drive from 2016.
and I've already a completed a 5 30.3
army races such as casca Holcomb Savage
Utah and nasarati
and two full image first First
Frankfurt Germany and secondary Kona
Hawaii wow that's quite a lot of
experience and what does the training
involve
a lot of hard work
you know it's like a full-time job yeah
I no nobody would work six days about
six days per week
with one recovery day
on hard days I suppose could be a 5k
swim that's 200 guys the 25 milligram
pool
uh
a five hour cycle or in a row on Swift
and uh a Verde K who run on a treadmill
on a 20 AK indoora
wow that sounds I'm exhausted listening
to you and you've received a huge number
of Walls you've got one around your neck
now the most recent is you've gone into
the Guinness book of records as the
first autistic person to complete the
Iron Man World Championship Triathlon so
what did that mean to you
oh it means oh that I didn't expect to
receive against the world record it was
so exciting I and it was and you're Keen
to encourage other people with Autism to
take part in uh triathlons and other
sporting events so what are the
challenges that people with Autism might
face when they take on this kind of
thing
oh
oh there are uh what quick question
oh it's the challenge oh oh there are so
many challenges if I was doing a try
afron first thing is the only to swim I
could swim before I started speaking at
six years old
I could swim so that I didn't want to
write a bike until I was 14. because
Burns in the book was difficult
how effective I think like people with
autistic can't do well I suppose because
many of us can't focus for your periods
without being distracted yes of course
and Tony I want to bring you in here
you've been very keen to encourage Sam
to do Sports what difference do you
think it's made it's been enormous I
think it's been life-changing for him
and for us as a family
um I think we started sport when
we found some research that said the
life expectancy in the UK of adults with
autism is under 54 years
and that's because of health reasons and
diet and so on so we decided that sport
had to be one of the ways to actually
help him to eat healthier and be
healthier and triathlins one as he
started off as a sort of bucket list and
it's just exploded into this wonderful
thing that he enjoys so great for his
physical health but what about managing
the autism does that make a difference
yeah I I think um so Sam as he said he
didn't speak till he was six years old
and he was swimming before he could and
I think it's the confidence that you get
from sport has helped with his
communication skills it's allowed him to
talk it's allowed to be a lot more fluid
to stand in front of people I mean three
or four years ago he couldn't have sat
this studio like this and had this
discussion and fantastic for anyone
watching in a similar situation a real
inspiration yeah I think um for all of
us I get up every morning and I look and
I see DMS from parents around the world
and I'm talking from South Africa Canada
everywhere saying we follow Sam simply
because he gives us hope for our
children and that's how my day starts
every day and the London marathon on
Sunday of course you'll be there
chairing them on I assume I tell you
what I will be every stride he takes
I'll be running with him and following
him on the app
but I think this one's a bit easier for
us because when he does a Iron Man for
example
um and we're in Hawaii he swam 3.8
kilometers out in the sea and then he
cycle 180 kilometers and we didn't see
him for over six hours that is scary
well I love the idea of the marathon
being the easy option but anyway
um a huge admiration for you Sam good
luck on Sunday thanks so much for coming
in and uh Tony his dad and Coach thanks
too thank you thank you thank you
well let's take a look at what the
weather holds
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the next few days look colder and
more unsettled but Northern parts will
stay largely fine today it's mostly dry
out there now if a bit chilly but cloud
and rain is spreading across the South
that rain will Edge further west across
Southern Britain during the morning with
some sunshine and showers following but
Cornwall should stay fine elsewhere
expect plenty of sunshine but the south
of Ireland will see increasing Cloud
it's going to be colder than recently in
the South but still on the warm side for
the north but blustery for many
Southern Britain and Ireland will see
afternoon showers some of them thundery
but more General rain will affect
Northern and Southwestern parts of
England elsewhere it'll stay mostly
sunny into the evening and rain will
push further north tonight while showers
largely fade but much of Scotland
luckily looks dry
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
coming up on the next hour of Sky News
breakfast Dominic raab's future still
hangs in the balance as the Prime
Minister considers a report into
bullying allegations against his Deputy
we'll bring you all the latest
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello everyone it's nine o'clock you're
watching Sky News breakfast he's one of
the prime minister's most loyal
supporters now Dominic raab's fate is in
the hands of Rishi sunak when he stay or
will he go lots of questions this
morning as we await the prime minister's
decision after reviewing allegations
that his Deputy bullied officials
the transport secretary Mark Harper
tells me the PM will want a swift
conclusion but he won't commit to a time
frame while Labor's Shadow Health
secretary says Mr sunac can't be
dithering and delaying plus we have the
remarkable story of 15 children taken
from Ukraine to Russia who've escaped
thanks to one exceptional woman it's
Friday the 21st of April
awaiting his fate Dominic Robb's future
in the balance as Rishi sunak considers
a report into bullying allegations
against his deputy
all eyes on Downing Street as Richie
sunac decides the fate of one of the
people who helped him into Power
contrasting views this morning from the
government and from labor
the times for taking the time to read
the report in detail before reaching the
conclusion it's putting proper weight on
the complaints that have been made as
well as on the future of the Deputy
Prime Minister you can't keep on
dithering and delaying or passing the
buck to someone else ultimately it's
it's on him
the head of NATO says all of its allies
have agreed that Ukraine will become a
member reaction of this program from a
Ukrainian MP I have no doubt Ukraine
will join NATO but we need for it to
happen earlier rather than later and we
need to see a clear path to that
taken at gunpoint how 15 Ukrainian
orphans escaped from Russia and the
thousands of others left behind
I'm in central London where thousands of
climate activists are planning to come
for a huge protest over the next four
days they're calling it the big one
charges are dropped against Alec Baldwin
over the fatal shooting of the set of
the movie rust
Sudan's paramilitary rapid support
forces says it's agreed to a 72-hour
truce in the fighting on humanitarian
grounds
ready to run President Biden will
formally announce his 2024 re-election
campaign as soon as next week
Marathon motivation later this hour I'll
be speaking to one of the world's
greatest athletes Elliot chip choge
about the London marathon and get a
campaign to get kids moving
[Music]
who's tour in the UK first time in six
years
[Music]
thank you
hello a very good morning to you Dominic
Robb is awaiting his fate this morning
the prime minister is deciding on Mr
Robb's future after the conclusion of a
long-awaited investigation into bullying
allegations against his Deputy the
report was handed to number 10 yesterday
Mr Robb has promised to quit if he was
found to have bullied staff well earlier
I spoke to the transport secretary Mark
Harper and he told me the Prime Minister
would want to reach a decision as
quickly as possible but he wouldn't be
drawn on when
there's a balance to strike here about
taking the time to get it right and of
course as you've reflected in your
report there are lots of other things
that the Prime Minister has to focus on
as well as this I think also you've got
to remember there were serious
complaints that were made and I think
it's also worth remembering this you
know the media reporting obviously
focuses on the future of the Deputy
Prime Minister but you know there were
people involved here who have made
serious complaints and I think you've
got to be fair to them as well and I
think it's by treating this seriously
the Prime Minister taking the time to
read the report in detail before
reaching conclusion it's putting proper
weight on the complaints that have been
made as well as on the future of the
Deputy Prime Minister
well Labor's West streeting told me the
Prime Minister needs to move swiftly
ultimately the Prime Minister has got to
make a decision he can't keep on
dithering and delaying or passing the
buck to someone else ultimately it's
it's on him it's his judgment as to who
he points to high office and who he
dismisses and I'm afraid he's got a
really poor track record of putting
people who are not good enough in some
of the highest offices in the land
well I also spoke to the assistant
general secretary of the civil servants
Union the FDA Amy levisage and she
thinks that some people are going to
question the point of making a complaint
if the system doesn't seem fair
and that's what I think people are going
to be fearing uh last night and today
that what we're going to see is history
repeat itself we're going to see
political considerations come first and
and
that will then have a chilling effect
across the Civil Service and you know
this isn't uh you know we this isn't
just one or two bad apples here we had a
report that showed that one in six
senior civil servants had witnessed
unacceptable behaviors just in the last
year alone and these behaviors are
really quite widespread and we do need
to have a moment where we say this isn't
appropriate in no other workplace in the
land would you get away with this kind
of behavior
well let's bring in our political
correspondent repel who's in Downing
Street Forest this morning and we think
don't worry that the Prime Minister has
had this report for around 24 hours now
don't we Rob so when are we likely to
get the prime minister's decision on
Dominic Robb's future are we any the
wiser this morning
yeah it was late morning yesterday that
Rishi sunak was handed this report from
the Barrister Adams Holly in terms of
when we might get his decision well
frankly we don't really know um you only
spoke to Mark Harper earlier he couldn't
guarantee he would even come before the
close of play today saying that Rishi
sunak would want to bring this to a
swift conclusion but also wants to take
the time to get it right and suggested
that it would be probably a lengthy
piece of work that Rishi sunak was going
through given the scale and the length
it has taken to put this inquiry
together remember as well this report
that Rishi sunak is going through right
now is not it doesn't reach a judgment
it doesn't advise the Prime Minister on
whether the ministerial code the rule
book for government ministers has been
broken by Dominic rabbit simply sets out
the facts based on those interviews
based on the work that Adam Tolley has
done so that's why it's for Richie sunac
to go through this and make a judgment
in his own head about whether the Deputy
Prime Minister of the Justice secretary
Dominic Raab can stay I think though the
fact that we haven't had this yet does
lend some credibility to the suggestion
that this isn't clear-cut that there
isn't something in here that is so
egregious and so absolute that Rishi
sunak would have been able to act
um quickly and swiftly after getting
this report and decide that Dominic Robb
may have to go and I think when you look
at some of the reporting and you speak
to civil servants about this I think
it's that sort of ambiguity that is
reflected in those conversations because
while yes there has been a lot of
reporting a lot of reporting anonymously
from civil servants claiming in very
very strong terms that Dominic Robb's
Behavior across the line and was
unacceptable you speak to others who say
who question who wonder whether this is
uh cast iron bullying or whether it is
simply someone who is yes maybe
difficult to work with and a demanding
boss but whether it actually reaches
that threshold for bullying I think that
ambiguity really presents political risk
for Rishi sunak there if he keeps
Dominic Raab on then he may well find
civil servants leaving their jobs in the
ministry of Justice if he does sack in
then people may wonder why he brought
him back into government in the first
place but no indication as yet when we
will get this decision or when we will
get to see this report okay we continue
to wait Rob for the moment thank you
very much indeed
now the head of NATO Yen's stoltenberg
says its 31 members have all agreed that
Ukraine will eventually join the
alliance speaking ahead of a defense
meeting in Germany and after a visit to
Kiev yesterday Mr stoltenberg addressed
a key Ukrainian demand since Russia
invaded 14 months ago but his prediction
came with a caveat the main focus now
should be ensuring the country wins the
war
I served in Kiev yesterday and that
Ukraine's future is in the Euro Atlantic
family and all NATO allies have agreed
that Ukraine will become a NATO member
but the main focus now is of course on
on how to ensure that Ukraine prevails
but the main focus now is on ensuring
that President Putin do not does not win
the award that Ukraine prevails because
without the Sovereign independent
Ukraine there's no meaning in discussing
membership
well the Ukrainian MP Kara ruddick was
speaking to me when the news broke and
so this development will bring fresh
hope to ukrainians
the ability to be a member of EU a
member of NATO is something that is
written in Ukrainian Constitution
however I will be very interested in
timing we understand that European
security uh is and the world Democratic
security is impossible without Ukraine
right now especially that we do have the
largest army that have an experience in
full-scale work in fighting however the
question is what would be the process
and when would this happen I have no
doubt Ukraine will join NATO but we need
for it to happen earlier rather than
later and we need to see a clear path to
that
well meanwhile at 15 Ukrainian orphans
have told Sky News how they were taken
at gunpoint by Russian soldiers removed
from their Homeland and illegally
transferred to Russia before making a
remarkable escape to freedom and to
safety our International Affairs editor
Dominic wakorn reports now on Ukraine's
missing children
thousands of children have been taken
from Ukraine by the Russians in this war
this is the story of 15 who escaped
their clutches
their ordeal lasted five months and took
them a thousand miles but they have
finally reached Freedom thanks to one
remarkable woman
Natalia was the director of their
orphanage in southern Ukraine when
Russian faucets arrived
we know from CCTV footage taken in
another orphanage how the Russian
military has searched for children in
this war Natalia begged the Russians to
let her children go
is
the day the soldiers came was filmed by
Russian State tv the footage doesn't
show what the children say happened that
they pleaded not to be taken and the
Russians fired their guns to make the
move
fourteen-year-old Dasha describes those
frightening moments yourself
they say they were moved against their
will at gunpoints a clear violation of
the laws of war taken from their
orphanage to another in the village of
stephanievka 150 miles Behind Enemy
Lines
then the Russians move them again as
they retreated across the danipra river
fifteen-year-old stas says he feared for
the worst
so maybe she never know
[Music]
he was right to be worried they were
heading for Russia taken through one
city after another in russian-occupied
Crimea then across the Kurt Straits and
over the Border Natalia's worst fears
had come true
foreign
this is the Fate that could have awaited
them Sky News has found evidence of
Ukrainian children being deported deep
into Russia some are given to Russian
families in these pictures in a city two
and a half thousand miles from home
oh this is sent to camps where we know
children are indoctrinated in putinist
ideology and trained in the use of
weapons
and they're being exploited for
propaganda purposes too in events
presided over by Vladimir Putin himself
the children being made to hug this
Russian soldier are from mariupole a
city destroyed by Putin's military
the Russians say they're rescuing
children from war
but both Putin and his children's rights
commissioner have now been indicted by
the international criminal court for the
war crime of deporting children charges
they've both rejected foreign
but this British war crimes investigator
whose senior evidence says moscow's
claims do not stand scrutiny this is a
clear conditioning of children for
nefarious purposes I think it goes to
the overall criminal plan which is to
extinguish extinguish Ukrainian identity
so we're talking about cultural genocide
and we're also talking about physical
genocide
our 15 orphans Journey ended an escape
from Russia slipping across the border
and finding sanctuary in Georgia
they recall the moments they made it to
Freedom is
they're now waiting till it's safe
enough to go back home against the odds
Natalia has kept her word and led them
to safety is
foreign
Sky News Tbilisi Georgia
now four days of protest by Extinction
rebellion and other groups begins today
dubbed the big one tens of thousands of
campaigners are expected to gather
throughout Central London all weekend
including on the day of the London
Marathon well earlier the transport
secretary told me disrupting the
marathon would be unfair on those
participating
I would be appalled if that was
disrupted you know there are thousands
of people that take part in that race
who are who will have trained all year
who are raising money for charity and I
think it would be appalling if it was
disrupted so that's the the first point
the second point is the protesters I
think have got completely the wrong
target here they're making very serious
points about climate change Britain is
one of the countries in this government
is one of the governments that's leading
the the fight against climate change
well our correspondent Rachel venables
are joined me now so Rachel what exactly
is planned by these protesters over the
course of this weekend
well throughout the morning small camps
like the one behind me here have been
popping up throughout Westminster as
Extinction Rebellion get ready for four
days of action action that we know will
be hugely disruptive here in central
London if for no other reason than the
numbers they are expecting they tell me
they hope that somewhere between 30 and
40 000 protesters will come to
Parliament to try and get their message
heard by the government here outside
defra the department for environment
food and Rural Affairs they've got what
they're calling a people's picket so you
can see several dozen people behind me
holding up banners they've been chanting
and singing through the morning as well
handing out leaflets and letters to the
civil servants going into this building
and they've been doing the same
throughout Westminster outside
government buildings trying to get
noticed we know certainly they will do
later on today at 10 30 they've got what
they're calling their opening ceremony
and from there over the next four days
they've got a huge number of events and
activities planned they are going to be
noise they are going to be disruptive
but they have pledged not to disrupt the
London marathon on Sunday there were
concerns that activists could get
involved in in doing something to
disrupt that so far Extinction
rebellions say no what they're focused
on is the government
Rachel thanks very much indeed
Sky News breakfast
[Applause]
Elon musk's huge Starship spacecraft
gets off the ground but not for terribly
not
[Music]
we'll start with breaking news and we're
going to interrupt that to take you live
to us of course it has a bearing on
what's happening with interest rates
we're cutting out of that to bring you
some breaking news could you tell us
about the night that the Russians were
coming Russia is making advances now
listen it's quite a Time hasn't it Alex
tell us what's happening this is turning
into a humanitarian emergency
news never stops Nelson breaking news
for you neither do we let's just come in
to us here at Sky News
[Music]
foreign
there's always more to the news than a
headline we want to discover to delve a
little deeper to find out what's really
going on explanation analysis the people
at the heart of every story I'm Neil
Patterson and this is the Sky News Daily
podcast Alex Crawford joining us now
from Ukraine their personal possessions
are all scattered around the place our
economics and data editor Ed Callaway
try him extensive at the big numbers for
us things can change incredibly quickly
that's what they have done so by the end
we'll hopefully all understand what's
going on in the world just that little
better available whatever you get your
podcasts
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
now it's the biggest and most powerful
rocket ever made destined eventually to
take NASA astronauts back into space
[Applause]
[Music]
well after an aborted attempt early this
week the SpaceX Starship lifted off from
Texas to cap to huge chairs carrying its
next Generation Starship Cruise vehicle
it was on calls for a 90-minute uncrewed
test flight and all was going pretty
well for the first phase of the flight
the entire Starship stack continuing to
rotate we should have had Separation by
now obviously this is uh does not appear
to be a nominal situation
but as you can see it exploded four
minutes later and it fell back down to
earth when two sections failed to
separate Elon Musk and the SpaceX team
say they've learned a lot and have hopes
that it'll one day be used to take
people to Mars
now prosecutors have dropped involuntary
manslaughter charges against the actor
Alec Baldwin over a fatal shooting on
the set of the movie rust the decision
came after new evidence emerged on the
gun that fired the shot that killed
cinematographer Helena Hutchins here's
our U.S correspondent Martha Kellner
in the place known as Montana's Paradise
Valley a project resurrected production
on the film rust is restarting 18 months
after Helena Hutchins was shot dead on a
set hundreds of miles from here as the
film's star Alec Baldwin did final
rehearsals he was told involuntary
manslaughter charges against him in
connection with hutchin's death had been
dropped Alec Baldwin and other members
of the cast and crew of rust were doing
last minute preparations here when news
came through that those charges which
were filed in New Mexico had been
dropped a preliminary trial was due to
start in just two weeks time so this was
an incredibly dramatic intervention
and for those preparing to resume
filming a note of relief so Alec is a
consummate professional and I think we
had every confidence in his ability to
act within the movie regardless of
what's going on in any aspect of his
personal life I would say probably
um for everyone else it's a good outcome
in the sense that we feel that justice
has been served Baldwin posted a picture
with wife Hilaria on Instagram I owe
everything I have to this woman he wrote
and to You Luke he put in Brackets
presumably a reference to his lawyer
Luke Nikas
the top of the Spire of a church is all
that's visible of Yellowstone film Ranch
from the public Road
a poignant reminder that it was while
rehearsing a scene in a church that
Helena Hutchins was shot dead the bullet
lodged in the shoulder of the film's
director Joel Souza a year and a half
later he returned to the set alongside
other members of the original cast and
crew
as part of a wrongful death settlement
Helena Hutchins widower Matthew Hutchins
has become an executive producer on Rust
there are still at least five
outstanding civil lawsuits against
Baldwin and the other producers of rust
but the Hollywood veteran will now
finish this film an actor and not a
criminal defendant Martha calnes Sky
News Montana
Sudan's rapid support forces have agreed
to a 72-hour cease-fire it'll coincide
with Eid and the group claims that
humanitarian corridors will be opened to
allow citizens to evacuate the former
secretary James cleverley has cut short
his specific tour to focus on
coordinating Britain's response to the
Sudan crisis
and let me just bring you this just in
from the British Council they have put
out a statement saying we are relieved
to share that all colleagues who were in
our office have been evacuated and are
now home the Safety and Security of our
colleagues is always our highest
priorities about from a spokesperson for
the British Council just in the last few
moments
and retail sales here have taken a big
hit in March down 0.9 percent after
rising in both January and February so
let's bring in our business presenter
Ian King who's in the city for us so Ian
disappointing these figures
well they are I mean we're talking here
about retail sales volumes rather than
values and at the amount of stuff sold
rather than the value of stuff sold and
uh yes a 0.9 contraction was pretty
disappointing the market was looking for
a contraction of 0.5 but I think you can
put most of this down to poor weather
last March the uh last month the
rainfall uh last month was 155 percent
what you would normally get in March and
the office for National statistics
actually pointing out that according to
the Met Office this was actually the
sixth rainiest March since 1836 so some
pretty extraordinary weather there and
that clearly hit non-food sales in
particular clothing and department
stores particularly badly hit slightly
weighed against that are better than
expected uh showing confirming what uh
we'd heard earlier in the month from the
British retail Consortium that sales of
jewelry uh were quite strong and some
confectionary sales were also quite
strong during the month along with
Mother's Day the other interesting thing
to note though here anna is that for the
first quarter as a whole retail sales
volumes were actually up 0.6 and that
was actually the first quarterly
increase in retail sales volumes since
the summer of 2021 so uh a slightly
stronger start for the year for retail
sales than had expected let down by some
pretty soggy March weather I think is
the overall picture yeah and we all
remember that soggy March don't we okay
Ian thanks very much indeed we'll see
you a little bit later on when we
uh in the meantime though oh more
weather
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the next few days look colder and
more unsettled but Northern parts will
stay largely fine today it's mostly dry
out there now if a bit chilly but cloud
and rain is spreading across the South
and that rain will Edge further west
across Southern Britain during the
morning with sunshine and showers
following but Cornwall should stay fine
elsewhere expect plenty of sunshine if
you're lucky
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
still come here on Sky News breakfast
we'll be giving you a sneak peek of The
Bible specially commissioned for next
month's coronation
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
beautiful
foreign
Bishop of Canterbury has received the
specially commissioned Bible which will
be used by King Charles at his
coronation next month so let's take a
look at it shall we
there it is
came quicker than I thought with the
Royal coat of arms in Gold Leaf as you
can see on a bright red leather cover
and it's the Bible that the king will
place his hand on during the coronation
oath the tradition of presenting a Bible
to the Monarch dates all the way back to
the coronation of William III and Mary
II in 1689.
nothing sportime is Alex
this guy new sports bulletin is brought
to you by Vitality getting more people
more active live life with vitality
coming out of University in the summer
of 20 2011 like I could see Bruce corner
on fire from my house I lived in Croydon
um and then the rhetoric coming out from
the a lot of meteorites and stuff is
very much around like these young people
being bad kids and they're born this way
and it's like lock them up throw away
the key so it's almost like a Eureka
moment of we need to do something here
we need to implement something to try
and help help the young people change
the rhetoric of what Society is
believing about these young people I
come with the connect when I was
15 16 years old to be felt no I never
really liked School
wasn't of Interest I was more like a
practical more Hands-On
so um I wanted to get like more serious
into football and uh hopefully make it
pro it's always my dream because where
I'm from as I have like two Roots as I
ever like
because I'm from a council estate so you
couldn't imagine her there's there's not
really uh no one really makes it out you
know Broken Dreams and a lot of us come
from broken Homes single parents and
things like that so I think it's
important that there's like kinetic
hopefully there's a lot more like
kinetic
can get a lot of people like me out and
help us along the way and hopefully
progress
if a young person is very talented they
typically won't value their education
particularly much when they're younger
sometimes in my opinion professional
clubs reinforce that by having day
release programs from very young Ages
which devalues an education for a young
person and then so when they might get
released whatever age it is they're also
potentially not have much to fall back
on because they've kind of pinned all
their hopes on being being a
professional footballer when releases
happen and inevitably they do more often
than not from young people in clubs like
a Young Person's lost it they've lost
their identity and they're very
vulnerable so students that will come to
us or players that will come to us will
be releases over at 14 15 that come into
evening Community sessions
um maybe a bit lost on their pathway
maybe fitting that they're not good
enough and picking those kids up and
giving them regular training to get into
the groove again I suppose and finding
their love of the game but that the
education does come first and and that's
our end to every student as soon as they
come through the door is education comes
first we will provide you with
everything that you want and need on a
football pitch but you need to commit to
the course give as much care to that as
you do your football and who knows what
will happen with the football
opportunity
this guy new sports bulletin is brought
to you by vitality
now all the way from Vegas to the UK
legendary music star Donny Osmond is
going on tour in the UK for the first
time in six years so let's take a look
at what we might see at that show
[Music]
this is not a
puppy love
[Applause]
and I'm delighted to say that Dolly
Osmond is here with you and that's just
the slow part of the show oh it goes
crazy I bet it does what I did was I put
six Decades of show business in one show
it's just jam-packed with everything
well yeah well tell us a little bit more
let's get into that right now for one
thing I I came up with this idea about
doing a wrap kind of like Hamilton where
everything is undone in rhyme it All
Began back in Utah I was four years old
started singing but my brothers and the
sound was like gold so my folks took a
leap and said what the hey we gotta get
these monsters out to California and it
goes up for 10 minutes gets faster and
faster and everything I say you see on
the huge screens it's data overload for
10 minutes that sounds extraordinary
yeah the other bit that I think sounds
amazing is that there is a sense of a
little bit of audience participation
isn't there oh it's more than that I've
wanted to do this for so many years it's
called the request segment so uh I've
done I've released 65 albums in my
lifetime so I put all 65 albums on the
screen from the beginning to the current
and anyone in the audience can pick any
song from any album I've ever done in my
entire life and we do it just like that
that is a big test it's uh the band I
have and the dancers I've picked
hand-picked it's probably the most
exciting show I've ever put together
because it's everything I've done
exciting but quite nerve-wracking as
well is there ever a song that's picked
do you think oh my goodness I can't
remember the words yes that's happened
and what happens is that I I follow the
fans they know the words so I follow
them it's quite funny but no most of
them I I remember is there one song that
gets picked more than others uh it's
across the board it really is depending
upon the age that's asking I mean little
kids will ask for Mulan in fact I do a
whole uh because I'm captain Shang in
the Disney movie Milan we turn the
theater into a home alone experience do
the same fight dancing that Captain
Shang is doing behind me let's get down
to business and it's fantastic but the
ones that crazy horses keeps coming up
yeah the 12th of Never
well puppy love is actually in the set
list it's the fourth song and and I
treat it with respect there's a time in
my life where I just didn't want to sing
it anymore I was trying to get away from
that image but then I grew up and I
realized it was a great part of my life
so this whole show that starts November
28th this whole tour I can hardly wait
to come is a celebration of six decades
in one show how do you keep things fresh
how
it's the audience I mean it doesn't
matter how tired you are when that
curtain goes up when the music starts
you see the crowd and the enthusiasm the
Synergy is is the word I'll use it's
just it's so much fun The Show Goes by
just like that and
I'm saying that this tour marks 50 years
since you and your brother's first
performed in London
I think that's about right yes and so
how is it being back here it was my
second home because they they coined the
phrase Osmond Mania back in 72 or 71
when now all that took place and the
hysteria uh and the excitement is what
spilled over to the United States and
the rest of the world so it was really
the UK is where the epicenter was of my
career so I love coming back here is it
right that you weren't able to fly into
Heathrow we were banned why was that
because of the amount of people that
that showed up uh there was an accident
one of the balconies because of the
amount of fans were on there collapsed
thank goodness there were no fatalities
a lot of people hurt so from that point
on you know for well I can fly into it
now
[Laughter]
but back in the day I had to fly into
Scotland and take a secret train to come
into the city was that quite an exciting
time though it was one of the best times
of my life and I get to relive it every
night uh when I do this show and
unbelievable that you've got 64 albums
did you say 65 65. currently working on
the 66th and to what extent has your
music changed over that time you have to
change it all you'd have to reinvent
yourself in fact this one I decided okay
who do I absolutely love out there Bruno
Mars is is one of the greatest artists
right now but I didn't want to just go
to Bruno I said okay who does he write
with who you know who are the production
teams so I would write with these people
Amy wage by the way who wrote thinking
out loud with uh Ed Sheeran she was one
of the ones uh that I wrote with uh
wrote a song The Way You Loved
the way you touch she and I wrote this
song it's about my wife and it's one of
my favorite songs on the album so the
whole album is about who I am right now
not when I was a puppy love not that I'm
putting that down because I celebrate
the whole breadth of six Decades of Show
Business well thank you and everywhere
I'm playing it's on donnie.com that's
Donnie Central you everywhere I'm
playing is on dottie.com or I've got a
very good taste of it here as well
Donnie Osmond real pleasure to meet you
good luck with the tour thank you very
much
now still to come to stay with us I'm
going to be speaking to one of the
world's greatest athletes Elliot Kip
choge about the London marathon and a
campaign to get kids moving that's
coming up next
[Music]
thank you
I'm Becky Johnson a Sky News
correspondent part of the teams based
here in the Midland
allegations of exploitation in
leicester's clothing factories aren't
new in fact it's been an Open Secret in
this city for years
[Music]
made for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain world
we're getting more and more stabbings
and essentially I think it's more and
more younger children because the team
we're not really surprised by anything
these days
so the reports of a male who can stand
repeatedly in the leg
here in the diverse industrial heart of
England we hear from people who have
real stories to tell
parents are going to complain like this
and schools had better get ready for it
these protests are being organized
primarily by people who aren't parents
at the school
so some patients aren't going to survive
this we have to be prepared that
patients will die from from this illness
staff here are currently identifying
wards that could be turned into in areas
where patients with covid-19 could be
isolated
River seven is still rising and people
here in Ironbridge have been told it
could go up by another meter before it
starts to go back down
it's going to be a long slow process to
put it back together we aim to be the
best and most trusted place for news
[Music]
tap into the latest news and insight
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
[Music]
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
now it's only a couple of days until
thousands of Runners will take to the
Streets of London for this year's
Marathon well the world record holder
for the fastest marathon Elliot kichoke
is in London but this morning he's at a
school to inspire the next generation of
athletes and as you can see I'm
delighted to say he joins me now very
good morning to you so good to see you
thanks so much for talking to us first
of all tell us a little bit about what
you're up to today in London
uh
and interact with them
promote Taylor mile you know
I'm also always asking the kids to run
for a mile or walk for a mile daily and
encouragement as many schools are called
to join for fitness and you know at the
moment you are fit then you can also
fit mentally so it it's two things being
fit tackle is basically and mentally
what is why is it so important to you to
get kids moving
um uh kids circle is our next Generation
so that's why I'm investing on kids and
in treating them with knowledge as far
as Fitness is concerned which can help
them uh let us to prosper with their
education you know they say health is
your wealthy and without being held then
you cannot cut well so it's good things
that it's good that to invest you on our
next generation and the kids are
important to ourselves
and All Eyes here in London are on the
marathon on Sunday of course but am I
right in saying that you're not taking
part in that
I'm not talking about uh on Sunday I'm
here to support I am here to watch
talk to to many to many people actually
as far as sport is concerned uh Marathon
why are you not running the London
Marathon
uh I was in Boston last week and uh
I always ran to two marathons I've
completed my assignments for this year
and
my call now is uh to spread a lot of
Fitness at the whole world
and just a quick word on the Boston
Marathon um you finished six didn't
quite go according to plan how
frustrating an experience was that for
you
it was really frustrating but all in all
is that uh sport is uh today you are
happy tomorrow your town and you need to
accept your results in order for us so
for disappointment and and and enjoy the
sport
you are the world record holder for
running the fastest marathon so for all
those marathon runners around the
country who are running for fun or to
test themselves on Sunday what's your
message to them
my message to everybody
on London marathon on Sundays to come
and start there is enjoy Terrace well
and you know marathon is live they say
running is where freedom is so it's
enjoy and go through the Finishing Line
why do you think the the marathon is so
special
it teaches us a lot as we go on through
that we know on the way we have a lot of
pumps on the road and we have the
portals it's like your life your life
cannot be smooth there is nobody I can
lose in a comfort zone and that's why I
treat Marathon as life and I I prefer
and I know in future uh I I know
marathon is the future of this world
okay well Elliot kipchoge it's such a
pleasure to talk to you thanks very much
indeed for joining us thank you
thank you too
let's just cross to Rob Powell who's in
Downing Street now because we have some
breaking news concerning the fate of
Dominic Robb so what can you tell us Rob
yeah so Dominic Robb in the last few
minutes has published his resignation
letter he has resigned on Twitter he's
published this two-page
um letter it's quite lengthy of just
trying to quickly go through it as it's
literally just been put online but
whilst it does confirm that he is
stepping down it also takes issue with a
number of elements
um of uh how this investigation into his
behavior has progressed so Dominic Rob
clearly not happy with the report as it
stands but ahead of Rishi sunak making a
judgment about what happens Dominic Robb
saying that he will be standing down I
can read you part of what is in this
letter it says that he feels duty-bound
to accept the outcome of the inquiry and
that the inquiry by Adam Tolley Casey
this Barrister dismissed all but two of
the claims leveled against him so
Dominic Robb stating that Adam tolley's
report essentially upheld two of the
claims against him but Dominic rather
than this letter goes on to say that he
believes that the two adverse findings
are flawed and set a dangerous precedent
for the conduct of good
um government so Dominic Robb
essentially saying that he is resigning
as Justice secretary and as Deputy Prime
Minister because he had promised that he
would stand down if uh the complaints of
bullying against him
um were upheld that appears to be be
what has happened in this inquiry from
Adam Tolley but Dominic Robb also taking
issue with how that those reports were
upheld and how actually this
investigation has progressed so the now
former Justice secretary clearly not
happy with how this inquiry has
progressed going through the rest of the
letter uh Dominic Robb says that
ministers must be able to exercise
direct oversight with respect to senior
officials over critical negotiations
conducted on behalf of the British
people otherwise the Democratic and
constitutional principle of Minister
responsibility will be lost he talks
about ministers being able to give
direct critical feedback on briefings
and submissions to senior officials to
set standards and drive reform uh and
says that Mr Tully Adams Holly the
Barrister that carried out this inquiry
concluded that Dominic Robb had not once
in four and a half years sworn or
shouted at anyone let alone thrown
anything or otherwise physically
intimidated anyone
um so essentially the Top Line being and
we don't yet know whether this has
happened as a result of a conversation
with vicious sunac it may well be that
Rishi sunak uh
almost pushed Dominic Robb into this
decision what tends to happen as a
matter of protocol is rather than
someone necessarily just being sacked
without any notice they can be given the
opportunity to resign although what
dominic Robb is saying in this letter is
actually he feels Duty bound to stick to
what he previously promised and because
those complaints
were essentially upheld in this report
which remember we still haven't seen he
says as a result of that he will be
stepping down so we wait to see what the
Prime Minister says whether the Prime
Minister essentially had reached the
same conclusion but it seems that
Dominic Raab in doing this ahead of
Rishi sunak making his decision has
taken the decision out of the prime
minister's hands and decided to stand
down himself albeit whilst voicing
significant concerns about how he has
seen the process playing out
well yes and Rob for anyone just joining
us let me just remind them of the
breaking news that has just come in the
last few moments the Deputy Prime
Minister Dominic Rob has said that he
will resign from Rishi sunak's cabinet
following the conclusion of an inquiry
into bullying allegations against him
but Rob as you were saying Dominic Rob
making it clear that he doesn't agree
with the conclusions of that
investigation and yet he is still
stepping down
yeah and reading the rest of the letter
Dominic Raab says that he believes that
the threshold for finding bullying for
sort of standing up if you like an
accusation of bullying has been set so
low that the inquiry has set a dangerous
precedent and he says it will encourage
spurious complaints against ministers
and have a chilling effect on those
driving change on behalf of the
government and the British people so
Dominic Robb clearly still believes from
himself that he has not bullied anyone
he believes though that essentially his
behavior as he sees it in being a
demanding Minister as being someone that
was trying to drive change and Achieve
things was interpreted as bullying and
now this inquiry has found that it
believes it was bullying but Dominic raw
believes that essentially the um the
level for defining that has been set
wrongly he's also raised complaints
about and raised concerns about
essentially some of the briefings and
some of the interviews albeit
anonymously that have come out from sit
from civil servants around his behavior
saying that he had raised with the Prime
Minister a number of improprieties that
came to light during the course of the
inquiry including the systematic leaking
of skewed and fabricated claims to the
media in breach of the rules of the
inquiry and the civil service code and
then he ends his letter saying that he
remains supportive of the Prime Minister
and the government as as when I first
introduce you at your campaign
leadership launch you have proved a
great prime minister in challenging time
so Dominic are clearly not happy with
how this is playing out voicing quite
serious warnings about what he sees may
be what he calls a chilling effect and a
dangerous precedent that setting the bar
so low as he sees it for bullying may
have for other parts of government and
other ministers but crucially in that as
well saying that he essentially doesn't
blame Rishi sunak when he remains
supportive of the government who remains
supportive of the Prime Minister sister
as well but clearly a significant
intervention British sunac has now lost
his Deputy Prime Minister and his
Justice secretary by my accounts I think
that's the third Cabinet member that he
has had to either Sack or that has
resigned since he took over a little
over six months ago of course Gavin
Williamson
um stood down and he was forced to sack
Nadeem zahari over his tax Affairs as
well we wait now to see whether we will
get a response from the prime minister
to that letter from Dominic Robb clearly
Dominic Robb feeling that because he had
promised in advance of this inquiry to
stand down if accusations of bullying
were upheld feeling Duty bound that he
should follow through on that but
clearly raising concerns as he as he
stands down in that letter about how
this process has played out and
essentially refuting that he doesn't
believe he has bullied anyone he
essentially believes that the definition
of bullying that this Inquirer has been
operating off was a flawed one and one
that was set too low
so Rob just how big a moment is this for
the prime minister to lose his Deputy in
these circumstances
I think we've just lost Rob there in
Downey street so I'm going to bring in
Ali 40 who's here with me in the studio
and I will put the same question to you
um just to reiterate we have just
learned that the Deputy Prime Minister
Dominic Raab has resigned so how big a
political moment would you say this is
for the prime minister to lose his
Deputy in these kind of circumstances
it's a huge moment Dominic Robb this is
not the same as Nadeem zahati who was
sacked it was pretty clear-cut was not a
close Ally of the prime ministers
Dominic Robb was someone who was out
supporting the Prime Minister during
that leadership race was sent into
Political obscurity under Liz trust
resurrected by Rishi sunac dep his
Deputy Prime Minister and Justice
secretary this is a huge moment I think
the sense you get from his letter is
that he's not going quietly he's saying
that this sets a dangerous precedent
setting the bar for bullying so low so
he yes has resigned but he is clearly
not happy with this okay Ali thank you
let's bring in our political editor Beth
Rigby who joins me on the line now Beth
your thoughts on this announcement from
Dominic Raab that he's quitting
well there's a there's a number of of
things in this and the fast is that he
is quitting but is clearly very unhappy
around the circumstances which he feels
he's been forced to go uh Mr Rob made it
very clear that if any of the complaints
were upheld he would resign two
complaints have been upheld and
therefore he's felt compelled to stand
down but in the letter he makes it very
clear that he believes the thresholds
are too low by which uh these claims
have been
upheld uh he says that it's such a
dangerous precedent he says he's
genuinely sorry for any unintended
stress or offense that officials felt
but he also goes on to say this as I
said the satin for bullying is so low
this inquiry is set a dangerous
president it will encourage spurious
complaints against ministers and have a
chilling effect on those driving change
on behalf of your government and
ultimately the British people he goes on
to say as Rob was pointing out that he
still supports the government and still
supports Mr sunak so where does it leave
the Prime Minister well in a way Anna
for for Mr Rob to resign rather than ask
the prime minister to for compel the
prime minister to have to sack him it
makes it easier for Rishi soon at
because Mr Rob has resigned of his own
accord he hasn't forced the hand of his
boss but where does it leave Rishi sunak
well it leaves him without his closest
political Ally a loyal Lieutenant he
loses his Deputy Prime Minister he's
going to have to re-configure uh his
cabinet now and and in terms of some of
the remarks that Mr Rob made in his
resignation letter there has been a
sense from some ministers that Mr Rob
was being forced out by the civil
service now of course civil servants
would contest that but some ministers
and former cabinet ministers might see
this as a sort of win of Whitehall
against the government and that it sets
as Rob has said a Preston in which more
claims can be made against ministers so
there's a sort of whole subsection to
this in terms of the Civil Service and
its relationship with the political
operatives in government and ministers
so I think that will be a Fallout of all
of this the way in which Dominic Robb
has frowned his letter of course for the
Prime Minister as well if you strip away
the kind of remarks or the framing that
Dominic Robb made around this letter
there's a question of well two of The
Bullying complaints were upheld then it
raises questions as to why the Prime
Minister if he had promised a government
of Integrity professionalism and
accountability put Mr Rob back into
cabinet not just into cabinet but as his
Deputy if there were rumors swirling or
accusations swirling about Mr Rob's
conduct to other people and I was told
by a very senior source that Rishi sunak
was told directly about what this person
described as Mr Robb's unacceptable
behavior in the summer when there was
the leadership campaign so months before
Rishi sunap became prime minister so I
do think there are questions from this
about why Richard Cena chose to put Mr
Rob into cabinet if there were
there was unhackedness in Civil Service
circles around his conduct and you have
to remember Anna that this went across
three cabinet posts three different
departments over a number of years so
this wasn't an isolated incident this
was eight separate complaints with a
number of complainants two of them
upheld Mr Rob felt he hadn't any option
uh but to resign he made it easier for
his boss but that resignation letter uh
is one
um laced with anger from Mr Rob about
how he feels he has been treated and in
a way in which the Civil Service in his
view has kind of moved together moved
against him and forced him out
okay Beth for the moment thanks very
much indeed for that very quick response
to Dominic Robbs a resignation let's
bring in our Deputy political editor Sam
Coates now so Sam a big political moment
the resignation of the Deputy Prime
Minister
that's right and it's quite something to
think Anna that 48 hours ago it was
Dominic Robb sitting next to Richardson
at Prime Minister's questions that was a
moment see there's a symbol a signal by
many about how close the Deputy Prime
Minister was to the PM and how hard it
would be in the event that the report
that we we kind of all knew was coming
probably the next day uh that how hard
it would be to let him go and all the
way through yesterday clearly Downing
Street having to weigh up what were
quite difficult judgments because it was
absolutely clear from the delay and the
problem is it got the report basically
24 hours ago now um it was quite clear
that what the report didn't do was
provide an absolute Smoking Gun that
would result in the automatic and
immediate dismissal of the Deputy Prime
Minister there was stuff to weigh up we
were told that this was a lengthy
document that it was very detailed it
had taken five months to assemble there
were multiple complaints that had to be
adjudicated on but there was a sense
that while we hand being guided that we
might get a pretty quick decision from
the Prime Minister it was in the event
rather harder than that Dominic Robb
chooses to make a lot in his letter of
the fact that really only two complaints
uh were upheld and the rest were
dismissed
um knowing that knowing that there were
two complaints upheld and if if we do
get the Adam Tully report in full we'll
be able to see the details and I I still
think the plan is that we see it so when
it comes we'll be bringing you putting
it on that screen and going it through
it line by line it'll be interesting uh
to see uh just how much uh how bad the
behavior was uh how bad Adam Tully
judged what dominic Robb did and uh will
be able to judge for herself whether or
not there was a realistic case uh for
keeping him clearly at points yesterday
Downing Street must have considered
whether there was a path to keeping him
that's why it would have taken so long
but here we are today with the
announcement of uh the resignation uh
although it's called a resignation when
you when you read the Lesser it doesn't
feel
uh like Dominic Robert is in any way
happy with the situation with the
outcome uh whilst acknowledging the
upheld complaints he says uh that
actually he says that the bar for a
billion complaint is effectively too
high and says that that's bad for
government that bad for society to be
set so high so I I suppose I'm I'm
questioning whether uh his resignation
letter really was a resignation or
whether uh he basically jumped because
he knew that he would have to be pushed
by the Prime Minister
um uh and and that kind of slightly
bitter tone rather reminiscent of the
slightly bitter tone in the Nadine zaha
we letter uh I think Will Shine through
and Spark a debate and that's probably
the politest word that we're going to
use uh but there's gonna be a debate now
amongst some of the Allies that we've
been hearing on Sky News uh for days
inside the conservative party who think
that Dominic Robb was the victim of a
politically motivated Witch Hunt uh from
uh potentially uh members of the Civil
Service younger members of the Civil
Service who didn't like his politics and
weaponized an HR system in order to get
him out of the jobs because they didn't
like what they were hearing now the
question is is Rishi cynic able to
contain that debate cauterize that
debate close that debate
with this resignation or are there some
people angry uh
Deputy Prime Minister who at one point
stood in for the Prime Minister when
Boris Johnson was very ill it harder to
push that out but ultimately when you
think of the calculation for Richard
said that we don't understand it a
little bit better as a result of that
letter from from Dominic Robb Richie
sunak was facing the possibility if he
wanted to keep Dominic Robb in that job
he was going to have to explain why
there had been two bullying complaints
harassment complaints upheld against his
Deputy Prime Minister uh but effectively
was still uh willing to keep him in the
job when he promised on the steps of
Danny Street about accountability and
responsibility and respect and returning
those sorts of values to the heart of
government when he came in he would have
had to done that and face down the
possibility of perhaps victims of
Dominic Robb's Behavior going public uh
senior civil servants who perhaps no
longer in the Civil Service being
prepared to give interviews and talk
about what they experienced while
working alongside him I think there was
a lot that Richie Sudan was going to
have to face down in order to uh in
order to keep Dominic up in his job so
perhaps that little uh that slight tone
of anger that tone of bitterness is
something ironic given this is all a
discussion it was seemed about a lot of
it about Dominic Rob's temper some of
that perhaps uh just uh a sparkling and
surfacing through in the way that that
Lit that letter uh is written
um I think it was uh probably just quite
hard in the face of perhaps a sustained
uh media appearance from critics people
who witnessed firsthand uh and the fact
that there were two complaints upheld um
and and although Dominic Robb may say
the majority of them are dismissed in in
some senses you know that there was a a
finding that uh that there was uh
bullying in two cases and and that is
enough and and I think in a lot of
workplaces that would be judged to be uh
enough uh but the question is do the
conservative back benches agree now
Richie sinak is lucky that this didn't
land four months ago or three months ago
this is this is a report that's been
taking that's taken five months in the
making because the police physical
conditions for Richardson that were very
very different back in January February
his position much less secure however in
the last couple of months we've seen his
Richie sunac's fundamental political
position improved dramatically after the
success of the Windsor framework
domestically after some of those foreign
trips wasted alongside Joe Biden in San
Diego making a bit of a mark on the
world stage bringing together the
conservative party uh back in
Westminster even doing something of a
deal around small boats with Tory Rebels
just uh 24 36 hours ago all of that
probably means that although there will
be sympathizers of Dominic Robb there
will be people who feel that he's hard
done by people perhaps those who came
out in the on the airwaves on Sky News
yesterday the day before uh say that
they hadn't seen Dominic raw bully they
thought he treated everybody with
respect uh uh uh that actually the
internal criticism for uh for this
decision is relatively minimal I know
people around Dominic rum some of them
in the last 24 hours have been uh
briefing pretty bullishly talking about
him being lawyered up even though the
law doesn't really focus feature in this
process talking about a fight to the
death that he was prepared to uh to make
again uh perhaps an unfortunate analogy
in the context of what we really uh
really talking about but I do know other
people who are around Dominic Raab who
for some weeks of effectively to me been
acknowledging that a positive outcome
for the Deputy Prime Minister was was
highly unlikely and that uh he was
almost certainly going to have to fall
on this sword as a result of the
cumulative nature of the complaints and
the stories uh some of which we've heard
in the media uh and and no doubt when we
get that document shortly and we'll be
able to peel through it uh line by line
we'll we'll we'll get the the full cast
of it
um but there is something it's going to
be honest of a national conversation
going on at the moment about exactly the
things that Dominic Robb talks about in
his letter there is particularly in the
um light of the dismissal of the former
head of the CBI Tony danker there's a
discussion about how one person's
workplace etiquette standards culture
the way they talk to other people the
standards that they demand might be
acceptable but another person might not
find that acceptable and I think um it's
quite interesting that Dominic Robb
leans into that discussion which will no
doubt feature in our politics in the
days uh to come as people try and get to
grips with uh people from sometimes
different Generations but not always
setting different standards um
approaching issues different ways being
more sensitive uh than others and uh
there will be some in the in the Tory
party who will be tempted uh to say that
what's happened here is uh the
derogatory term for Whitehall used by
some Tory MPS which is the blob uh has
won this time by uh serving up a chorus
of complaints about the Deputy Prime
Minister a figure that intrinsically
they didn't like and that the Prime
Minister has given in to that and that's
the issue here so I think that there is
a discussion to be had politically where
people try to minimize the political
Fallout but in the end Rishi sunat must
have decided that even if uh Dominic
looks like he resigned although he looks
like he didn't want to resign from the
letter in which he announced his
resignation uh that he I think Richie
sunac will have decided uh that the pain
of keeping him outweighed whatever the
potential benefit it's work for
impressing perhaps one flank of his
party and effectively standing by his
Deputy Prime Minister
um it is it has to be said you know
people's political careers are judged by
the public in the round and this will
obviously uh be a very important part of
his uh of his record as uh will be the
um standing in for Boris Johnson when
Boris Johnson had covered but of course
one of the things that might have made
it easier to wave goodbye to Dominic
Robb today were the circumstances in
which he departed from the foreign
office in 2021 they weren't they weren't
pretty you'll you'll remember in that
summer there was the evacuation of
Afghanistan NATO uh uh pulling out of
Afghanistan the U.S and the UK as well
and I think in that uh in that period
Dominic Robb was on holiday uh Dominic
Robb didn't uh uh go back to the foreign
office overseas per in person and
ultimately uh
um Boris Johnson decided uh to demote
him now you can see on your screens that
we do
that have the letter from Dominic Robb
that's the one uh where you do see the
sort of just that slight sense of
bitterness and anger uh coming out uh
just to read some of it that you can see
on the screen uh he talks about um he
feels Duty bound to accept the outcome
of the inquiry by the way uh viewers of
skogies will know that he made the
pledge to resign if there was an
accusation of bullying to Sophie Ridge
on uh on Sunday so he had committed
publicly to resign if there were
allegations of bullying that were upheld
in this inquiry and if you look at
paragraph three on your screen it says
um the report did dismiss all but two of
the claims leveled against me I also
believe that it's two adverse findings
are flawed and set a dangerous precedent
for the conduct of good government you
know what um now what that means is that
the next question for Richie sunac is
does he believe that the eminent Casey
who spent five months doing a report
into Dominic Royal's Behavior issued
flawed judgments that's quite an
incredible uh attack line from Dominic
Rob who of course himself is a lawyer
quite an incredible attack line against
tolly and the report that he's spent
five months yeah totally as a man of
some standing in the legal profession
it'd be interesting to see whether uh he
agrees with Dominic Robb interesting to
see whether uh Rishi selac agrees with
Dominic Raab who makes uh levels quite
an aggressive accusation about adverse
findings which are flawed in his
language and a dangerous precedent
there are people that disagree with that
there are people in private who who do
talk about how it was difficult working
with Dominic rather received senior
civil servants who wouldn't let junior
staff alone with Dominic Raab according
to reports certainly that I've heard
Dominic Robb still in this letter uh
insisting uh that he uh does uh uh uh
sort of behave professionally at all
times
it's an interesting letter because in
many ways it suggests that he both
accepts and doesn't accept the findings
simultaneously which is why this all
throws up but the fact that he's
resigned probably minimizes some of the
pressure on the Prime Minister but it'll
it'll be interesting to see uh quite how
he uh he the Prime Minister uh answers
the the challenges and the questions
posed by Rishi sudax by Dominic Ralph's
letter there now the letter goes on
ministers must be able to exercise
direct oversight with respect to senior
officials over critical negotiations
conducted on the behalf of the British
people otherwise the Democratic and
constant institutional principle of
ministerial responsibility will be lost
and that is how Dominic Robb frames the
way that he can conducted himself in
government and of course
there are other accounts of how he uh
behaved Infamous examples from
2018 where he was appointed brexit
secretary suddenly turned up in Brussels
to the consternation of the negotiating
group not clear uh what gains he made
but uh uh there are in Whitehall
memories of moments like that where uh
some believe that there wasn't good
behavior now in this letter what's
interesting is Dominic Robb goes on to
attack those people who quote unquote
leaked those episodes now he basically
says it is unacceptable for members of
Whitehall members of the Civil Service
to effectively talk about his behavior
he he thinks it is a bad thing that the
media got hold of accounts of his
behavior uh which he contests and thinks
that that's unacceptable
um but what's interesting about this is
that really we wouldn't be where we are
today without the reporting not just on
Sky News but on the guardian and other
media Outlets which brought to light in
quite Stark terms the fact that there
have been formal complaints it was the
media coverage that resulted in Dominic
Robb having to ask for an inquiry into
himself by the um by the Prime Minister
ultimately done by Adam Tolley back last
November so I suppose in one sense yes
Dominic Robb can regret uh the fact that
civil service or proxies for the civil
servants or representatives of the civil
servants we won't know who uh did reveal
details of Dominic rail's Behavior but
however much he might regret it the
truth is he would probably still be
Deputy Prime Minister today if that
wasn't the case so an attack on leaking
an attack on uh uh the standards that he
thinks should be maintained in the
workplace but according to the accounts
that that I've heard that that there are
there have been quite difficult episodes
um some people might characterize it as
controlling he would say uh that it was
only exacting standards uh uh the the
sort of General theme that that I think
uh that when he talk to a lot of people
that have worked with Dominic Robb that
that does surface quite repeatedly is he
very much was a politician who liked
doing things uh in a very specific way
uh to to quite a fine degree he liked
exacting ways for documents to be
prepared uh he was very hot on timings
he was very hot on presentation uh he
was very hot on how he was treated now
he will argue that was appropriate for a
senior Minister who's trying to run a
government Department uh to behave
others clearly disagreed and we await
the details of the two cases of conduct
that Adam Tolley the Casey believes were
inappropriate and that's the and that
that really is that the nub uh of this
letter uh and the reason why Dominic
Robert said he's going to resign uh and
that um he has accepted his fate and
done what he promised to Sophie Ridge
that he would do uh uh a few weeks ago
and resign if that report uh found uh
that there was bullying but Westminster
never stand still and so we uh uh uh so
we uh uh you can see the door of Downing
Street uh there I'd expect some activity
uh a little bit later today uh with uh
perhaps a new replacement as Justice
secretary and then there's a decision
for the Prime Minister as well whether
or not he does a like for like
replacement of the Deputy Prime Minister
job because that's a title that comes
and goes in British politics Dominic
Raab was initially at the point that
Boris Johnson came in given the chart
the title of first minister of State
okay and then when Boris Johnson demoted
him in 2021 from the foreign office to
the justice department uh he gave him
the Deputy Prime Minister job as a
consolation will that job title be
handed out today or might it just
disappear for a little bit that we
should find out a little bit later okay
okay Sam for the moment thanks very much
indeed well let's bring you some
reaction which is now flooding in to
this news of Dominic Robb's resignation
we've got some response from the liberal
Democrats their Deputy leader Daisy
Cooper has put out a statement saying
Dominic rapper shown that he's not only
unfit to serve as a minister but is
totally unfit to represent his
constituents in Parliament he should
resign as an MP and trigger a
by-election so the people of Isha and
Walton can finally have the MP they
deserve the liberal Democrat Deputy
leader goes on to say voters across
Surrey and the blue wall are fed up with
this endless conservative chaos and MPS
who take their communities for granted
at the next election in Isha and Walton
it'll be a two-horse race between more
conservative party chaos or a
hard-working and liberal Democrat MP
he'll listen and stand up for local
people so that's what the liberal
Democrats have said in the last few
minutes let me also just bring you a
line from the TUC the general secretary
Paul nowat has tweeted uh sorry not
sorry as classy a resignation statement
as we might have expected beyond the
non-apology spare a thought for the
civil servants who've had to put up with
Dominic raab's unique brand of direct
oversight for so long so a reaction
there from the TUC and from the liberal
Democrats let's go back to Downing
Street shall we and bringing our
political correspondent Rob Powell robal
a notice there that the liberal
Democrats are calling for Dominic Raab
to not only resign his role as Justice
secretary Deputy PM but also as an MP
they want a by-election what chances of
that
I mean I think that's fairly unlikely
unless Dominic Raab decides that he
simply doesn't want to even carry on as
a back bench um MP but you would have
imagined that he maybe would have made
that clear in his resignation statement
I'd be no surprise that if Dems want
that
um Dominic rods sorry constituency is
one of their big Target seats and
potentially one that they may take at
the next general election I think if
Dominic Robb did decide to stand down as
a backbencher it would really cause
Rishi sunak problems because it would
open up a very very difficult bile
action
um there so I think for that reason
that's probably on my kid you'll see Dom
McGraw sticking around albeit on the
back benches
um for now we've also had some reaction
coming in from labor we're expecting to
hear from the labor leader secure storm
over the next hour or two with labor
source ahead of that saying that this is
the second cabinet bully who's been
allowed to resign and has essentially
accused Rishi sunak of failing to sack
both Dominic RAV and Sir Gavin
Williamson who of course resigned over a
fairly similar accusations related to
his behavior you're a potential bullying
the labor source going on so you've had
13 years of touring Prime Ministers
trying to dodge the rules and defend
their mates enough is enough and you
talked about the reaction coming there
from Paul Novak from the TUC we've also
had a comment from the General Secretary
of the prospect Union which represents
many public sector workers as well kind
of making a similar Point almost to what
labor and the TUC said and it's what
we've heard from other unions about the
way that bullying complaints that are
made by civil servants are handled and
dealt with within government and it
really goes to that question that fact
that it is the prime minister who was
the ultimate Arbiter of whether someone
has broken the ministerial code so when
Rishi sunak was weighing up what to do
about Dominic Robb you have to imagine
that part of what would factor into that
is the fact that Dominic Raab is someone
who is a close political Ally someone
that went out to bat for him during the
leadership contest and what people that
work for unions representing civil
servants say is their needs to
essentially be a better process a better
Arbiter a more independent Arbiter to
decide on whether someone has uh
committed behavior that would be
inappropriate in any other workplace so
I think that the sort of dilemma that
Richard sunac has been going through
speaks to some of the concerns really
that many unions have had um right from
the off uh I think in interesting
reading more closely Dominic Robb's
resignation letter you start to get a
sense of what some of these complaints
and some of the issues that have been
investigating in this report may be
revolve around Dominic Robb talks about
oversight of senior officials and
negotiations and references the context
of the brexit negotiations over
Gibraltar when a senior Diplomat
breached the Mandate agreed by the
cabinet so Dominic Raab essentially
indicating that at some of the points
where he behaved in ways that people
thought was bullying actually what he
was doing was holding his officials to
high standards and as Sam was so as Sam
has explaining that really a kind of
mixed resignation letter where he's
accepting the findings to an extent that
he accepts that he has to resign but at
the same time criticizing
um even the complaints against him that
were upheld
okay Rob for the moment thanks very much
indeed well let's get some more reaction
to this breaking news that we've had in
just the last half hour or so that uh
the Deputy Prime Minister Dominic Raab
has resigned uh well joining me now is
former special advisor to William Hague
Chris White
um Chris your immediate reaction to the
news that Dominic Raab has resigned
uh good morning um I think it pretty
much was inevitable for a couple of
reasons first of all Dominic Robb
himself made clear uh that were any
findings made against him he would
actually resign and he's clearly gone
ahead and done that but we can come on
to the details of the letter in more
detail uh shortly but secondly I think
Rishi sunak as prime minister when he
came into office made it very clear uh
that uh in his first speech that he said
that this government will have integrity
professionalism and accountability and
that was a clear attempt to
differentiate himself from uh previous
incumbent of uh Downey Street and Boris
Johnson and the issues that the
conservative party in government had had
during their year in office as prime
minister in uh in the end of
2022. so I think that um clearly he was
really only left with one option and
while sources in number 10 is suggesting
that he was not pushed I think there
would have been some encouragement uh
before the Deputy Prime Minister to head
towards the exit
well yes so as you say he has gone
because he acknowledges that Adam
tolley's report in his words dismissed
all but two of the claims leveled
against me and because of those two
claims he has gone but he's very unhappy
about it isn't he he said in his letter
in setting the threshold for bullying so
low this inquiry has set a dangerous
precedent what do you think the reaction
will be in the Tory party to the way
that he has couched his resignation
well it's it's really interesting that
he's gone in a lot of detail into uh the
findings and and said basically that he
disagrees with them uh and it's a very
legalistic interpretation of uh the
findings as you would expect from the
Justice secretary
um I think for for the conservative
party clearly he's been a core supporter
of Rishi sunak for a long time and that
will make things uh challenging and
you've already seen some conservative
MPS come out publicly and say that
they're pretty disappointed with uh the
fact that he's being in their words
forced to resign
um you know in the in the long run I
think we're going to sort of see that uh
the conservative party will clearly
recover the business of government will
go on you'll get a mini reshuffle today
with the new uh Secretary of State
appointed uh suggestions that that could
be uh and one of two or three different
MPS
um so I think the impact uh today will
be significant but I think in the long
run I don't think he'll be as
significant as some are making out
well yes because some will say this is
damaging to the Prime Minister this is
the third Minister who's had to go in
his short tenure in office it's really
not very long and he made big play when
he stood on the steps of Downing Street
when he first took office about
restoring Integrity to the role
yeah and clearly the opposition will
make us uh as they've already done
you've made some statements or stated
some statements from the liberal
Democrats opposition parties already
asking for him to resign I think the uh
from the number 10's point of view
clearly they will uh go out and make a
virtue of this uh and said that since
the Prime Minister said that the he
personally will act with Integrity
professionalism and accountability and
lead a government that does so at every
level uh then by receiving a report and
seeing a minister resign effectively
he's putting that into practice which
way when you compare and contrast that
with the uh activities of previous Prime
Ministers uh for example Boris Johnson
that was not followed through so instead
of uh having a situation where the prime
minister is standing at the dispatch box
every week and trying to defend a
minister where adverse findings have
been found against him he's actually now
got a clean state to be go to go out
next week at Prime Minister's questions
on Wednesday and say look I've taken
action the government has moving on
we're going on with the business and
this should be a one-week story at least
that's the expectations that will be
from Downing Street it'll be a tough
week for them to get through but
actually if we look at this in in sort
of the medium term this story will
probably not be uh one that is lasting
long into the months ahead
okay Chris Wyatt we appreciate your time
thanks so much for that uh response to
the news of Dominic Robb's resignation
uh we're getting loads more reaction
let's go back to our Deputy political
editor Sam Koh Sam what can you tell us
so what's really interesting Anna is
this is the letter from Dominic Robb
announcing his resignation saying that
he feels Duty ban to offer it doesn't
sound very happy and we're going to go
through it in a second but I'm also
getting some live reaction from people
in Whitehall about this letter some
pretty critical commentary about the way
Dominic Robb has chosen to conduct
himself uh in uh in his outgoing moments
and it's worth um just highlighting some
of that and before we go through some of
the text uh somebody in whitehall's just
pointed out something very interesting
that you know look at what's not here
what is not here is the kind of thing
that you saw in Nadim zahawi's letter
kind of thing you saw in Gavin
Williamson's letter what is not in this
letter is any kind of fulsome tribute to
Rishi sunak now down in street are
saying that they didn't push uh Dominic
Roberts all his own decision but when
you go through this letter and it's an
extraordinary list I can't think of a
letter like this in these circumstances
it's quite as bitter quite as personal
quite as angry as as the one that
Dominic Robb has done today when you
think about the fact there's no tribute
to the Prime Minister you know Dominic
Rhodes walking out the door and he's
slamming it shut he's crossed and he's
not making any attempt to kind of use
the kind of language the law of outgoing
secretary of the state do when they
leave in order to try and make sure
there's a bit of a path back this is a
this is a hard exit from Dominic Robb
and that's that's just fascinating in
itself
um and if you go through it what you see
actually is that he's taking out the
machine gun to quite a lot of
individuals uh uh he um talks about the
claims uh he he he appears to gun in
particular I'm just going to take you to
page two of the letter if I can
there we go
um uh and he um he in this on the second
page of the letter I'm just going to try
and get it up on our screens no that
doesn't work uh he goes for
um what appears to be one of the most
officials in uh senior officials in
Whitehall she's called Antonio Romeo and
he picks on her in that penultimate
paragraph when he talks about how people
were removed from his private office
under the guise of his conduct which he
clearly is very angry about
um he talks about uh leaks to the media
and he talks about fabricated claims to
the media and the coercive removal by a
senior official of dedicated private
secretaries from my Ministry of Justice
private office in October of last year I
hope this will be independently reviewed
so as he walks out the door not only
said no tribute to wish you sudak there
is a kind of attempt to try and get the
permanent Secretary of the ministry of
Justice Antonio Romeo a big figure in
Whitehall inter uh into a sticky
situation and calling for a review uh
into her that just one of many many
examples in this extraordinary letter of
his anger now let me consider do you see
entire thing this entire thing is about
Dominic Rob's allegations about Dominic
Rob's temper his temperament and how he
conducts himself so it's fascinating
that he hasn't held back and um you can
just read uh between the lines to see
how he's feeling today so let's go
through it because you're getting quite
a lot of you can read quite a lot into
it so he writes to resign following the
release of the report by Adam Tolley it
was a uh and then there's just the most
perfunctory of goodbyes to Richie sulak
it was a privilege to serve you and I
pay tribute to many outstanding civil
servants with whom I have worked again
this is no reference to Richie Cena
though it's fascinating that he's that
he's not doing what most letters do uh
and here we get into uh the bits where
he sort of unleashes his true feelings
whilst I feel Duty bound to accept the
outcome of the inquiry which is what he
said to Sophie Rich a few weeks ago it
dismissed but all but two of the claims
leveled against me so what we're not
doing there is starting with an upfront
apology for being found to have behaved
badly he goes straight in there by
focusing on the claims that he didn't
make rather than the uh allegations uh
that he found so that's an interesting
technique from uh from a lawyer who
knows how to write these documents knows
how to have the biggest act so he goes
straight to the cases uh that were of
the issues on which he was found not
guilty
I also believe that it's two adverse
findings are flawed and set a dangerous
precedent for the conduct of good
government so there's another Target for
Dominic Raab he's going for this man uh
uh Adam Tully Casey eminent
well-regarded uh uh legal figure from
the legal profession who knows uh who
has done employment cases in the past I
understand so he basically says this
report is flawed so uh uh he uh doesn't
seem to pay tribute to the Prime
Minister uh and he goes at the uh
individual who wrote spent five months
investigating his behavior uh and he
sets out then at the case for why he
thinks there might just be different
views on Behavior but his view of his
behavior is acceptable first ministers
must be able to exercise direct
oversight with respect to senior
officials over critical negotiations
conducted on behalf of the British
people otherwise the Democratic and
constitutional principle of ministerial
responsibility will be lost so what's
that what what that is decoded is him
saying civil servants disagreed with me
that's why it was so difficult because
they because they implicit in that
sentence ministers must be able to
exercise direct oversight with respect
to senior officials over critical
negation is that they did things that he
didn't want them to they didn't do
things that he did want them to in other
words civil servants pushing their
political agenda in a way that he
disagreed with and he thinks that's bad
so he is citing he's acknowledging a
clash here with civil servants but
basically saying that's because they
didn't do what I told them
so it'll be interesting to find out
whether everyone agrees with that we go
on
uh this was particularly true during my
time as foreign secretary in the context
of the brexit negotiations over
Gibraltar when a senior Diplomat
breached the Mandate agreed by the
cabinet so we're gonna have to go back
through that episode and find out who
the senior uh Diplomat was and what
really went on there were lots of
occasions where perhaps there was an
agreed or some occasions that I'm aware
of where there's a agreed cabinet
position in agreed negotiating strategy
and Dominic Robb would insert himself in
discussions in a way that surprised some
so uh so that's interesting then he goes
on to say secondly senior ministers must
be able to give direct critical feedback
on briefings and submissions to senior
officials in order to set the standards
and drive reform the public uh expect of
us this must be done within reasonable
bounds and then he basically says
um uh it basically says I didn't throw
anything and it didn't hit anything it
hit anyone so he's been found guilty but
his case for his defenses I didn't throw
anything so he says I have over the last
four and a half years never sworn or
shouted to anyone let alone thrown at
anything or otherwise physically
intimidated anyone nor intentionally
sought to Blitz him so um don't make
Rad's case I didn't throw anything I
didn't hit anyone I Didn't Do It
deliberately
no apology no tribute to the Prime
Minister this is slamming the door shut
on the way out
okay Sam thanks very much indeed well
let's go back to Rob Powell who's in
Downing Street for us now and I
understand Rob that we hope to hear from
us shortly giving his reaction to this
news we've already heard from the
liberal Democrats as well just how bad
is the timing of this for Rishi sunak
and the conservative party coming so
close to the local elections
I mean it's not great it's probably not
great for things like this to happen at
any point but as Sam was outlining a
little bit earlier it probably would
have been a lot worse if it had come
sooner even a month two months ago
because Rishi zunak is just coming sort
of out of a month six weeks or so where
actually he can point some considerable
um political achievements be it getting
that brexit deal around Northern Ireland
done and announcing
um new policy and plans for channel
Crossings um as well so I think Rishi
sunak has potentially built up a little
bit of political Capital over the last
month or two so he probably would have
rather it have come now than maybe a
couple of months ago but you're right
we're a week or two out from the local
elections and I think maybe less than
just the specifics of this case what the
risk is that it's perceived by voters as
another Minister having to resign
following the Nadim zahari Scandal over
his tax Affairs following sir Gavin
Williamson having to step down as well
and all of that matters for Rishi sunak
because he he came into number 10
promising to clean up the shop
essentially to bring back Integrity to
politics and now there are questions
about why he brought those previous two
ministers in and back into government
and why he bought Dominic Robb back into
government as well but we can now hear
um from the labor leader sakir starmer
he's been out and about in Middlesbrough
this morning and this is what he's had
to say have a listen
what I think this shows is the continual
weakness of the Prime Minister because
there's a double weakness here he should
never have appointed him in the first
place along with other members of the
cabinet that shouldn't have been
appointed and then he didn't sack him
and even today it's Rob who resigned
rather the Prime Minister who acts and I
think you know we're here at
Middlesbrough College I've been talking
to the next generation of NHS staff they
desperately want to talk about the
future of the NHS and here we are
talking about these weaknesses at the
top of the Tory party and I think you
know in the end after 13 years it just
demonstrates that no matter how many
times you change the person at the top
you've essentially got a party that just
can't deliver just can't govern Dominy
Robb said depending on the findings of
the report he would resign he has now
resigned he's done the right thing
hasn't he well the big question for the
prime minister is why he was so weak to
appoint him in the first place the
second question for the prime minister
is why didn't sack him and now it's left
to Dominic Robb to resign and the Prime
Minister hasn't acted and it's that
indecision it's that weakness I think
that goes to the heart not just of this
prime minister but of 13 years now of
failure and it's why people desperately
want to change and also it has a bigger
picture here we've got a cost of living
crisis there's a future of the NHS that
um you know is really really important
I've been talking to students here who
are the future of Workforce of the NHS
they desperately want to talk about the
NHS and we're mired in talking about the
weaknesses and the inability of the
government to actually deliver anything
for the people of this country Mr Rob
has resigned he's gone down fighting
those taken aim at the inquiry saying
that uh in setting a threshold for
bullying so low it set a dangerous
precedent it'll encourage spurious
complaints against ministers and have a
chilling effect on those driving change
on behalf of government and ultimately
the British people I don't know why
Dominic craft thinks Dominic Robb in the
middle of a cost of living crisis
thinks that anybody wants to hear about
his whining about having to resign what
I think everybody wants is strong
leadership and that has been palpably
absent here why on Earth was Rob
appointed in the first place one Earth
didn't the Prime Minister act more
quickly why on Earth isn't the
government laser focused on the cost of
living crisis and the absolute mess of
the NHS that they've made the NHS is
broken many people today would say I'd
rather hear from the government on what
they're going to do about the NHS
they're broken I'd rather hear from the
government about the about the cost of
living crisis but here we are talking
about the failures at the top of the
Tory party that's the story of the last
13 years and you can understand why
people are utterly fed up with it do you
think there is a bullying culture or an
HR problem within the government I think
there's a weakness from top to bottom
um you know strong government that
delivers requires leadership and we
haven't got that and you can ship in
different Prime Ministers as we've seen
over the last 13 years but it's an
essential failure to deliver for the
people of this country and you know
where is that leadership on the cost of
living crisis people today can't pay
their bills where's that on the future
of the NHS people can't get a doctor's
appointment the massive waiting list you
know millions of people waiting more
than two weeks to see their doctors
despite promises they are the issues
that we should be debating today not
more discussion about weaknesses and
whining at the top of the Tory party so
just one
so labor once again training their sites
firmly on Richie sunac and essentially
trying to present the fact
um that Dominic RAB has resigned rather
than being sacked by Rishi sunak as
evidence of weakness on the prime
minister's part I think in reality
actually by Dominic Robb going before
um Rishi sunak was able to really make a
decision about this publicly anyway he
made the prime minister's job easier
because I think some of the ambiguities
in the case and the complexities of the
case against Dominic Robb were really
making this quite politically difficult
for Rishi sunak and really there was
quite considerable political downside
whichever way he turned we wait now to
see what we should see next response to
this is and of course we rate we wait to
dig through uh Adams Holly's full report
when that is eventually published
absolutely we will indeed Rob for the
moment thanks very much indeed
well let's get more reaction now joining
me is the cross bench pier and former
head of the Civil Service Lord Bob
kerslake a very good morning to you at
Bonkers Lake thanks for talking to us
what's your reaction to Dominic Robb's
resignation
well he clearly put up quite a strong
fight but I think this was the most
likely outcome in the end there were
eight formal complaints against him
across three departments whilst he might
be able to dismiss some of those it was
almost certain that some would stick and
had it given that he said he would
resign if some of them did uh he he has
gone and I think that was pretty likely
it's a kind of uh very bitter letter
though as some coats said it's a kind of
non-apology apology uh if I was doing my
job then I'm sorry if I upset people I'm
afraid there's some very contested and
contentious points in it nobody in their
right mind would say that a minister
couldn't oversee negotiations or indeed
give critical feedback on
um on briefings it's how you do it and
the way you do it that's important here
we don't have the benefit I'm afraid at
the moment of having Adam Tully's report
so we've only got his version
I receive things when we see the full
version I think we'll be able to get a
better idea of the balance of the
arguments here I particularly disliked
his rather a vindictive attack on a
permanent secretary a very well regarded
permanent secretary Antonio Romero for
what was probably an unnecessary thing
given the reaction of the staff to his
return to the department so it's a
pretty uh how can I put it unsavory way
to have gone I think he could have gone
in a much more graceful fashion but he's
gone and I guess that's the thing that
those who are complaining about him
really wanted to see happen well yes and
as you say he's clearly not happy in his
letter he says in setting the threshold
for bullying so low this inquiry has set
a dangerous precedent I mean that should
be taken seriously shouldn't it what's
your view
well until we see the Tony report we
don't know what the threshold was
um in terms of this issue I I think he's
trying to turn it into some kind of
constitutional issue about
um ministers and how they relate to This
concerns when in reality it's about his
behavior and the one thing he doesn't
really accept is that some of his
behavior uh was very undermining and
damaging to the Civil Service involved
by what all we know at the moment so we
need to see Charlie's report but I don't
buy it I'm afraid I think this is
um he's uh rather an unfortunate way of
defending himself in the circumstances
how do you think that civil servants
will react to this news
Oh They'll be pretty annoyed by his
letter I think they'll feel it's a
graceless and uh completely lacking in
any recognition of his own behavior and
its impact
but I think they will probably feel
relieved I think this is the only way
you can put it that the behavior hasn't
gone
unchallenged and and has led to
consequences no sort of by the way wants
things to be all smooth and sweet and
sweetness and lie they recognize they're
working in a high pressure challenging
environment but they do expect the basic
standards of behavior to be observed by
ministers being a minister isn't a
license to abuse and I think if this is
established that point Beyond doubt then
it's a good thing
okay Lord Bob because like thanks very
much indeed for giving us your views
this morning and responding to the
Deputy Prime Minister's resignation
our Deputy political editor Sam coats
who's been pouring over the details as
we have them and Sam of course as Bob
kerslake was was saying there it's
difficult for everybody else to make a
real conclusion about the judgments that
have been made until we have eyes on
Adam Tully's full report are we getting
any word about when we might see that
well I think Downing Street will
probably have to release that later
today because as it stands all we have
is the partial detail in Dominic Robb's
resignation letter and reading it and
kiss Dharma there called it whining
um Bob because like the former labor
advisor and crossbarge beer called it
bitter uh it's hard to descend from
either of those two things uh when you
actually read it
um what's quite clear about Dominic
Robb's letter is that he does Rishi
sunak no favors it's fascinating to
watch there you've got I mean clear
evidence of a disloyal Deputy frankly is
what it it looks like there's a there's
just that sense through what it does say
disputing the report disputing how
government is working and what it
doesn't say the lack of any kind of
tribute to the Prime Minister
acknowledgment that uh he was a man that
he backed the leadership and and was
doing a good job of the country's none
of that language of the sort that you
normally get in a resignation letter to
ensure smooth relations once you return
to the back bench so I I just wonder
whether Danny's through a slightly more
inclined to release that report sooner
rather than uh later
uh uh in order to um sort of get get the
other side out there clearly Downing
Street briefing that they didn't push
Dominic Robb it's his decision to resign
and he had committed on safety ridges uh
show uh that he would resign if any
allegations of bullying uh were upheld
he says in the letter uh that he's
released today that he's important to
keep my word he says
um and you had to piece together bits of
the letter he talked about findings that
were upheld and at the start he talks
about promising to resign if there were
allegations of bullying I think what we
can do is draw from that that the
allegation that was uphold was one of
bullying but in the letter he goes and
sets out and in this absolutely
extraordinary bit all the things that he
didn't do and it's quite a long list of
things that he didn't do uh he said that
in the four and a half years he was a
minister he never swore or shouted to
anyone let alone doing anything
otherwise that physically intimidated
intimidating did anyone nor
intentionally sought to belittle anyone
uh and he never threw anything
now it is fascinating that a man who
held effectively the second highest
office in the country is having to
respond to a report about his bullying
where allegations are upheld but I said
but I didn't throw anything
that's that's the kind of that's the
kind of argument that he's chosen to
reach for there's no sign of an apology
there is a in effect rejection of the
standards that an external uh legal
advisor a key a Casey uh Adam Tolley a
well-regarded lawyer who has done I
understand uh employment cases of
Conduct in the in the workplace cases
before he basically rejects the standard
that that external advisor has set for
his behavior and and to be honest the
sort of allegations that I was hearing
about didn't involve throwing things or
shouting um the the allegation that you
heard time and time again uh from some
former and and officials that work for
Dominic Rob was a bit more about sort of
controlling behavior and a uh and a sort
of willingness to uh to get cross if
things weren't exactly as he wanted and
and creating a Culture of Fear as a
result of impossibly exacting standards
words in this letter he basically sets
out why he thinks that that should be
treated as reasonable behavior and
rejects the external advisor for saying
that um uh that that this was
unacceptable and then you and you end up
with this extraordinary bit uh where he
can uh where he says in setting the
threshold solo for bullying this inquiry
has set a dangerous precedent it will
encourage spurious complaints against
ministers and have a chilling effect on
those driving change on behalf of your
government and ultimately the British
people you've got to wonder at this
point what is Dominic Robb's goal by
writing a letter like that as I've been
saying for the last eight it's like he's
slamming the door shut firmly there's no
Grace in relation to his relationship
with the Prime Minister he seems to be
taking aim at very very senior civil
servants it looks like uh by talking
about an incident last year involving
the removal of some Junior officials
from his office that he is demanding an
independent inquiry into Antonio Romeo
one of the most high profile civil
servant in Whitehall it was nearly
development secretary at the treasury
touted potentially as a as a future
cabinet chief he seems to be saying we
should investigate her for the way that
she was dealing with some of the people
complaining about his behavior
he's taking on everybody but to what end
you know he now goes back to the back
benches there is no uh chance of a
return to office certainly this side of
a general election he's got a very hard
battle as Rob power saying to keep his
seat in Surrey uh the Eastern Walton
seat that he's held since 2010 is a
marginal it's exactly that kind of area
uh where the libdens have been making
inroads uh in the last two or three
years uh and and may not end up even
being an MP after the next election I
just wonder given the tone of this
letter given the kind of No Holds Barred
attack on just about everybody whether
actually he he mentally overnight
decided that he was going to close the
door on his political career by writing
that because I don't think there's going
to be any love lost in his own party in
many parts of his own party for he's
written uh today uh in an inquiry about
his potential anger angry moments this
letter does actually speak to episodes
of anger which we can see coming through
the text of this letter quite the most
extraordinary resignation letter I've
ever seen
yes Sam thanks very much indeed Let's uh
go to Downing Street just down the road
from here and talk to our political
correspondent Ali Fortescue who's there
Ali all eyes will be on the Prime
Minister today behind that door and
number 10 are we likely to hear from him
and what do we expect him to say do you
think
I think undoubtedly we're going to have
to hear from the prime minister at some
point the premises
I was also looking carefully considering
we're told the report
was Dominic Robb who appeared to go
before being pushed
saying that he was going to resign as
Deputy Prime Minister and Justice
secretary so
I'm going to jump in because your line
is coming and going there at Downing
Street I said it was just down the road
but unfortunately the technology is not
working perhaps partly because of the
weather and so let me just uh let you
know
um if you're just joining us what's
happened so far this morning Dominic
Robb the Deputy Prime Minister has
resigned this is after Adam Tolley Casey
a senior lawyer delivered his report
after a five-month investigation into
allegations of bullying against Dominic
Raab that was delivered to the Prime
Minister yesterday we understood that
Dominic Robb got sight of it yesterday
as well and then this morning he has
issued just at about a quarter to ten
this morning his resignation letter
where he accepts that in this inquiry it
dismissed in his words all but two of
the claims leveled against it against
him but because it upheld two of the
claims he was Duty bound to resign he
said all along throughout this process
that he would resign fine if any of the
findings were made against him were
found to be valid and so he has gone but
the letter is an angry one as a son
coats has talked us through this letter
since Dominic Robb's resignation he
talks about the threshold for bullying
being so low he says this inquiry has
set a dangerous precedent and he goes on
to say it will encourage spurious
complaints against ministers and will
have a chilling effect on those driving
change on behalf of your government and
ultimately the British people he also
has some argument with what he calls a
number of improprieties that he says
came to light during the course of the
inquiry they include he says the
systematic systematic leaking of skewed
and fabricated claims to the media so
that's what's happened so far today
we're getting lots of reaction as you
can imagine and let's get a little bit
more now because joining me is minira
Wilson who's the liberal Democrat MP4
Twitter
Wilson thanks very much indeed for
talking to us what do you make of the
resignation of the Deputy Prime Minister
well Dominic Robb has proved quite
clearly that he's unfit to be a minister
he's therefore unfit to be an MP and I
really think he should stand down as a
member of Parliament and cause a
by-election and his resignation letter
frankly is utterly graceless when
they've clearly been two serious
findings against him in this independent
report by a barrister specialist in the
area
uh in the history of graceless
resignations this has got to be up there
okay you say it's graceless but he would
no doubt argue that he has a valid
argument to make he talks about the
threshold being too low for bullying and
he thinks that this inquiry sets a
dangerous precedent is that something
that that you don't take seriously
well uh we called for an independent
inquiry and so did Dominic Robb and
there's been a barrister Casey who who's
a specialist in this area who's done a
five month long detailed investigation
and has found two findings of bullying
against him I mean if that isn't
sufficient enough are we now saying that
workplace bullying is okay I don't think
it's okay for a minister or a member of
Parliament and that's why I think his
position is untenable the people of
Easter and Walton deserve a decent
hard-working MP with Integrity who's not
going to bully members of staff and
that's why the liberal Democrats are
calling for a by-election now
he's also raised what he calls a number
of improprieties that he says came to
light during the course of the inquiry
he talks about systematic leaking of
skewed and fabricated claims of the
media he says in breach of the rules of
the inquiry is that something that you
would like looked into
uh well I mean clearly if there have
been inappropriate leaks they need to be
looked into but people also members of
Staff need to be able to to whistle blow
and share their stories if they're being
maltreated so we need to be careful
around that as well but I think we also
need to think about the prime minister's
role in all of this let's not forget he
promised us a government of integrity
and accountability so he has questions
to answer too as to when he knew about
these allegations and why he employed
appointed Dominic Robb in the first
place let's not forget Rob was has
always been one of his most loyal
lieutenants right by his side throughout
his leadership campaign last summer even
when it was very clear that he was going
to lose so clearly he felt he had a debt
to repay to Dominic Robb and therefore I
think the Prime Minister has some very
difficult questions to answer too
he does say in his letter that he
regrets any unintended stress that
officials felt but he's clearly not
happy do we need a debate at all do you
think about what constitutes
inappropriate or bullying behavior in
the office or about how complaints are
treated
well by all means we should have a
debate but I think we also need to have
zero tolerance for bullying in the
workplace
um we could have a debate about the
threshold but at the end of the day if
there is bullying taking place and this
has been a serious independent
investigation by a barrister who's a
specialist in the area who has found two
findings against Dominic Robb that is
enough for me to say that he should
resign both as an MP as well as a
minister
okay manira Wilson liberal Democrats MP
for Twickenham we appreciate your time
and your response to the resignation of
Dominic Robb this morning thanks very
much indeed
so let's go back to Downing Street now
we had a few problems with the
communications there to Ali Fortescue
our political correspondent Who's down
there and Ali you were talking about the
prospects from for hearing from the
Prime Minister today
we're going to have to hear from the
prime minister at some point things have
been remarkably quiet here the last 24
hours of course Russia sunak as we were
told was carefully considering this
report now we know Dominic Robb appears
to have gone before being pushed but he
doesn't really seem to have gone quietly
he does say I'll continue to support the
government but he doesn't seem
particularly happy with how things have
turned out as we've been saying he says
that this has set a dangerous precedent
setting the bar for bullying solo so
Dominic Robb is resigning he will no
longer be the Deputy Prime Minister all
Justice secretary the question of course
now goes to who might replace him but
there'll be questions too for the Prime
Minister when we hear him why was
Dominic Robb appointed when there were
perhaps rumors swirling at that time
over his position he of course is
someone who's been on the front benches
for a long time as a brexit secretary
Justice secretary Deputy Prime Minister
under Boris Johnson to now he is back on
the back benches where will he be making
life Russia's United's life difficult it
remains to be seen he has been a close
Ally of the Prime Minister but a big
moment and it was a big decision that
the Prime Minister was looking at but in
the end it looked like Dominic Robb has
gone before being pushed all eyes now on
number 10 and whether we hear from the
prime minister
and there is still very little going on
on number 10 we await to find out if we
hear from Rishi Cena there will be
though a government briefing from the
prime minister's spokesperson in the
next couple of hours they may well be
able to give you more then
you're watching at Sky News today it's
11 o'clock here are the headlines to
bring you this morning breaking news
this hour Dominic Robb quits after a
report upholds two bullying claims
against him
the Deputy Prime Minister resigns from
all of his government posts but still
takes issue with the report's findings
calling them flawed
we bring you all the latest developments
today as Rishi sunak looks to replace a
key member of his cabinet and weighs up
the damage ahead of next month's local
elections
[Music]
thank you
very good morning dramatic developments
to bring you from Westminster Deputy
Prime Minister Dominic Raab has resigned
from government following the conclusion
of an inquiry into bullying allegations
Mr sunak received the report from senior
lawyer Adam Tolley Casey's investigation
yesterday and had been considering the
findings since Dominic Robb said it was
important to keep his word by stepping
down if an inquiry found that he had
bullied officials but he said the two
findings against him were flawed and set
a dangerous precedent
well let's bring in our Deputy political
editor some codes uh morning Sam this
isn't the first cabinet minister lost
but it is the most significant isn't it
so far of Rishi sinak's Premiership
that's right first it was Gavin
Williamson then it was Nadim sahawi
today it is Dominic Raab the most
significant because he is the Deputy
Prime Minister officially the second
highest office holder in the government
until about an hour and a half ago
Dominic Robb now out back to the back
benches losing his job both as depth
prime minister and as Justice secretary
after a five-month investigation by a
prominent employment lawyer Adam tolly
QC into multiple allegations of his
behavior the accusation that Dominic
Robb was a bully and it would appear
that has been uh upheld we've got a
letter we'll look at it in a moment but
in that letter he said I did pledge to
resign if there were accusations of
bullying upheld that do appear to have
been two counts on which that was the
case he does appear to concede that he
unintentionally belittled people and
he's going with a blast but now the
Prime Minister has a problem he has a
vacancy he's got to fill probably today
the role of uh Secretary of State for
justice covering prisons uh the justice
system key role at this point uh in the
parliament he also has to decide whether
to give someone else the role of Deputy
Prime Minister or whether that's a title
that perhaps as it has been for so many
years of the last 30 years a title to
retire but more than anything else
Richie sunac stood on the steps of
Downing Street in early November on
entering government and promised to
restore Integrity accountability and
respect to the heart of government there
is now a conversation about how the
second highest office holder in his
government could remain in office for so
many months given the accusations of
bullying that only came to light because
of media pressure media reporting ended
up in an independent investigation that
took five months the conclusions that
that Dominic rub was indeed somebody who
behaved in a way not fit for cabinet
ministers in the view of that QC and
Dominic Raab has now gone an
extraordinary moment more problems for
Richie sunak he has had quite a good few
months but this plunges him back into
turmoil and he has to make some
difficult decisions and try once again
to steady the story ship after a
difficult few months and years
what I think this shows is the continual
weakness of the Prime Minister because
there's a double weakness here he should
never have appointed him in the first
place along with other members of the
cabinet that shouldn't have been
appointed and then he didn't sack him
and even today it's Rob who resigned
rather the Prime Minister who acts and I
think you know we're here at
Middlesbrough College I've been talking
to the next generation of NHS staff they
desperately want to talk about the
future of the NHS and here we are
talking about these weaknesses at the
top of the Tory party and I think you
know in the end after 13 years it just
demonstrates that no matter how many
times you change the person at the top
you've essentially got a party that just
can't deliver just can't govern Domin
said depending on the findings of the
report he would resign he has now
resigned he's done the right thing
hasn't he well the big question for the
prime minister is why he was so weak to
appoint him in the first place the
second question for the prime minister
is why didn't sack him
um now it's left to Dominic Robb to
resign and the Prime Minister hasn't
acted and it's that indecision it's that
weakness I think that goes to the heart
not just of this prime minister but of
13 years now of failure and it's why
people desperately want to change and
also you know there's a bigger picture
here we've got a cost of living crisis
there's a future of the NHS that
um you know is really really important
I've been talking to students here who
are the future Workforce of the NHS they
desperately want to talk about the NHS
and we're mired in talking about the
weaknesses and the inability of the
government to actually deliver anything
for the people of this country Mr Rob
has resigned he's gone down fighting
those taken aim at the inquiry saying
that uh in setting a threshold for
bullying so low it set a dangerous
precedence it'll encourage spurious
complaints against ministers and have a
chilling effect on those driving change
on behalf of government and ultimately
the British people I don't know why
Dominic craft thinks Dominic Robb in the
middle of a cost of living crisis
thinks that anybody wants to hear about
his whining about having to resign what
I think everybody wants is strong
leadership and that has been palpably
absent here why on Earth was Rob
appointed in the first place well on
Earth didn't the Prime Minister act more
quickly why on Earth isn't the
government laser focused on the cost of
living crisis and the absolute mess of
the NHS that they've made the NHS is
broken many people today would say I'd
rather hear from the government on what
they're going to do about the NHS
they're broken I'd rather hear from the
government about the about the cost of
living crisis but here we are talking
about the failures at the top of the
Tory party that's the story of the last
13 years and you can understand why
people are utterly fed up with it do you
think there is a bullying culture an HR
problem within the government I think
there's a weakness from top to bottom
um you know strong government that
delivers requires leadership and we
haven't got that and you can ship in
different Prime Ministers as we've seen
over the last 13 years but it's an
essential failure to deliver for the
people of this country and you know
where is that leadership on the cost of
living crisis people today can't pay
their bills where's that on the future
of the NHS people can't get a doctor's
appointment the massive waiting list you
know millions of people waiting more
than two weeks to see their doctors
despite promises they are the issues
that we should be debating today not
more discussion about weaknesses and
whining at the top of the Tory party
so whining there is the accusation from
the labor leader kirstarma about the way
that Dominic Robb has resigned here is
the letter to which he is referring
because this is one of the most
extraordinary documents I've ever come
across when it comes to a resignation
letter it's not Dominic Robb's first
resignation letter by the way he
resigned as brexit secretary he's got
some practice at writing uh things like
that so he knows what he's doing and
which is why the language in this letter
what he says what he doesn't say is very
very interesting important and let's see
whether or not uh viewers at home think
uh that the charge of whining which uh
kirstana just made is fair because what
he does in the space of the two pages
and we'll come to the second one in a
moment is to effectively challenge the
entire investigation into him challenge
the verdict says he's only uh going
because he promised in the past and
takes aim at the people who worked
around him and then just in the briefest
thank yous to the Prime Minister pledges
his support but the tone of all of this
and the rejection the process that's led
to say makes me really wonder quite what
role Dominic Rod's gonna be having in
future so let's just take you through
the whole document because it's a it's a
it's quite a big thing so if we if we
just zoom in here uh to the first uh to
the first paragraph there you can see it
I called for the inquiry now by the way
he called for the inquiry because
there's quite a lot of media reporting
about his behavior and it was only then
that uh Dominic Robb wrote to Rishi
sunak and initiated this inquiry so he
didn't call for the inquiry after
goodness of his own heart he called for
the inquiry because um uh basically
politically he had to he called the
inquiry and undertook to resign if he
made if they made any finding of
bullying whatsoever I believe it is
important to keep my word right he
doesn't quite say it but this appears to
me to be Dominic Robb admitting he has
been found guilty of bullying so there
you have it the Deputy Prime Minister
admits being found guilty of bullying in
that key section uh uh of um of the
document right and then it goes on
uh it's just been a privilege to serve
you as uh as a depth prime minister and
Justice secretary let's skip to the next
important bit let's go down a little bit
whilst I feel Duty bound to accept the
outcome of the inquiry it dismissed all
but two of the claims leveled against me
so here we are in paragraph three of the
letter and all we know is that in two
cases Azam Tully upheld a judgment that
Dominic Robb was seen to have bullied
fellow members of Staff but he doesn't
concentrate on that he doesn't apologize
for that instead what he does is he
talks about all the other allegations
that he wasn't found guilty uh for of in
that so he begins by uh by going through
the report by talking about the stuff
that it dismissed and he talked about
that uh uh uh is the first thing that he
picked out from the report uh and he
then goes on to basically undermine the
entire basis of the report here he then
says the two adverse findings where he
was found effectively guilty of the
allegation are flawed and set a
dangerous precedent for the con conduct
of good government so while he accepts
the verdict in one paragraph two
paragraphs after that he says that the
findings that he's having to accept he
disagrees with so I think at the very
least you'll get critics saying that
this is something of a merely mild
resignation and although Downing streets
say they didn't push him it's quite
clear that Dominic Robb is deeply deeply
unhappy talking about the flaws in the
Adam Tully report that have led us to
this resignation today and goes on
leaning into that culture war that we're
seeing at the moment at the moment about
conduct in the workplace he goes on to
say it sets a dangerous precedent for
the conduct of good government so there
you have effectively a very senior
politician
who is attacking the entire basis of the
inquiry and saying it has detrimental uh
detrimental effects now I'm just going
to skip forward a couple more paragraphs
to this again absolutely extraordinary
way of dealing what uh what is a very
difficult moment for him uh what he does
rather than going through what he was
found guilty was of he talks about all
the things that the report didn't find
he had done it's quite a long list Mr
tolly concluded that I had not once in
four and a half years sworn or shouted
at anyone let alone thrown anything or
otherwise physically intimidated anyone
nor intentionally sought to belittle
anyone okay so the most important thing
in this sentence is this bit he didn't
intentionally sought to belittle anyone
well that reads to me like he's
admitting that actually the report
rightly found that he belittled somebody
he claims it was unintentional but but
that's not the focus of that sentence
that little admission there snuck on uh
in the final Clause instead he wants to
focus on the fact of the things he
hadn't done that he hasn't swore he
hasn't shouted and there we have the uh
Deputy Prime Minister until a few
minutes ago basically saying I never
threw anything uh so that's a basis on
which I can defend my conduct there is
something of an apology here I'm
genuinely sorry for any unintended
stress but it comes after those
paragraphs that you just saw where he's
talking about he rejects he rejects how
he has been treated and then he goes
back to effectively feeling sorry for
himself in setting the threshold for
bullying solo this inquiry has set a
dangerous precedent it will encourage
spurious complaints against ministers
and will have a chilling effect on those
driving change on behalf of your
government and ultimately the British
people now whilst again Danny Street say
they didn't push him and Dominic Rob
chose to resign it's going to be
interesting to see whether Rishi sunak
agrees with that I mean he didn't agree
with him sufficient that Richard sunat
looked at the Tully report and stood on
the steps of Downing straight and said I
actually don't think there's a problem
here and if I let this guy go it'll
create a chilling effect on my
government you know I don't I didn't
think Richard is going to end up
agreeing with Dominic Robb on that and
this is one piece of evidence I think
you can see many of the others that
point to the idea that really this
letter this extraordinary letter is
deeply deeply unhelpful and then he goes
on to continue his attacks this is the
second page of the letter
and now this is where he's really uh got
his boxing gloves off uh he is a boxer
of course Dominic Rob uh and uh is
taking on the Civil Service and he
attacks the uh he says the impropriaties
came to light in the course of this
inquiry and basically blamed civil
servants for leaking to the media uh he
said that this is an impropriety uh the
impropriety includes the systematic
leaking of skewed and fabricated claims
to the media in breached the rules of
the inquiry and the civil service code
so this is civil servants feeling that
they were belittled and they would say
bullied by the Deputy Prime Minister of
this country uh not finding any recalls
internally leaking details to the media
so that there could be an inquiry which
uh which has now concluded today and
basically Dominic Roberts defenses well
doing that leaking uh because they have
no other option uh that breached the
civil service code and then he goes on
to to basically fight another Target uh
this bit here
he talks about another impropriety is
and bear with me the coercive removal by
a senior official of dedicated private
secretaries from my Ministry of Justice
private office in October last year let
me just try and translate there that
would appear that here
Dominic Raab is making a direct exercise
attack on what I believe to be Antonio
Romeo she's the most senior civil
servant in the ministry of Justice very
high profile uh figure in that
department and what she's what he's
saying here is
um she seems to be referring to an
incident where um some of the more
junior members of that stuff were pulled
out of his private office to kind of
inner sanctum of his working uh he's the
word coercive it's an interesting word
uh to use that sort of in other words
she forced them to do it uh coercive uh
I think comes up in the it will come up
in this issue in other ways but
effectively saying she was wrong to
remove those people there have been
allegations that senior civil servants
had to remove more genuine ones from the
environment of the debt of the recently
accepted prime minister because they
couldn't uh they were they felt that it
was unfair uh the conduct the way that
they were treated and the conduct of the
Deputy Prime Minister uh was uh
effectively bullying so this is him
disputing that action ever needed to be
taken and then he goes and say well why
can't we have an inquiry into those why
can't inquiring to Antonio Romeo why
can't we have an inquiry into civil
servants leaking because they feel that
detective prime minister is is bullying
them but now he wants an inquiry uh into
into that and then we finish the letter
uh with this uh short sweet uh thank you
to Richie sunac uh references the fact
that he's one of the first backers in
2022 for his leadership campaign uh and
then briefly goes you've proved a great
prime minister in very challenging times
you can count on my support from the
back benches I mean I have to say
reading this reading this letter in
detail as we've been doing for the last
few moments I wouldn't even say that the
letter was supportive so I'm not quite
sure uh whether or not on that basis uh
you can well if this is supportive I
look forward to seeing uh what dominic
Robb does in future all in that that
that makes it one of the most
extraordinary resignation letters I've
ever seen and it doesn't suggest that uh
that Dominic Robb thinks that he has a
future in politics
um maybe even uh probably before long
finding it difficult to hold on to his
Isha and Walton's seat the sorry seat
under attack uh from the lib Dems could
even be contemplating exiting Parliament
at the next election because this is not
a letter that you write if you think
you're coming back into government
what's his future doesn't look good so
he slammed the door loudly as he heads
to the exit Dominic Rob no longer
Justice secretary no longer depicted
prime minister we await from the Prime
Minister whether he's going to replace
who he's going to replace Justice
secretary the title Justice secretary
with whether he's going to appoint
another deadly prime minister
all right uh Sam coach thank you very
much indeed for that fulsome analysis uh
there Let's cross over uh now to our
political correspondent Ali Fortescue uh
Ali many open questions today uh not
least who is going to replace Mr Rob in
his various roles are we likely to hear
from the Prime Minister today
we're gonna have to hear from the prime
minister at some point because it has
been strangely quiet we've been under on
number 10 for the last few hours and we
have barely seen anyone going in or out
and of course the Prime Minister has
been looking at this report he got it
about 9am yesterday in the end
um it was Dominic Robb who appeared to
go before being pushed but you've got to
it's important to stress the
significance of all of this and Rishi
seen that because Dominic Robb was right
in his inner circle one of his closest
allies the person who was out batting
for him backing him when he was the
underdog in the leadership election
against Liz truss sent of course into
Political Wilderness when Liz Strauss
became prime minister and then
resurrected uh when Rishi sunak uh
finally entered number 10. so today this
is a bigger moment this is not like
um when Nadim zahawi reside this is a
close Ally of Rishi sunak so we wait to
hear from the Prime Minister one of the
questions that is being asked now is why
Dominic was given such a big job in the
first place if these rumors were
swirling at that time so Rishi sunak I'm
sure will be in there we'll be working
out what he's going to say we expect to
hear from Danny streaks spokesperson in
the next couple of hours as is usual the
daily briefing with journalists
um who will replace Dominic Robb well
there have been a few names in the frame
uh Victoria aitkins he's been quite a
long time Minister currently the
financial secretary to the treasury
Victoria
um Apprentice has also been suggested as
a name that could be in the ring who of
course is at the moment the Attorney
General so already in cabinet Alex chalk
was a name that was said to me uh he of
course used to be in cabinet that is
currently a defense minister so
attention will soon turn to who might be
the new Justice secretary will the Prime
Minister appoint another deputy prime
minister it has been a hugely
significant moment Dominic Robb has had
a role on Frontline politics for such a
long time as Sam was saying questions
two now about whether he will stand in
his seat of Israel Morton in Surrey he
has a very slim majority there about two
and a half thousand I think the lib Dems
of course calling for a by-election I
doubt that will happen but there are
lots of questions for the former deputy
prime minister and of course the Russian
Act 2 who we still haven't heard from
and Ali Mr Robb hasn't wasted much time
in putting forward his side of events I
know you haven't been able to see it
yourself but um we've got hold of an
op-ed that he has written in the
telegraph which has just dropped in the
last few moments in which he describes
the whole process of this investigation
as a kafka-esque saga indeed the letter
the resignation letter that he wrote was
excoriating about the process
I mean that is fascinating as you said I
haven't read the article but he clearly
is not going quietly he does say
continues to support the government but
he obviously has views on how all of
this has been handled fascinating that
he has already as you say written in the
telegraph
um and I mean you can see pretty plainly
from his extraordinary resignation
letter that he has strong views he said
um it dismissed all but two of the
claims level against me and it's two
adverse findings are flawed and set a
dangerous precedent he talked about the
bar being set for bullying so low um
setting a dangerous precedent as well so
this is clearly not someone that is
happy I think the letter is quite bitter
in tone even though he does go on to
make some sort of apology and there will
be questions now about the whole issue
of bullying I'm sure and this clearly
was not a clear-cut we know that
certainly the civil servants that I have
spoken to some who say that he was a
tough robust boss others who feel that
he did cross a line into bullying I'm
sure there is a debate that will be had
over the coming days and questions too I
think for Rishi sunak and we still wait
to hear from him
all right Ali thank you very much indeed
we'll be going back to Ali as and when
there's any movement outside Downing
Street we are showing you that op-ed on
the screen now which uh Mr Rob has
penned for the telegraph today just to
bring you a little bit of detail uh from
it he describes the process of the
investigation as one in which normal
rules have been disapplied normal Rules
of Evidence and procedural fairness were
disapplied for example he says there is
a three-month time limit for bringing
bullying claims in an employment
tribunal while standard internal human
resources practice is to avoid
unreasonable delay because late claims
are unfair and unreliable in my case he
adds all the complaints were stored up
for over three months most over eight
months some for over four years and then
submitted he says in a coordinated way I
was subject to trial by media for six
months fueled by warped and fabricated
accounts leaked by Anonymous officials
breaching the rules of the inquiry the
Civil Service Code of Conduct or both uh
some further detail that he goes into as
well saying despite
these flaws the investigator Adam Tolley
Casey concluded that over four and a
half years I never once swore or shouted
at officials let alone threatened
targeted or threw anything at them the
claim that he goes on to say that I
threw Tomatoes was not even put to me
and separately led to a White Hall press
officer being investigated for spreading
misinformation contrary to leaks
suggesting more than 24 formal
complainants there were 15 since 2018
making mostly vague undated and
unsubstantiated claims from my time as
brexit secretary foreign secretary and
Justice secretary and so the op-ed goes
on so making it very clearly that Mr Rob
in his resignation this morning as
Deputy Prime Minister and Justice
secretary and law Chancellor will not be
going quietly that op-ed published in
the telegraph just within the last few
moments
now our political correspondent Liz
Bates has more now on the latest senior
figure in Richie's synac's government to
go
after months of denials I am confident
that I have behaved professionally
throughout I behave professionally
throughout Vision throughout
professionally at all times
it's all over for Dominic Rabb the
latest senior figure ousted from Rishi
sunak's government amid a scandal of his
own making damaging the Prime Minister
who defended his Justice secretary even
as the bullying allegations mounted it
brings to an end a long ministerial
career we will be able to restore
control over our immigration policy and
our border controls a prominent
brexiteer he was brought in as brexit
secretary to try to get a deal Over The
Line
but stood down just a few months later
delivering a brutal blow to Theresa
May's fragile Premiership ultimately it
comes down to the political leadership
that we've got
he then stood unsuccessfully to take
over the top job before throwing his
weight behind the front runner
rewarded for his loyalty to Boris
Johnson he was made second in command
Deputy Prime Minister and foreign
secretary so senior that when the Prime
Minister was hospitalized with kovid it
was Dominic Rabb that stepped up to run
the country in his absence if there's
one thing I know about this prime
minister
he's a fighter elected in 2010 my name
is Dominic Robb unapologetically on the
right of his party I'm a tour
I don't support the Human Rights Act and
I don't believe in economic and social
rights this is looking like a very tense
exchange known for not always being in
control of his temper here he is caught
on camera backstage at a 2019 election
events
she's squaring up to a labor MP
his views on women have also drawn
criticism he said repeatedly he's not a
feminist which might explain why he
winked at Labor's Deputy leader in the
House of Commons
bullying claims have dogged him for
years but came to a head just in the
last few months as dozens of civil
servants came forward to give evidence
against him
the head of the Civil Service union says
it was long overdue I think it's clear
several servants haven't felt they could
challenge the behavior of a minister
it's clear to yours this is not just
about Dominic Rabb this is a broader
cultural issue about ministers and their
conduct and a belief that they can get
away with it
a close Ally of Rishi sunak his
departure has just added to the prime
minister's problems as he now faces
questions over what he knew about his
Justice secretary's Behavior
for those who say they were bullied by
Dominic Rabb though this exit is long
overdue
Liz Bates Sky News Westminster
so back to our Deputy political editor
Sam Coates uh Sam we were looking in
detail at that resignation letter which
you described as very much of slamming
the door shut behind him looking at some
of the detail of the op-ed that he has
written in the telegraph that has just
been published that that appears almost
like he's he's pulling the pin on the
grenade and lobbing it through the
window
that's right Sam I I
it's fair to say that Dominique Rob
isn't going quietly and we're going to
go through that uh Telegraph piece
extraordinary piece yet more attacks all
over the place uh in just a few minutes
but just right now I want to bring you a
little update a very specific update uh
on Dominic so welcome back to the letter
this is page two of it we were going
through it earlier
um and there's something of a fight back
going on something around developing
about this paragraph here now this is
the paragraph where Dominic Robb calls
for a independent inquiry into some of
the people that he says were maneuvering
uh against him uh he talked about how he
really profoundly disagrees with the
leaking which he says is in breach of
the civil service code which uh
ultimately led to the inquiry that today
led to his dismissal but it's this bit
and there's something to fight back let
me just pick up the the piece of paper
with the details he picks up on an
incident that happens that he says um
was the uh it took place in October last
year and it was the coercive removal by
a senior official of dedicated private
secretaries from my Ministry of Justice
private office right let's explain I now
have a better understanding of what what
he's referring to and what there are
some people in Whitehall are really
quite angry uh with his use of the word
uh coercive law of unhappiness at that
incredibly politically loaded uh word
what appears happened is last October a
there was what I understand to be and
what is being termed in Whitehall a
welfare decision and staff were moved
for a short period of time out of the
office immediately adjacent to Dominic
Raab that in itself is just
extraordinary that is my understanding
that the the sort of the the essential
uh uh suggestion that staff are moved
away from Dominic Robb because of his uh
Behavior he acknowledges it here I
understand that that is true but there
is an absolute rejection that that was
coercive and it is quite clear that uh
Dominic Robb is pointing the finger he
wants an independent inquiry into the
senior official who who did that now I'm
told that the permanent Secretary of
that department Antonio rabio was aware
of that decision but it wasn't her
decision uh now we don't know who
Dominic Robb's referring to by the
senior official but he'd be pretty
certain that uh that she's one of the
top contenders of who's referring to but
she didn't make that decision but the
idea I'm told that that could be
presented as a coercive is is absolutely
rejected inside Whitehall no one was
coerced after they left for a short
period of time they were allowed to
return if they wanted to or they could
be deployed into other places but the
idea that people were being forced to do
this against their will is utterly wrong
I'm told and and I understand and but
more than anything else to dig a hole
for himself by referring to this you
know at the point at which senior
officials are having to move junior
staff away from you then that's not good
and now there is a row over that loaded
politically loaded word uh Coe said
nobody I'm told was forced to do that
and it's a sign of just the bitterness
and anger inside Downing Street uh
inside Whitehall at what uh Dominic
Rob's done the fury of Dominic Raab
which in a moment uh we'll see in
underneath the telegraph as well as this
letter there's a lot more anger to come
today uh Sam this is not an easy
departure for the prime minister
yeah busier Friday afternoon than we
both expected some thank you very much
in indeed and just to update you some
more breaking news we understand uh that
the PM uh has accepted Dominic Robb's
resignation we understand with great
sadness uh we assume that probably comes
from a letter in response to his
resignation letter we haven't got hold
of that yet but we will of course bring
it to you as and when we do get it but
joining me live in the studio now is the
Deputy leader of the labor party Angela
Rayner a good to see you Angela
um I'm presuming you're not viewing this
resignation with great sadness no I feel
really sorry for the people who have had
to endure months of coming forward with
the allegations against Dominic Robb and
then Rob resign and in the way that he
has this morning which is incredibly
defiant for a resignation accepting the
findings on the report and you know for
the Prime Minister say he's incredibly
sad well I'm incredibly sad that the
Prime Minister can't take the action
that was needed to protect civil
servants that are trying to go about
their day and it makes everybody feel
like you know the prime minister is weak
and doesn't see bullying in the
workplace as seriously saw this with the
previous prime minister who allowed um
one of the cabinet ministers to bully
someone they were found to have breached
the ministerial code for bullying and
was allowed to continue in their job
quite different though isn't it he
received the report yesterday and by
this morning there is a resignation from
Dominic Robb so you could say he has
acted quickly and decisively well I
would argue that's not the case because
of course prime minister knew about the
allegations against Dominic before he
appointed into cabinet we've had three
there were allegations they weren't
there and they could have been
investigated and that could have been
dealt with before you appoint someone
into a significant senior position and
now we see even now with the resignation
this Defiance this lack of
self-awareness about what he's actually
done you know the the threshold for
bullying well if you've been found
bullying that's bullying there's no
there's no threshold for bullying you
know it's completely unacceptable to
frame it in that way and if I was one of
those victims this morning who cannot
speak out because of the process I would
be feeling absolutely devastated and it
sends the wrong message for the rest of
the civil servants who have to have
confidence that they can raise concerns
and can work in the interests of our
country if you've got a prime minister
who's too weak to deal with these issues
then for me that will lead to risks
around governance around being able to
raise issues and to come forward with
the what's best and what's in the
interests of the Civil Service and these
people know their job they know it's you
know it's not a question of oh is your
interpretation these people are senior
civil servants they know their job that
they're carrying out and I think it's
just completely wrong that a Dominic
Rabb thinks he can frame it in this way
and that the prime minister to be saying
I'm really sad you're leaving well you
shouldn't have appointed him in the
first place we understand that that
report has now been published as soon as
we're able to bring you details of it we
will get some coats to be providing some
analysis of it um now he was effectively
your counterpart you faced off against
against him many times
um what was your sense of the man and of
his behavior I mean for me he was my
political opponent he was my political
peer so you know the relationship the
Power Balance there is different to if
you're working you know if you work for
me if you work for a senior
Minister like the Deputy Prime Minister
then there's a power imbalance
immediately there so you have to have
self-awareness about relationships and
conduct in the workplace myself and
Dominic are politicians and we robustly
go at each other at the dispatch box and
that's different but when you're taking
advice when you're working with civil
servants that is a different
relationship and you have have to be
aware as a leader about the conduct that
you put you know you bring out in the
office because you set the culture and
for all of those people to come forward
not one not two many people to come
forward notwithstanding what happened
previously where a civil servant came
forward and lost their job after it
being found that they've been bullied it
must have took significant bravery for
them to come forward and therefore I
don't think this is an interpretation of
somebody's conducting office this is
clear that those people felt there was
bullying and the fact that Dominic Rabb
has resigned tells me even in his
Defiance that he knows there's something
there it's going to play uh quite well
though isn't it to the crowd of people
that will read the op-ed in the
Telegraph and think well you know the
Tory party need to stand up to what you
know has been pejoratively termed The
Blob of the Civil the power of the Civil
Service well I don't accept that you
know civil servants have worked under
all different political leadership and
I'm sure conservative former Prime
Ministers would say exactly the same
they act and they've got a cold and they
act in a particular way I'm really I'm
really sorry to interrupt you now but we
have just received the prime minister's
response letter to dominate Rob and I'll
just read that out because it might
inform some of our subsequent discussion
uh it reads dear Dominic thank you for
your letter notifying me of your
decision to resign from your position in
his Majesty's government as Deputy Prime
Minister and Lord Chancellor and
Secretary of State for justice it is
with great sadness that I have accepted
your resignation when I became prime
minister in October last year I pledged
that the government I lead would have
integrity professionalism and
accountability at every level the
ministerial code requires ministers to
uphold the highest standards when formal
complaints about your conduct in
different ministerial posts were
submitted last year I appointed at your
request just an independent investigator
to conduct a full investigation into the
specific facts surrounding these
complaints Adam Tolley Casey has now
submitted his report and I have
carefully considered its findings as
well as Consulting the independent
advisor on Minister's interests
as you say you had rightly undertaken to
resign if the report made any finding of
bullying whatsoever you have kept your
word but it is clear that there have
been shortcomings in the historic
process that have negatively affected
everyone involved we should learn
we should but it's clear there have been
shortcomings in the historic process
that have negatively affected everyone
involved we should learn from this how
to better handle such matters in future
but your resignation should not make us
forget your record of delivery in both
this government and previous
Administrations
these achievements should make you
extremely proud most recently as
Secretary of State for justice and Lord
Chancellor you have put the rights of
victims at the heart of our criminal
justice system through our Landmark
victims and prisoners bill as well as
increasing sentences for violent
criminals
reforming the probation system and
pushing forward the biggest prison
building program this country has seen
in over a century as foreign secretary
you were a major driving force of the
2021 integrated review conceiving and
delivering the indo-pacific Tilt I know
the personal drive you also displayed to
create the UK's new independent
sanctions regime and in our response to
the undermining of Human Rights and
democracy in Hong Kong it goes on during
the covert crisis you stepped in when
the then prime minister was hospitalized
you provided the country and your
cabinet colleagues with reassurance and
Leadership at a moment of profound
National concern as Chancellor at the
time I was struck by the Collegiate way
in which you handled this most difficult
of challenges I will always be grateful
for your steadfast personal support
during last year's conservative party
leadership contest from the day you
introduced me at the launch to the last
day of the contest the subsequent
dedication commitment and loyalty with
which you have discharged your
responsibilities as Deputy Prime
Minister has been typical of your belief
in public service I look forward to
receiving your support from the back
benches as you continue to passionately
represent your constituents of Isha and
Walton thank you for your service to
this and previous governments and I wish
you and your family every possible
success for the future yours sincerely
Rishi sinak of course the Prime Minister
let's bring back in our Deputy political
editor as Sam Coates who has also been
looking at that letter which we have
just received there's something of an
asymmetry isn't there Sam in the um in
the complementary nature of what the
Prime Minister has put out in response
to Dominic Robb's resignation and indeed
in in what dominic Robb himself had to
say with respect to his support of the
Prime Minister oh you oh Sam you put it
much more politely than I would have
done uh I would say that the Prime
Minister was Far nicer about Dominic
robbed and Dominic Rob was about the
prime minister in that letter
um and although the tributes were
fulsome and lengthy going through uh all
of the uh sexual straight jobs that
Dominic Robb uh had done there was a
blunt acknowledgment at the heart the
prime minister's letter uh that there
was enough in Adam Tully's report that
meant he had to go but
now we have the Tully report and we have
just in the last uh few minutes started
to go through that Rapport and so if I
may Sam I'm just going to start to take
you through some of the bits now it's
written in in a in a very Barrister
legalistic way and so you have to Wade
through pages and pages of terms of
reference and and uh uh uh details about
the ministerial code and who does what
and all the rest of it uh yeah it's page
35 before you start getting to the
conclusions that Adam Tully reached uh
and here we are let's just um let's just
read them for the first time together uh
it says that the complaints were
submitted in early November mid-november
the 15th of November uh and uh he has
now concluded his investigation uh this
paragraph 152 I think is uh one of the
most important that we're going to have
and we're going to highlight it and read
it together now the uh the Dominic Raab
worked in a particular way which he felt
he was entitled to as a form of
legitimate management Choice the Deputy
Prime Minister Dominic Raab had formed
in adverse view as to the way in which
civil servants had acted in relation to
an ongoing work project so there was
there were issues that Adam Tolley says
that Dominic Robb was cross about uh and
um uh he has assumed that the Prime
Minister was entitled to form that view
however this this appears to be one of
the key judgments in this report however
as part of the process towards
implementing this management choice so
there was a in other words we're talking
about a specific incident here rather
than a generalized assessment in this
specific instant he acted in a way which
was intimidating in the sense of
unreasonably and persistently aggressive
in the context of a workplace meeting so
there you have it that's an
extraordinary sentence the Deputy Prime
Minister until this morning of this
country acted in a way which was
intimidating in the sense of
unreasonably and persistently aggressive
in the context of a workplace meeting
let's go on and go further his conduct
also involved an abuse or a misuse of
power in a May that undermines or
humiliates an abusive power the Deputy
Prime Minister in a way that undermines
or humiliates don't forget as we've saw
from his letter dominant Robb contesting
the judgments here saying that he's
being treated unfairly rejecting the
basis uh about uh against which he has
been judged at fault uh he would say
that's that that that that is setting
the bar too low that you can't really
conduct government if people are going
to come out and judge and judge him on
this basis but here it is in black and
white page 35 paragraph 152 uh he abused
his power in order to undermine and
humiliate in particular he went beyond
what was reasonably necessary in order
to give effect uh to his decision and
introduce a punitive element his conduct
was bound to be experienced as an
undermining or humiliating by the uh his
conduct was bound to be experienced as
undermining or humiliating by the
affected individual and it was so
experienced and further prime minister
must have been aware of this effect the
very least he ought to be reasonably
reasonably uh have been so in other
words Adam Dolly thinks that Dominic Rob
ought to have known that what he was
doing was abusing his power intimidating
his staff and being aggressive in a
workplace meeting let's go into the next
page
if we can here we go uh and he talks
about another incident uh that had a
significant adverse effect on particular
individuals the uh Dominic Royals
Behavior Uh was a form of intimidating
behavior in the sense of conveying a
threat of unspecified disciplinary
action he did not Target any individual
nor intend to threaten anyone with
disability reaction however he ought to
have realized that referring in this way
to the Civil Service Code it would be
understand it would be understood to be
something of a threat so we're now going
to go on to paragraph 172 where there's
more of uh this uh it's a lot it's a
very lengthy and complicated report but
and and navigating it is uh
uh here so uh one seven one uh I'm gonna
do one more one page further uh to one
uh oh it's a very very lengthy 171. uh
still going uh and here is uh paragraph
one seven two
and what we see here is 173 uh he uh
overall I uh conclude that the Deputy
Prime Minister's contact during his
period as Secretary of State for justice
was on some occasions abrasive in the
sense of a personal style uh which is
intimidating or insulting to individuals
but is not intended to be sue his
conduct was not abusive in the sense of
behavior which is intended to be
specifically uh targeted uh but he
should have altered his approach earlier
particularly after concerns were raised
with him so you've got the flavor of
some of the most significant things in
that report uh we'll bring you more uh
imminently Sam
thank you very much in D as Sam was
saying that is a lengthy legal document
so we're just going to give him chance
to catch his breath and uh be able to
take stock and look through it before
going back to him for some more
takeaways from what is actually in that
report let's go back to the deputy
leader of the labor party Angela Rayner
um we were a mid-conversation weren't we
well thank you for your for your
patience but the news is coming in thick
and fast
um your read of this Dominic Robb did
say that if he was found of bullying he
would resign do you get the sense that
he willingly tended that resignation or
did the Prime Minister forces hand I
don't get the sense that the prime
minister or Dominic Rabb understand the
seriousness of that report and the
findings within it there seems to be a
sheer lack of self-awareness around the
intent the a senior level should have
known that your actions would have been
perceived in that way and and how that
affected people and there was no apology
it's it's like backslapping oh you did a
good job you're not sorry well it was a
oh I've done a great job
the process was horrible to me in
Dominic rabbs
and Rishi sunax response was not your
conduct fell below standards this is
terrible we've got to have the highest
standards it was you've done a great job
which by the way I'd argue that's not
the case in justice but it was literally
look at all these wonderful things
you've done thank you I'm really sad
you're leaving that report is very clear
that the Deputy Prime Minister of this
country bullied and intimidated people
in their workplace if they were if you
were the victims of that bullying today
you would be feeling that even though
Dominic Rabb has resigned that there is
no
um awareness and no acknowledgment of
what's happened or ability to put it
right just over 24 hours later he's gone
I imagine he possibly wasn't even in the
office today which may be a relief to
the some of the civil servants
um that were working for him
action has been taken well he's gone
quickly and the ministerial code has
changed he didn't have to be sacked did
he could have been sanctioned in a
different way so you could argue that
this is Rishi sunak
um bringing to Bear exactly what he
pledged on the steps of Downing Street
integrity and accountability what it
looks like to me is that they've tried
to get ahead of the report being
published because when you hear what Sam
coax was reading out in that report
that's pretty damning so his Dominic's
resignation came choreographed with
vicious with no acknowledgment of what's
happened here just uh oh you've done a
really great job and oh the process
isn't isn't quite right without the
acknowledgment actually of the
substantive issues within that report so
it's almost like trying to damage
limitate what's happened here I don't
see um Dominic rabb's resignation as
having Integrity he's not fought about
his actions he's not acknowledged what
he's done in his resignation letter and
I don't see the prime minister's
acknowledgment and of the resignation as
doing any justice to those people that
have faced bullying and recognizing
what's happened here and what he's
enabled because of course he knew about
these allegations before he appointed
him and even now with that report I
don't think the Prime Minister has
responded to this in a way that you
would expect a leader to respond when
that level of misconduct has happened in
a senior office Dominic Robb in his
op-ed in the telegraph writes about how
he feels that the process has been
unfair normal rules disapplied he says
that many of these complaints should
have been timed out because of the
three-month time limit for bringing
bullying claims and then says that they
were then submitted in a coordinated way
what is your response to that have you
ever had a sense with civil civil
servants that those kind of situations
no can arise if I mean first of all
first of all vicious brought Dominic
Rabb back into cabinet and that's where
the trigger was for many people who had
felt relief that he wasn't there that
that wasn't going to be the case it's
pretty clear that as soon as he was
brought back into cabinet these people
were frightened that he was going to be
back in the workplace and raised it I
don't think that's a problem with that I
think if you look at the context to
which these people came forward as well
as I said before the former prime
minister allowed a Cabinet member to
bully a senior civil servant and the
cabinet member kept their job and the
civil servant had to leave even though
they were the ones that were found to
have been bullied so for civil servants
under that context to bring forward
these allegations I would say this is
not a question of coordination it must
have been incredibly Brave of them and
very scary for them to bring those
allegations to the fore in the context
but they obviously believed what Rishi
sunak said and that he wanted to drive
forward as prime minister with these
integrity and we with these values and
we've seen actually that hasn't been the
case and I think his letter to Dominic
rabbit is absolutely disgusting and
doesn't acknowledge the seriousness of
what's happened Angela Rayner thank you
very much for your time thank you
well earlier the former special advisor
to William hey Chris White gave his
reaction to dominate Robb's resignation
Rishi sunak as prime minister when he
came into office made it very clear that
in his first speech that he said that
this government will have integrity
professionalism and accountability and
that was a clear attempt to
differentiate himself from uh previous
incumbent of Downing Street and Boris
Johnson and the issues that the
conservative party in government had had
during their year in office as prime
minister in the end of
2022 so I think that um clearly he was
really only left with one option and
whilst sources in number 10 are
suggesting that he was not pushed I
think there would have been some
encouragement uh before the Deputy Prime
Minister to head towards the exit
well joining me now is the former
special advisor to Amber Rudd Mo Hussein
Mo good to see you this morning
um I had to catch myself there it is
still morning it feels like a long one
already
um have you ever seen a resignation
letter like that
um I've seen a few resignation letters
but this seems quite loaded uh and uh
clearly lines have not been drawn under
the issue at all uh Dominic is Cooley
very unhappy about the process and uh
how the last few months have played out
and whilst I don't think he will he's
not one of the awkward Squad he's very
close to the Prime Minister he's not
really aligned to uh the trust faction
or anybody else I don't think it will
cause problems to the Prime Minister on
the back benches but he clearly has real
uh beef with what's happened real issues
with how the Civil Service have behaved
and I don't think this is the at the end
of the matter by any means no uh he's
clearly not going quietly as he uh
certainly his op-ed in the telegrapher
would indicate that he is definitely
going to make as much noise as he can on
the way out um Angela Rayner was just
sitting in the studio with mimo and she
was saying that this whole episode
reveals the weakness of his Premiership
he shouldn't have appointed him he took
too long over it
yeah I mean I think there are there are
questions around the appointment given
that uh we're told informally the Prime
Minister was aware of some of these
things but equally in the thrust of a
leadership campaign Dominique was a real
uh strong Ally and a strong supporter
for him and I think that will have been
remembered on the point of him looking
weak uh that is uh the easy allegation
to make and I can see why people would
think that because he did take some time
and he didn't take the decision to sack
Dominic however politically I think this
outcome is a lot better for the Prime
Minister we're a few weeks out from
local election campaign and also the
Prime Minister has not got the popular
mandate he didn't have the Mandate from
Members he's dependent on his NPS and
he's trying to strike the balance
between trying to keep different
factions of the party happy and there
will be many MPS on the conservative
backbenchers who are unhappy that this
looks like uh the Civil Service and the
blob as they perhaps to call it has
scored a victory over a cabinet minister
that kind of us and them mentality so
when the Prime Minister did not have to
really appine and not really have to
take aside but just accept the
resignation is politically I think an
easier situation even though there is
this initial allegation of not being
decisive or not making a decision
quickly enough yeah I mean you rightly
point out there it's been a rocky
relationship between the this recent
conservative uh well succession of
conservative governments and the civil
service is this going to be viewed as a
Line in the Sand you know Dominic Robb
was somebody who had a uniquely poor
relationship with civil servants and
he's now gone or is this just going to
make things worse yeah I think this case
clearly spans several different
departments and probably goes back quite
a long time as well so it does seem that
uh there are particular issues with uh
with Dominic and the people who worked
with him and around him but I don't
think this is the end of the matter
there'll clearly be tensions and I work
in government both as a civil servants
and as a special advisor and there is
always attention in terms of new
ministers coming in some civil servants
thinking well how long will you be here
for this is how we've always done things
uh and ministers clearly wanting change
impact uh delivery they don't know how
long they'll be there for so they need
to make their Mark and so you can have
these creative tensions which I think
actually sometimes strengthen policy
making and do have a positive impact but
when they stray into what we're seeing
now in the report and words around abuse
of power and things this is clearly uh
much uh much more of a problem and a
really serious issue and I don't think
the these uh tensions and the
relationship as fractured as it now is
between the Civil Service and elements
of the government is just going to
improve overnight all right saying good
to get your thoughts on Sky News thank
you very much
indeed let's go back to our Deputy
political editor Sam coats who's had a
further opportunity to sift through that
report uh there from Adam tollisam
that's my thank yes it's a 60-page
report and it's quite dense and so
there's a lot in here and so we'll keep
going through it and there's no doubt
there are extremely uncomfortable
elements of this report for the now ex
Deputy Prime Minister uh talking about
his behavior the way he treated civil
servants but
but there's something else this is
really weird I just want to bring it to
you uh straight away because
um there is as you'll have noticed from
the way that Dominic Raab is trying to
defend himself this suggestion that
perhaps some of the complainants had
other motives other than simply to raise
issues of conduct and and if you look
here at this is Page 37.
and it's worth just uh pausing for a
moment as we as we uh as we approach 12
o'clock because what what it says here
is is really fascinating it said that
there was a group that did organized
complaints of non-senior policy
officials uh and uh the complaint was
Collective and it was the product of
discussions within an informal Network
inside the ministry of justice and they
didn't know how many civil servants a
part of that and for the purposes of
this investigation it was called the MOJ
group complaint but here's the thing
just just pause and think about this
only some of those individuals had any
direct experience of the Deputy Prime
Minister some had never met him at all
but were seeking to support their
colleagues
in other words there is as a finding a
fact from Adam Tolley apparently there
was a group of civil servants
coordinating some of who had no direct
personal experience of Dominic Royal's
Behavior who nevertheless were seeking
to basically escalate the escalate the
complaints and effectively uh presumably
uh getting out of his job over the next
coming days there's gonna be a huge
argument a huge argument about the role
of the Civil Service whether or not
Whitehall succeeded in pushing out Rob
who politically they weren't terribly
comfortable with and I think when we
when we have that discussion uh this um
this paragraph paragraph 160 161 where
it turns out some of the people who were
pushing the complaints had never met
Dominic Robb inside the ministry of just
that I think is going to be used by
those seeking to protect in some way uh
some of the reputation of Dominic Rob as
he uh as he leaves government and heads
to the back bench he's like I suspect
this bit actually is one of the reasons
why it's taken so long we've all been
puzzling why uh Rishi sunak why Dominic
Robb didn't come to a clean conclusion
yesterday
this is it this is it there were group
there were the report says there was a
group of civil servants some of whom had
never met him who were coordinating and
working against the Deputy Prime
Minister uh to try and get him out of a
job uh and uh they were in fact they
were they were working on on this
project on this Rob project uh as early
back as March 2022 and then
uh and then they took uh they tried
again in November when it the whole
issue uh entered the media so that is a
complication in this and a story that
we'll tell in just a few seconds about
what the report did find about Dominic's
Rob's Behavior Uh but there are just
bits in that report that suggest that
the overall picture is much much more
complicated and as we go into a phase
where you know the Prime Minister
actually pretty nice about Dominic Robin
his exit letter uh there will be some
sympathy uh in Tory circles about what's
happened to him and that that paragraph
about the coordinated uh effort by Civil
Service you've never met Dominic Robb to
get him out of the job well that is
going to be front and center of the
discussion
all right uh thank you very much in
indeed to Sam coats we'll be coming back
to him for more analysis shortly
in the meantime a good afternoon from
Westminster if you're just tuning in
Dominic Robb has resigned from
government following the conclusion of
an inquiry into bullying allegations the
report by a senior lawyer Casey has just
been published in the last few moments
that it found the Deputy Prime Minister
acted in an intimidating fashion with
unreasonably and persistently aggressive
conduct in a work meeting while he was
foreign secretary Mr Rob said it was
important to keep his word that he would
step down if it was found that he had
bullied officials but he still insisted
that the two findings made against him
were flawed and set a dangerous
precedent well we can go back to our
Deputy political editor some codes Sam I
hope you've had a chance to draw breaths
talking to you
um Talk us through for the benefit of
our viewers uh just tuning in
um the letter the resignation letter
from Dominic Robb and indeed what is in
that report that prompted the
resignation
a huge amount to get through Sam but
this is the document at the heart of it
it dropped about an hour ago and it is
these almost 60 page report into Dominic
Rob's Behavior it's taken five months to
get this far two complaints upheld the
rest dismissed uh there's a lot that
Dominic Robb will have found very
painful to read there's a lot that
suggests that he doesn't accept the
accusations of bullying and it's quite
explicit that although there are
findings that he behaved improperly he
doesn't believe he did so even now
that's clear uh from the document from
the letters that have been exchanged and
from the telegraph article that has just
come out but ultimately the bottom line
is that Dominic Robb is now out as
Deputy Prime Minister and as Justice
secretary because of the conclusions of
this report now I'm going to take you
I'm going to whiz you through as quickly
as possible uh some of the key bits that
we've managed to find uh in the last um
uh half an hour or so so we'll just
flash through various bits uh and it was
uh and this document really uh talks
about
um uh goes through inordinate detail
Adam Tully talked to Rob uh in which
Dominic Rob admitted that he was in his
own word inquisitorial direct impatient
and fastidious so Dominic Robert is
admitting some bits of behavior that he
thinks are absolutely uh a fine clearly
what he wants to do is make the case
that different interpretations of
behavior are what's going on here
um and that uh but as you get into the
report you can see here
uh that uh views differed uh and the it
was the precise nature of the way that
Dominic Rob liked to conduct uh uh uh
his work they'd like to conduct business
with his officials that caused in the
words of Adam Tully uh to distress uh
perhaps even harms the health of the
people that worked around him uh Dominic
Robert said it was my exacting standards
uh uh Adam Tolley doesn't come down on
his side in a number of uh respects but
this paragraph here gives you a sense of
the kinds of uh things that we're
dealing with so he thinks Dominic Robb
thinks that things are frustrating as
he's working inside uh the ministry of
Justice
um but here are the sort of Demands that
he's making he prefers to receive papers
in a set format so that he can quickly
assimilate the information in question
if this work is not provided to his
satisfaction he will in general say so
if in the course of meeting an attendee
does not in the PM Deputy Prime
Minister's view answer a question in the
manner which he regards as direct and
straightforward the Deputy Prime
Minister will likely interrupt one of
the key questions in relation to some of
the complaints uh is the is whether or
not the debt prime minister's style of
Conduct in a meeting and in particular
when frustrated goes beyond what would
normally be regarded as acceptable and
that's where we end up with a division
Dominic Robb says it was acceptable Adam
Tolley says it wasn't acceptable
ultimately he's left his job but this is
a conversation Sam that's not going to
finish today uh it's got a long way to
go as as different people have different
views of what happens in the workplace
and different approaches to it and he
says
as part of that
as we go through this report you come
across extraordinary paragraphs take
this one it's about the use of physical
gestures I heard a good deal of evidence
about the depth prime minister's use of
physical gestures in communication at
the most extreme and uh and which would
have been unacceptable this was put as
extending his hand directly out towards
another person's face with a view to
making them stop talking another example
of such is an allegation of loud banging
of a table to make a point at the upper
at the end of the spectrum he would be
which would be regarded as acceptable he
used defensive gestures to suggest that
a person should hold off from speaking
further so so this is an unacceptable an
unacceptable example of Dominic Ross
behavior in Adam tolley's view is
extending his harm his uh his hand
directly out towards another person's
face with a view to making them stop
talking so everybody at home will have a
view whether they think that is
acceptable or unacceptable Adam Tully
says in the workplace that is
unacceptable uh Dominic Robb it would
appear disagrees
um but let's look at some of the things
uh that happened when Dominic Robert's
foreign secretary uh that uh talked
about later uh in the report
and there was an incident uh when he was
in the in the foreign foreign office and
uh he had formed an adverse view in the
way about the way that his officials
were conducting their work about a
particular project and doesn't say what
the project is but there was uh
something uh the Deputy Prime Minister
the front secretary was uh was unhappy
with
um as part of the process towards and
the implementation of a management
Choice uh he uh acted in a way which was
intimidating in the sense of
unreasonably and persistently aggressive
uh it goes on uh in the context of a
workplace meeting his conduct also
involved an abuse or a misuse of power
in the way to humiliate and undermine in
particular he went beyond what was
reasonably necessary in order to give
effect to his decision and introduce a
punitive element his contact was bound
to be experienced as undermining or
humiliating by the affected individual
and so it was experience so that's the
sort of nub of the of the kind of
allegation that you get in parts of this
report basically he was humiliating
staff undermining their confidence
um he would say he was pursuing exacting
standards and he was trying to uphold an
efficient workplace to get stuff done
but Adam Tolley say it did undermine and
humiliate uh civil servants who were
working uh with him and said he should
have been aware of this Dominic Rob
disagrees that this was bullying uh but
he should have done uh according to uh
that report
uh if we go on uh you can see that in
one case it had a significant adverse
effect on a particular individual in one
complaint uh who took it uh seriously
the Deputy Prime Minister's conduct was
a form of intimidating behavior in the
sense of conveying a threat of
unspecified display so the allegation
there is if you don't do the stuff in
the way that I like it you'll face some
kind of disciplinary sanction
um and uh the basically what you've got
there uh is Adam Tolley saying that he
should have realized uh that in like the
threat came through the basically it's
seeing Dominic Rob going yeah you do
know you'll be in breach of the civil
service code if you if you continue to
act like that uh basically Adam's Tully
saying that kind of way of acting was
unacceptable uh let's look at the next
uh bit sometimes the Deputy Prime
Minister Dominic Robert take a strong
view that officials should have been
prepared should be prepared in advance
to answer his questions at a meeting and
in the event that he cannot do so offers
largely unconstructed criticism about
the banner so you don't come to my
meetings and and you're going to get
something of a roasting uh you know
Dominic Rob would say necessary to in
order to ensure that civil servants do
come prepared to a meeting it's quite
perfectly fair to get cross if the
people who work for you aren't ready
with the answer to the questions you
think uh and uh one of the things that
the Deputy Prime Minister used to do it
would seem in the absence uh would be to
complain about the ABS of what he would
call basic information or we go on about
the basics you haven't got Basics the
public airing of a comment of this kind
where others are present are not or may
not be well placed to judge whether the
criticism is well founded it's likely to
be experienced as an unfairly personal
criticism by the individual uh to whom
the comment is directed and was so
experienced by some individuals this is
again where this whole issue goes back
away from a subject of Law and actually
comes back in terms of politics is
somebody is the boss of an organization
standing there or sitting there okay
look you haven't just haven't done any
homework you haven't done the basics you
haven't got the got the information that
I want is that bullying is that
harassment is that not you know this is
something that ultimately has resulted
in Dominic Rob losing his job but
everybody at home will have their own
view about what they think constitutes
bullying what's acceptable in the
workplace
um and what uh was going on uh here we
go uh this is this is from the
conclusions Adam Tully says I overall
conclude that Dominic Rod's conduct
During the period that he was Secretary
of State for justice was on some
occasions abrasive do we think that's
acceptable or unacceptable everyone have
a view on that in terms of his personal
style which is intimidating or insulting
to individuals but not intended to do so
his conduct however was not abusive in
the sense of behavior which was intended
and specifically targeted so there is
some uh there is some limit to the
Judgment adverse judgment that Adam
Tully is willing to make says he isn't
abusive he has been able to regulate
this level of abrasiveness since the
announcement of the investigation so
he's improved his his behavior in the
last five months but Dominic Raab should
have altered his approach earlier
particularly after two of the most
senior civil servants in Whitehall took
him aside and said look you've got to
treat people uh better does he regret
what he did well here it says he has not
offered any apology given that he does
not accept anything uh was wrong uh and
so I think there you get the difference
between his View and the lawyers and you
can see how really this uh breaks down
and it's going to end up being a
something of a talking point for some uh
time to come and then towards the end of
the conclusions you've got more uh sense
that Dominic Raab acted in a manner
which was intimidating going further
than necessary in order to deliver
critical feedback making unconstructive
critical comments about the quality of
work done and wanted uh stuff about the
basics so there you get the overall
sense of what we're talking about
Dominic Robin his letter making clear
what this is not so I'm going to jump
across to Dominic Robb's letter so he's
read the report this is him highlighting
what he thinks of the fair points and
the unfair points in the letter that I
think it's fair to say it doesn't make
him sound like he's thrilled with the
conclusions and the Judgment of Adam
Tolley but since he pledged on Sophie
ridges program and at the start of this
process to resign at the moment that if
he was a fan of bullied or harassed
anybody he has gone and he says it's
important to keep my word
but here you've heard Adam tolley's
verdict on Dominic Ralph's behavior
let's hear Adam let's say Dominic Robb's
verdict uh on Dominic uh Rob's behavior
um he's he points out
um that actually the report didn't find
that he he behaved uh badly in lots of
different uh um uh uh types of ways so
um ministers must be able to give direct
critical feedback on briefings and
submissions so a big part of what we've
just seen in the report from Adam Tolley
is he was unconstructively critical to
to civil servants who didn't turn up
properly briefs he says you've got to be
able to do that if you're a minister
you've got to be able to tell your
officials that's not good enough go away
come back this is all in the Nuance this
is all in the disputed interpretations
of what's acceptable uh and what's not
he says you can do that provided Dominic
Robb says it's within reasonable bounds
and then he goes on to set out why he
thinks that although tough although
tough it was reasonable that report Mr
Tony from Adam told his report concluded
that I had not not want in four and a
half years sworn or shouted at anyone
let alone throwed anything or otherwise
physically intimidated anyone nor
intentionally sought to belittle anyone
I'm sorry if I cause unintended stress
however the public expect ministers to
push hard in setting the threshold for
bullying so low this inquiry set a
dangerous precedent of spurious
complaints against ministers and that
will have a chilling effect on those
driving change on behalf of your
government so overall
Sam you've got this sense that Adam
Tully has listed different types of
behavior and he has judged a couple of
them to go beyond what's acceptable a
kind of repetitive criticism of
officials that Adam
characterizes as unconstructive and then
Dominic Robb's reply is look you've got
to be able to be frank with your civil
servants uh because in the end we need
to get the best out of them there is a
long way to run to see uh what side
everybody comes down on which is why
there is one verdict that matters more
than anything else we've changed the
screen again now we've got the letter
from the Prime Minister and I think
we're just going to go through this for
clues of where does Richie see that come
down and I have a feeling that one of
the reasons it's taken so long 24 hours
to digest this 60 odd page report and
come to a conclusions because I think
inside Downing Street judging by what
I've read they feel that the whole
picture is quite nuanced what
constitutes bullying was there a group
of civil servants who never met Dominic
Robb working again instant so let's
let's just look at the language of the
Prime Minister uh he says it's with
great sadness I've accepted your
resignation remember the sort of
tributes to the Prime Minister brief and
Dominic Robbs a letter to uh receive
that but the other way around actually
it's very very uh uh a fulsome uh he
deals with the complaint the decision uh
to dismiss him at the beginning he says
when I became prime minister I pledge
that the government I lead would have to
have integrity professionalism and
accountability at every every level uh
the ministerial code requires ministers
to uphold uh the highest standards when
formal complaints about your conduct in
different ministerial posts were
submitted last year I appointed Adam
Tolley uh as you said you rightly
undertook to resign if any findings of
bullying uh were made whatsoever and you
have kept your word but it is clear that
there have been shortcomings in the
historic process that have negatively
affected everyone involved we should
learn from this how to better handle
such matters in future so that's the
Prime Minister talking about
um shortcomings amongst the people who
previously had made complaints but also
affected everyone involved does that
include Rob is that little note of
sympathy actually from the Prime
Minister acknowledging that actually
some of this stuff is more nuanced that
actually whilst there is unacceptable
verdict of unacceptable behavior in some
context there is some other context that
uh that makes the whole situation a bit
more complicated and then the rest of it
is essentially a tributes to the uh four
sector Estate jobs that Dominic Robb has
done brexit secretary foreign secretary
and twice at the ministry of Justice uh
he says he was a great Justice secretary
putting victims and uh prisoners first a
great foreign secretary uh uh a a key
point in brexit and uh uh and in taking
on Hong Kong and then uh pays tribute to
that role and a lot of people remember
that role when Boris Johnson uh was
prime minister went into Hospital
Dominic Rob took over so where are we in
conclusion I think Sam that there are
many elements of the report that was
done by Adam Tolley that are pretty
uncomfortable pretty damning it paints a
picture of something he was pretty
Relentless when dealing with stuff but
there's nothing physical vehicle there
was nothing outright there was not
outright shouting by Dominic Raab there
was something that critics and Adam
Tully have judged with unacceptable
niggling at and effectively uh bullying
and undermining uh their confidence uh
something that Dominic Raab makes very
clear in his letter that he does not
accept amount to bullying because he
thinks that you should be able to have a
robust conversation with civil servants
who turn up without proper briefings and
the Prime Minister just a little hint
there that he's acknowledging that
whilst it was right to resign maybe this
situation isn't quite as clear-clutt as
you might uh have thought from some of
the headlines that there is a lot to
discuss in Adam tolley's report that
actually do have that group of civil
servants who never met Dominic Robb
working inside the ministry of Justice
effectively campaigning uh to get him
out it's not very straightforward
actually very positive about his grid
this uh this I think is a lot more
sanguine a lot more traditional in terms
of letters uh to uh outgoing Secretary
of State he's had to resign uh pouring
tribute on everything they did so a
verdict in terms of his exit a verdict a
formal verdict in terms of Dominic
Robb's Behavior but many many questions
are lots of people will end up taking
away lots of different lessons about all
the information the huge amount of
information that we've received this
morning I've been bringing to you on Sky
News
all right uh Sam thank you very much
indeed well as you can imagine uh
there's been a flurry of reaction to
that news of Dominic Robb's resignation
this morning
um from his roles in government uh those
being Justice secretary Lord uh
Chancellor and uh Deputy Prime Minister
let's have a listen to some of that uh
reaction to the resignation now
um the labor leader sakir stammer has
said that Rishi sunak's handling of the
affair highlighted the prime minister's
weakness let's have a listen
I don't know why Dominic craft thinks
Dominic Robb in the middle of a cost of
living crisis
thinks that anybody wants to hear about
his whining about having to resign what
I think everybody wants is strong
leadership and that has been palpably
absent here why on Earth was Rob
appointed in the first place one Earth
didn't the Prime Minister act more
quickly why on Earth isn't the
government laser focused on the cost of
living crisis
uh leader of the opposition is a
reaction there to the news Well joining
me now is Alex Thomas he's Civil Service
lead at The Institute for government uh
good afternoon to you Alex firstly what
is likely to be the reaction inside the
Civil Service to the resignation of
Dominic Robb
well I think uh you know those who've
made complaints and had concerns about
his behavior I would have thought would
be um pleased about it
um but equally I suspect particularly at
the top of the single service there'll
be some discomfort that it's got as far
as it has and that we found ourselves in
a situation where civil servants have
ended up you know leaking allegations
and then being drawn into an inquiry and
that there's been this very strong sense
of antagonism between a very senior
politician and the civil service so I
think they'll be concerned about that I
also think there'll be some concern
about the tone of Dominic Robb's
resignation letter that added fuel for
that antagonism he's clearly still very
unhappy about it yeah I was just going
to ask you about that
um there may be Relief by those uh
working with him that he's not coming
back to their department but that letter
um is fairly excoriating isn't it he
accuses people of making a coordinated
uh submission of complaints he also
talks about getting a dangerous
precedent via a low threshold for
bullying
well ultimately of course it's the Prime
Minister who's taking a decision on that
precedent so that's you know that's on
that's on Richie sunac
um the uh other interesting point though
that relates to I mean you can you can
take a certain amount from the
resignation letter but I've just in the
last sort of half an hour rapidly
skimmed through the the detail of the
the tolly report and I think that's the
really interesting thing to focus on
here it's a you know my impression of
that you asked what the Civil Service
will think about it it's a really
thorough piece of work it sets
everything in context it reads to me as
being fair to the former um Secretary of
State while also pointing out that there
were you know some you know where where
Adam Tully could get into the specifics
there were some you know substantiated
suggestions of intimidating Behavior he
doesn't quite get to the bullying point
but he does talk about intimidating
Behavior so I think the you know the the
the whole of the context is set out by
that tally report that looks to me to be
a pretty thorough piece of work
it does also say in the tolly report
that some of the civil servants who were
who were Keen to put forward complaints
or substantiate complaints had never
even met him it does I mean what what
the tele report does do quite well from
my initial reading is it distinguishes
between those areas where there are
grounds for specific complaint and those
areas where there's been more General
commentary so one of the group of
complaints complainants for example at
the ministry of Justice uh it seems to
me that Adam Foley didn't give that much
weight to precisely because as you say
they hadn't met the Secretary of State
or that they had um you know that their
complaints were quite general or about a
general atmosphere and of course an
inquiry like this you can't really get
very far if you're just talking about
General atmosphere you can talk about
the effect on individuals which totally
does um but you can't really get very
fast so the most telling and the most
damaging part of that report
um uh by Adam Tolley for Dominic Robb is
the section on the foreign office uh and
where he gets into a very specific uh a
very specific complaint that Dominic
Robb seems to suggest is about Gibraltar
um uh but but that
um that Adam Tully concludes did lead to
sort of consciously intimidating
behavior on Dominic Robb's um so that's
that's the really sort of um damning
part of the Tolley report for Dominic
raw but there are other bits exactly as
you say that put um Mr Rob's uh you know
behavior and approaching context that
talk about him as a driven high standard
Secretary of State and of course there's
absolutely nothing wrong uh with the
Secretary of State having high standards
and what about
um the claims that he makes which appear
to be about the permanent secretary at
the justice department Antonia Romeo
he's calling himself for an inquiry uh
into what we understand to be her
behavior well the suggestion there so
there's a there's a section of the Tony
report that talks about Antonio Romeo
and how she recorded her you know
warnings to to Mr Robb as it were so uh
and I don't think that's what's at issue
what what Mr Rob seemed to be saying in
his uh resignation letter was that there
was an incident where when he returned
to the department
um after Richardson came back in as
prime minister
um uh that there was there was
unofficial I'm not sure that is uh Ms
Romeo I think that's another official
who sort of gathered private secretaries
into a room and said that
um uh and said that you know as the
media reported it that there should be a
kind of you know an exit route for
anybody who didn't want to work with Mr
Rob that seems to be the thing that's at
issue um it may be that we hear more
about that as time goes on I mean my
view on that is if if there is a
secretary of state returning to the
department that some quite junior
private secretaries uh felt found very
difficult to work with it's completely
reasonable for a more senior official
than to say actually if this is going to
be very difficult for you it's we'll try
and find you a route to a different job
within the department what was then very
damaging was that all being leaked and
litigated out in in public with some
suggestion that this was you know this
was a uh you know a a you know uh either
kind of civil servants conspiring
against uh their Secretary of State or
the Secretary of State behaving
unacceptably so uh what one of the
things that I think and I hope that you
know the government learns from all this
is it's far better to nip these things
in the bud
um as Mr Tully says in his report uh uh
Dominic Robb's uh you know conduct in
the department no one was uh making any
complaints about his conducting
Department after all of this had been
surfaced so the lesson I take from that
is if all of this has been addressed by
successive Prime Ministers sooner and by
Mr Rob himself we wouldn't be where we
are today and into being a job all right
Alex Thomas good to talk to you on Sky
News thank you for your time
well joining me here in the studio is
our political editor uh hello there to
you Beth um you know that there are
political pyrotechnics going on when you
get sent forward to comes in the studio
yes yeah and you're probably enjoying
your day off there many people seem to
be saying inevitable that he had to go
but the manner in which he's gone is
going to create a headache for the Prime
Minister yeah absolutely some I think
the first thing to say is in terms of
inevitable that he had to go I was
speaking to a senior civil servant a
former senior civil servant early this
morning about whether or not they were
surprised by the verdict and they said
well in some ways it's hard to read how
it was going to go because in terms of
bullying complaints it's always a matter
of interpretation one side versus the
other but in terms of the weight of the
evidence we should remember that this is
very unusual
for this number of complaints about an
individual cabinet minister to come
forward so on the weight of the evidence
eight separate complaints it kind of
seemed uh when that was all happening it
would have been very difficult for
Dominic Robb to somehow wriggle through
all of those complaints and come out
clean and and that's what's happened two
of them have been upheld he had said
clearly that if they were upheld he
would resign and in that sense he has
been to quote the prime minister in his
acceptance letter of Dominic Robb's
resignation he's been true to his word
and he has resigned so
what is interesting about all of this
though isn't just the substance of what
happened it's the kind of way it has
been staged this morning because part of
this is about how you frame the argument
and by Dominic Robin I've got all of the
stuff here
dominant Rob getting out of the traps
fast putting forward his resignation
framing the tally report before it came
out really as an attack on the Civil
Service and saying that the bar for
bullying complaints was too low uh that
it set a dangerous precedent in terms of
ministers being able to robustly
challenge civil servants and really
blaming uh the civil service for what he
thought was unfair treatment of him so
that's how it's been framed now as the
morning has gone on and other things
that have come out such as the Tully
report you begin to see a different
picture because what you see in the
tolly report is that two complaints
upheld and the evidence is pretty damn
in against Dominic Raab from the fcdo
the foreign office the complaint
concludes that there was an abuse of
misuse of power in a way that undermines
or humiliates and that in doing this the
uh former deputy prime minister ought to
have reasonably been aware in terms of
the MOJ complaint it says the DPM acted
in a manner which was intimidating in
the sense of going farther than was
necessary or appropriate in delivering
critical feedback there was a strong
view officials should have been prepared
in advance to questions at a meeting and
that there was largely unconstructive
criticism so yes two six of the
complaints uh didn't pass the bar but
two of them did
when we spoke many months ago when we
knew that this investigation was going
to be undertaken
um we spoke to Jacob reese-mogg who said
sort of people who make these complaints
they're snowflakes I mean he does have
an abrasive style most people would
acknowledge that but is it not
reasonable for him to expect civil
servants to turn up prepared to well and
this is this is this is exactly uh the
conversation I had with the former
senior civil servant this morning about
well actually this is a question of
interpretation and
um you know do you have any sympathy
with Mr Rob in terms of what he felt was
robust others felt were bullied and I
think the point of all of this Sam is
that this and this is in terms of the
stage and I say two things about it
number one this will definitely be used
now as a way and you you'll probably see
later as the day goes on Minister's
former cabinet ministers politicians to
come out and say look this is not just
about Dominic Robb this is about the
civil servants relationship with
ministers this is about kind of
institutional resistance from the Civil
Service as to the relationship with
ministers the Counterpoint of that which
I said earlier is the fact there was a
weight of evidence this wasn't one
person making a complaint this was a
sustained set of complaints the second
thing I'd say about that is that if you
actually zoom out
of this the fact is there were eight
complaints made two were upheld and this
is a prime minister that has had to let
go of three cabinet ministers in six
months around allegations of bullying or
misconduct and actually this comes back
to a question
beyond all the noise around the civil
servant and how aggrieved Dominic Rob
feels of his treatment this all comes
back I think to a question about the
prime minister's judgment that he put
people into his cabinet where there were
concerns around them
in terms of either being made publicly
or privately and he put them into the
cabinet nevertheless whilst at the same
time on the steps of down the street he
promised a government of accountability
integrity and professionalism and I
think that we shouldn't lose sight in
the row about the civil servants the
culture of the Civil Service and Rob's
attacks on the Civil Service and he
clearly feels deeply aggrieved but we
shouldn't lose the bigger picture in all
of this which is this goes back to the
Prime Minister he decides who to appoint
and he decides whether those people in
his cabinet reflect his standards and
the standards he sets under government
and labor today making a big meal of the
fact that the prime ministers allow
people to resign be that Nadeem zahawi
Gavin Williamson or now Dominic Robb
instead of sacking them for some of
these issues look I think when we read
the letters and I think when you read
the prime minister's letter
um I imagine that for many civil
servants that fear aggrieved that this
reads raw because he is extremely
supportive of the DPM the former deputy
prime minister Dominic Robb one of his
clear allies so you can see that this
comes at a personal cost to him
um but you have to look at that in the
context of how then that is received by
other people that feel aggrieved by his
conduct he's a prime minister that
clearly did not want to let his Deputy
Prime Minister go and that is clearly
going to Fester isn't it over the course
of the weekend there are there is also
the Practical matter of replacement Mr
Rob and certainly the Justice brief is
one that's seen High turnover isn't it
over the years talk us through who the
runners and riders for that might be we
are unders we understand that uh Alex
chalk defense minister has been seen
going into Downing Street in the last
hour well Alex chalk um Alex chalk is a
key Ally of Rishi sunak and he was one
of the ones that really pushed for him
both the first time and the second time
in his far his failed leadership bid and
then his successful one so what they'll
be looking for is a senior lawyer as
well so Alex chalk could be a definite
possibility there's also uh Vicky
aitkin's uh Atkins who could be an
option for him he then also has the
issue of does he appoint this person his
Deputy Prime Minister as well or does he
hand that title to someone else in his
cabinet that is a key Ally someone like
say Mel stride off the top of my head
like someone I know that is very close
to the prime minister so does he pass
the mantle of Deputy Prime Minister to
to that person there's also an issue
that of recovering Michelle donalan
um donalan's maternity leave so does he
do that all today so we yeah he's got a
job of replacing people but I think in
the wash-up of all of this as well
part of the difficulty he has is in a
way Dominic Ralphs made it easier for
him by resigning but in a way it looks
like he might make it harder for him in
that the fact he wrote a op-ed in the
telegraph uh no sooner than his letter
had been published again uh criticizing
the Civil Service suggests that Dominic
Robb is going to come out fighting feels
he has been wronged and wants to make
his argument whilst the Prime Minister
would probably like one new cycle of
this story and then it all to go away
and I think for the Prime Minister what
he will want is Dominic Robb to go
quietly and as it looks at the moment he
wants in vain that that so in the in the
immediate time it's easier but in the
medium term it could be harder because
what Rishi sunak who's promised a
government of integrity and getting on
with the job and fixing Public Services
rather than chaos and politics and
infighting and backstabbing what he
wants is an efficient competent
government what he doesn't want are
endless headlines
about rowing in government about
politicians feeling that they're wronged
and a political Palmetto if you if you
know what I mean so what he will want is
Dominic Robb to go quietly but at the
moment it doesn't look like he intends
to do that he genuinely you can clearly
see feels extremely aggrieved yeah it
certainly does doesn't he certainly that
op-ed in the telegraph is anything to go
by all right so Beth thank you very much
in indeed joining me now is the former
chairman of the committee on standards
in public life sir Aleister Graham uh
Sarah good to see you this afternoon uh
first of all your reaction uh to the
resignation of Dominic Robb
well I don't I I think that neither
Dominic Rob or the Prime Minister comes
out well from this particular incident
in our political uh life Dominic Rabb
has had two of the complaints against
him upheld and has been found to uh
participated and and been unnecessarily
intimidating uh so the report says the
let me stress I haven't read the full
report in in detail but I've seen some
of the quotations and the Prime Minister
first of all is under criticism for not
having taken into account the complaints
that were around when he was appointed
as Deputy uh prime minister
and seems to have unnecessarily taken
too long a time to come to a conclusion
when there was a clear conclusion in the
report the two of the complaints were
upheld and the ministerial court is
extremely strong in saying the civil
servants have to be dealt with
consideration and respect and that no
forms of bullying or harassment or
intimidation will be tolerated so why
does it wasn't a decision taken more
quickly
he did though launch an investigation
didn't he and and it was at a strange
time where there was no ethics advisor
in post
yes well he's appointed an Ethics
advisor and the first thing he could do
now to show he was serious about
improving standards would be to give
that ethical advisor the discretion to
commence investigations where he thinks
it appropriate without first seeking the
permission of the Prime Minister and
this has been recommended by the
committee on standards and public life
and it would be a sensible first move
that may get him some credit with the
public
uh Richardson did pledge didn't he on on
the steps of number 10 integrity and
accountability it sounds like you think
he's fallen short on the way he's
handled this but the ministerial code
has changed hadn't it hasn't it um he
didn't have to fall on his sword Dominic
Rob he could have been sanctioned in
some other way
well the terms of the ministerial code
on this matter are so strong I think it
would have been impossible for him not
to have resigned uh plus the fact he
said he would resign if any of the
complaints were up of bullying were
upheld and they have been
let me ask you as well and if you feel
like his his resignation was uh was 100
a logical conclusion of what was in that
report should he still be an MP or
should he should he stand aside from
from that as well
well that's a separate question uh uh I
think he will we're going to have a
general election in the not too distant
future within possibly a year so he will
have to be accountable to uh his
electorate and his constituency so I
don't think he needs to stand down uh uh
as an MP
um but uh he will have to answer to his
constituency party under the uh
electorate
interesting so standards in in public
life you think apply they apply
differently if you're in government as
opposed to just on the back benches
well no we've already got a backbench MP
Boris Johnson who is in fact is uh
facing a serious situation because of
the investigation by the Privileges uh
committee uh but we do have a procedure
for members of parliament to be
disciplined
um and uh he hasn't been through this
procedure he's been through a separate
inquiry and he's lost his position as
Deputy Prime Minister
um and uh his standing in Authority as a
member of parliament has been clearly
undermined so I don't believe further
action is required at this stage
there's something inherently difficult
though isn't there about investigating
allegations of bullying particularly
verbal
bullying because it comes down in in
some instances where it's not black and
white to interpretation and to how
somebody's Behavior made others feel
which is which is difficult really to to
concretely say one way or the other
well we've we've had a very substantial
inquiry I think there are some lessons
to be learned about how we can speed up
dealing with these matters but civil
servants as the ministerial
says have a right to be dealt with by
consideration and respect uh and that
does not involve a climate of fear or
intimidation uh and uh therefore we do
have to safeguard the position of civil
servants because we want the best people
to come into the Civil Service to be
able to support and advise ministers and
there has to be a respectful
relationship between those two parties
and if in fact ministers go over the
line there has to be consequences
all right sir Aleister Graham uh great
to talk to you on Sky News thank you
very much indeed let's bring back in our
political editor Beth Rigby and Beth
other than the response to the
resignation letter we haven't heard yet
um from the Prime Minister what will he
be doing this afternoon do you think to
try and circle his wagons well the first
thing he'll be doing is trying to work
out who he replaces uh Dominic Rob with
and as I said I'm interested to see if
he puts someone else into that DPM post
as we're talking about earlier there's a
number number of Runners and riders for
justice you typically want someone that
is has legal experience when you haven't
in the past uh and I remember uh it
doesn't go it doesn't go so well but as
I said there's there's Victoria aitkins
who is the financial secretary to the
treasurer and a big loyalist Alex chalk
who you were talking about going in uh
earlier there is Victoria
she's currently the attorney general and
was actually a former legal brain for
government before she became
um
um an MP and then of course for Michelle
donalan it's all talk about whether Lucy
Fraser steps up uh to replace her while
she goes on maternity leave so I think
there's some discussion in Westminster
today whether Russia does this as a mini
Shuffle or does he
um does he expand it out but you know
the thing about reshuffles is someone's
always unhappy
um so it might be better given that he's
already slightly on the ropes today uh
that he keeps it uh as not as neat and
tight as possible I think also that
and I think it's reflected if I get his
letter up here that you can see that
this has come at quite a personal cost
to him if we just sort of zoom out a bit
and think about what the relationship
between Rob and Rishi sunak is when
Rishi sunat was running to be leader in
the summer of 2022 uh Dominic Robb was
the star act that was kind of kept in
the room behind who was unveiled to
introduce Rishi soon at the most senior
cabinet minister to publicly back him
as it became clearer that Liz truss was
likely to win uh many cabinet minister
deserted uh Mr sunac and and and flipped
but Dominic Rob didn't and not only
didn't dominate Rob desert Richie see
that but he spent a lot of his own
political capital on Rishi soon at
defending him attacking Liz trust
knowing that this would ultimately hurt
him so one of the big moments in that
campaign was when he described list
truss's economic plans and tax cutting
plans as an electoral suicide note and
after that he really was you know dead
to her there was no way he was coming
back into her cabinet so he sort of
wrote his own suicide note if you like
when it came to a cabinet post so it's
been a long six months it's been a long
week to be honest
but so so the so the point is is that he
knew that and then he but nevertheless
he did that and then he and tsunac out
in the political Wilderness and of
course when Rishi sunak came back in to
government and then you know became the
Prime Minister after Liz truss's
Administration imploded and I don't
think anyone thought it would happen
quite as quickly as it did Dominic Robb
gets brought back Dominic Robb becomes
Deputy Prime Minister uh reinstated as
Justice secretary so they were kind of
outcast together and then they were back
in and he was his key you know courtesan
if you like so this comes a lot of
personal cost to Rishi sooner this is
you know a loyal Lieutenant a close Ally
and he's had to let him go but going
back to the issue of judgment
you have to ask there were rumors around
Dominic Robb and his conduct I've been
told that people raised this directly
with the Prime Minister and when we
asked number 10 about that their defense
was there were no formal complaints
raised
um and that's the way not denying that
there were informal complaints or
informal misgivings put to the PM but he
put Rob back in
uh and it reflects the fact that perhaps
he felt he owed him uh he needed his
support and now that Rob is back out of
the tent that will be potentially
politically quite lonely for Rishi
sooner but he'll also be worried perhaps
about having Rob agitating on the back
benches I have to say from the letter it
seems that Dominic rather does not
plenty of agitation to do but it also
seems like Dominic Rob doesn't blame the
pm he blames The Blob if you like as
some of the critics of the Civil Service
not Lisa Liz truss would put it but when
you look at the letter and the content
of the legend what the Prime Minister
says about uh Dominic Robbie says it's
with great sadness I have accepted your
resignation he says that you rightly
undertook to resign because you said you
would if any complaint was upheld so you
kept your word and then he goes on to
talk about all the extreme achievements
that Rob had in government that should
make him him quotes extremely proud and
then at the end of the letter he says
here
the sub that I will always be grateful
for your steadfast personal support
during last year's conservative party
leadership contest the day you
introduced me at my launch the
subsequent dedication commitment and
loyalty with which you have discharged
your responsibilities as Deputy Prime
Minister has been typical of your belief
in public service
um you know you could not have a more
glowing you know resignation letter
from a prime minister than that and I
think that
while Rishi sunak has obviously wanted
to do that to be loyal to the very end
to an ally that he's had to let go I
mean I think really what would have
happened is that Rob was either going to
have to resign or would have had to be
sacked right so he's taken the more
elegant route but I do think this this
will raise political difficulties
potentially for the Prime Minister for
two reasons he hasn't distanced himself
and the fact is that this guy's had
bullying complaints upheld against him
so you know whatever the framing of this
there will be people that will say he is
a bully and he has bound been found to
be a bully by an independent
investigation by a KC that has looked at
these complaints it's not a gray area
two complaints were upheld so there's a
prime minister promising a government of
professionalism Integrity whilst also
being extremely sympathetic
to a competent Minister who has been
found to have bullied more junior
members of Staff right that I mean you
know whichever way you spin it some that
that's the conclusion so there's a kind
of question about Civil Service backlash
and it will also give labor
an ability to call him weak because they
can say you didn't you had the tally
report there were two complaints upheld
you didn't sack the guy you allowed him
to resign this is what you did with
Gavin Williamson when he had bullying
allegations as well this is what you did
with the dean Sahar we went there was
clear uh misconduct you allowed him to
resign you do not you are not a strong
prime minister you do not uh stick by
your word and you've allowed yourself to
be bounced and you've allowed these
people to take the initiative rather
than you so I think any repetition of
what Angela Reyna was telling me about
an hour ago right well exactly well
exactly I didn't hear that interview
um but that that's the point so that's
what political enemies will be able to
do and then they will hope in a way that
this all keeps running into the May
local elections the week after next
because you know the whole shtick of
Rishi sunak is all of the conduct issues
of the past you know oblique nod to to
Boris Johnson and then some of maybe the
more economic chaos of Liz Truss I'm not
that guy I'm a different politician it's
a break from the past I am competent I'm
getting on with the job it's a
government of integrity and then what
you are hearing from Westminster is not
on the policies the policies that he's
been pushing in recent weeks but all
around issues of bullying and cabinet
ministers bullying members of staff and
it just all adds up into that swirl of a
feeling of there's political chaos again
at a time when this prime minister wants
exactly not to have that and then you
know his political opponents are able to
say this guy's just like all of the
others so it's you know I I it's it's
difficult you can see you read in that
letter I can feel I can palpably feel
that the Prime Minister has been
personally pained by this whole episode
and having to let his Deputy go all
right Beth thank you very much in indeed
uh Beth there also alluding to the
legacy of Dominic Robb our political
correspondent Liz Bates now looks back
at his political career and indeed his
undoing as one of the most senior
members of Richie sunax government
after months of denials I am confident
that I have behaved professionally
throughout I pay professionally
throughout Vision throughout
professionally at all times
it's all over for Dominic Rabb the
latest senior figure ousted from Rishi
sunax government amid a scandal of his
own making damaging the Prime Minister
who defended his Justice secretary even
as the bullying allegations mounted it
brings to an end a long ministerial
career we will be able to restore
control over our immigration policy and
our border controls a prominent
brexiteer he was brought in as brexit
secretary to try to get a deal Over The
Line
but stood down just a few months later
delivering a brutal blow to Theresa
May's fragile Premiership ultimately it
comes down to the political leadership
that we've got he then stood
unsuccessfully to take over the top job
before throwing his weight behind the
front runner
rewarded for his loyalty to Boris
Johnson he was made second in command
Deputy Prime Minister and foreign
secretary so senior that when the Prime
Minister was hospitalized with kovid it
was Dominic Rabb that stepped up to run
the country in his absence if there's
one thing I know about this prime
minister
he's a fighter elected in 2010 my name
is Dominic Robb unapologetically on the
right of his party
I don't support the Human Rights Act and
I don't believe in economic and social
rights this is looking like a very tense
exchange known for not always being in
control of his temper here he is caught
on camera backstage at a 2019 election
events
she's squaring up to a labor MP
his views on women have also drawn
criticism he said repeatedly he's not a
feminist which might explain why he
winked at Labor's Deputy leader in the
House of Commons
bullying claims have dogged him for
years but came to a head just in the
last few months as dozens of civil
servants came forward to give evidence
against him
the head of the Civil Service union says
it was long overdue I think it's clear
several servants haven't felt they could
challenge the behavior of a minister
it's clear to yours this is not just
about Dominic Rabb this is a broader
cultural issue about ministers and their
conduct and a belief that they can get
away with it
a close Ally of Rishi sunak his
departure has just added to the prime
minister's problems as he now faces
questions over what he knew about his
Justice secretary's Behavior
for those who say they were bullied by
Dominic Rabb though this exit is long
overdue
Liz Bates Sky News Westminster
joining me now is the former special
advisor in the conservative government
Anita berteng Anita good to see you this
afternoon what's your take on everything
that's been unfolding today
has been a fairly dramatic day and
actually that there's a lot of lessons
in this report and it is worth
um you know listeners and Watchers
reading it in full because I think it
really breaks down some of the
um challenges of working between
ministers and civil servants for
instance it talks a lot about basically
how you get the most out of civil
servants it talks a lot about
um the fact that if if you're giving
feedback how it comes across really does
matter in a modern workplace
um and I think that both civil servants
in general you know as a former special
advisor I was also a special advisor in
the ministry of Justice
um are normally work very very well with
ministers and there are these really I
think unusual instances where things
really do seem to have broken down quite
a lot and in terms of the consequence
for politics obviously this has been
hugely explosive but I really think it
is worth people reading this report and
reflecting on how to make the
relationship between civil servants and
ministers much better
what do you make of Dominic Robb's
response that the uh that the upshot of
the investigation by Casey Adam Tolley
effectively sets the bar so low for
bullying that it creates a dangerous
precedent
yeah there are interesting Reflections
in the report about this specific
question because Dominic appears to have
made you know a number of
representations and there were
interviews between Adam Tolley Casey and
himself that seemed to have lasted he
said two and a half days which is quite
extensive and I think one of Dominic
Robb's arguments effectively was that
intent really matters behind bullying
and I guess in a lay sense that's what
most people would think of of bullying
as being you know deliberately sort of
targeting individuals and making them
feel a particular way
um and what Adam Tolley sort of says in
reflection of that point is that
essentially he thinks that it it it
isn't that and it's got the broader
culture and the way that people feel
um even when they're providing feedback
which seems from the from the report to
be very focused on work it's not sort of
commenting on people's character or
making personal remarks he says that
does sort of amount to bullying and if
people feel intimidated or feel
frightened even if that wasn't your
intent that is sufficient to be
considered bullying
the Prime Minister clearly uh the
difficult decision isn't it
um to lose one of his closest allies
from government but Dominic Robb you can
tell by the language he uses uh not just
in his resignation letter but in his
Telegraph op-ed he is not going to go
quietly this is the potential to be an
ongoing headache for the prime minister
distinguish between two things I think
definitely Dominic Robb has been very
strident in his resignation letter in
his Telegraph article and in his kind of
comments and responses to Adam Tully
throughout this investigation that's
reflected in the report that he feels
yes unhappy with the way that this
entire process has unfolded and in
particular very unhappy with the ways in
which the um civil service complaints
have been made for instance they're not
very specific he says in some instances
that kind of thing but I think that's
different to the question of whether
Dominic Rob will be a headache to Rishi
sunak on the back benches I think we can
tell from both
um both letters from between the two of
them and from what I know of them that
they are kind of close in terms of you
know being really important allies you
know Rob was an important supporter
obviously now because you've said and
therefore I think that the question of
whether he's going to be a kind of
political Challenge on the backbenches I
don't think that really Rises
um so I think that this you know Dominic
Robb clearly feels aggrieved but it's
going to be quite focused on the issues
of the way that civil servants
um behave and the sense of whether
ministers are able to provide the kind
of robust feedback that he clearly feels
is important without being accused of of
bullying
Anita good to talk to you this afternoon
thank you
Beth um let's come back to you on this
of course opposition leaders opposition
politicians wasting no time in basically
saying this illustrates poor judgment on
the part of the Prime Minister and that
he's not a leader with accountability
and integrity though I think some as
well that part of this is about
um although he's tried to turn the page
on the psychodrama of the conservative
party last year it's all of those sort
of ghosts if you like kind of coming
back to haunt him and the reason I say
that is that in each case where he had
someone that resigned or was sacked in
the case of Nadeem zahawi it was partly
about the people that the Prime Minister
needed to bring into his tent in order
to kind of get his cabinet up and
running or to repay them for their
loyalties so Gavin Williamson was
instrumental in getting him past the
line for that second leadership race and
kind of pushing away the kind of threat
of Boris Johnson so behind the scenes
Gavin Williamson was really instrumental
he of course resigned over bullying
allegations Nadine zahawi he found it
difficult to move him because he had a
base on the trust side he sat over
claims around the disclosure of his
financial interests and tax Affairs and
then of course you have Dominic Raab who
was his loyalist Lieutenant where there
was rumors and talk and
you know made clear to the Prime
Minister informally about questions
around his conduct but he brought him
back into cabinet and now they've all
hurt him
after the event of going back into
government because he's had to let them
go or they've had to resign there's a
fourth one within cabinet that people
talk about about whether or not they
will eventually have to resign and
that's swella bravaman because obviously
she was found to have broken the
ministerial code when she was uh under
Liz truss as Home Secretary she resigned
from Liz truss's government to be
reappointed a few days later uh into uh
Rishi sunax and that has left him with a
hangover from that about well if you're
a government of integrity and this
person resigned over breaking the
ministerial code you bring that person
back six days later and she's sitting in
his cabinet and why is she because she
brought the right of the party she
brought a group of people he needed so
this cabinet that he created wasn't in
His image if you like it was a
Coalition of different interests of the
party that he put in to government and
there has always been I think this
tension between what he said on the
steps of Downing Street about integrity
professionalism accountability and sort
of the makeup of his government but he
hoisted himself on his own petard really
because he made those promises if he
hadn't made those promises so publicly
his uh political opponents won't be able
to attack him so effectively about it
now all right Beth thank you very much
indeed baptism of fire isn't it for
somebody relatively new to politics and
becoming prime minister relatively uh
quickly into his political career it has
just gone at one o'clock you're watching
Sky News Today the main story this
lunchtime the only story it's evenly
this lunchtime Dominic RAV resigns as
Deputy Prime Minister and Justice
secretary offer a report into bullying
claims finds that he acted in an
intimidating fashion with unreasonably
and persistently aggressive conduct well
in response Mr Robb has criticized the
process and says the country will now
pay the price if the threshold for
bullying in government has been lowered
said he accepts Mr Rob's decision with
sadness and admits there were some
shortcomings in the process we'll bring
you all the latest developments as Rishi
sunak looks to replace a key member of
his cabinet and weighs up the damage
ahead of next month's local election
[Music]
very good afternoon to you from
Westminster where Dominic Robb has
resigned from the government this
morning following the conclusion of an
inquiry into bullying allegations
while the report by a senior lawyer Adam
Tolley Casey has been published and it
found the Deputy Prime Minister acted in
an intimidating fashion with
unreasonably and persistently aggressive
conduct in a work meeting while he was
foreign secretary Rishi sunak who
received the report yesterday said that
he accepted Mr Rob's resignation with
great sadness for his part Mr Robb
insisted that the two findings made
against him were flawed and the process
had set a dangerous precedent well let's
just uh walk you through some of the
report's key findings
it found that Mr Rob acted in a way that
was intimidating and persistently
aggressive at meetings he said to have
described the work of officials as
utterly useless and woeful that's while
he was just a secretary Mr Robb also
made unconstructive critical comments
about the quality of his colleagues work
and he was also found to have been
involved in an abuse or misuse of power
in a way that undermines or humiliates
well announcing his resignation after
seeing that report Dominic Robb released
a letter in which he took issue with the
findings let's look more closely into
that as well as calling the inquiry
flawed Mr Robb said whilst I feel Duty
bound to accept the outcome of the
inquiry it dismissed all but two claims
that were leveled against me I also
believe that it's two adverse findings
are flawed and they set a dangerous
precedent for the conduct of good
government
the Prime Minister responded with a
letter of his own accepting Mr Robb's
resignation with great sadness as well
as pointing to Mr Robb's record of
delivery in both this government and
previous administrations Rishi sunak
said it is clear that there have been
shortcomings in the historic process
that have negatively affected everyone
involved we should learn from this how
to better handle such matters
in the future well we can bring in again
our political editor Beth Rigby
um Beth the Prime Minister might have
hoped however much this decision pained
him to lose Mr Rob from government he
might have hoped that that would be it
it would be done and dusted and he could
focus his attention on the local
elections but this is just going to
snowball this weekend well look I think
I'm I'm re-reading dominant Robb's
article in the telegraph rereading his
letter of resignation and I think what
is clear from both is that Dominic Robb
feels that there is a discussion to be
had
about the conduct of the Civil Service
the way allegations were brought and his
treatment
and so I don't think it's just going to
go away because I don't think Dominic
Rob
feels like he's been treated fairly and
I think he wants to make his case and
actually when you look at some of the
arguments that he has made which the
Prime Minister picks upon in his letter
in the there was a curious
moment in the letter the PM letter where
he talked about if I can find it skim it
he talked about the process he said as
you say you've right and undertaken to
resign if the report made any findings
of bullying whatsoever you kept your
word but it's clear there have been
shortcomings in the historic process
that have negatively affected everyone
of all involved we should learn from how
to better handle such matters now I read
that as
something around issues around how
bullying complaints were lodged and
would there be reform and actually in
the article the telegraph article
dominant Robb expands on this which the
prime minister's picked up because he
says that regardless of the rights or
wrongs of whether he did or didn't mean
to bully and he has apologized where he
says he's unintentionally uh stepped the
mark overstepped the Mark or upset
people what he talks about here is the
fact that in an employment tribal the
tribunal there's a three-month time
limit for bringing bullying claims while
in standard internal human resources
practice it's on it's it's practical to
avoid unreasonable delay because late
claims are unfair he said in my case all
the complaints were stalled up over
three months most over eight months some
over four years and then submitted in a
court coordinated way he's absolutely
accusing the Civil Service of yeah being
out to get him he's saying uh that these
were not dealt with at the time and
actually in the report it does nodes
that his behavior has changed since this
investigation these allegations emerged
I.E he has adapted his behavior now that
these allegations have emerged but I
would argue Sam uh that the Counterpoint
to that right is that if you talk to
civil servants their job is to serve
ministers and they try to do that the
best way they can so it's quite
difficult for them to make a complaint
against their bot you know it's they
work in tight teams under high pressure
their job is to execute the wish of the
minister
um and that there was such a sort of
level of
complaints suggests that this was across
three departments it does suggest that
there was a systemic issue going on
whether Dominic recognized it or not and
that actually it's quite hard I think we
should always remember it's actually
quite hard for younger Junior people to
come forward and make formal complaints
against very important in any employment
situation Gates very very senior people
so I do think that's what's happening
here at the moment
is that because civil servants aren't
meant to speak out what we're getting is
a kind of Dominic dominant Rob version
of events uh the Prime Minister kind of
effectively backing him up and what we
haven't really heard about is how the
civil servant service feel about this
and and actually
um I think part of the danger in all of
this apart from the kind of continued
sort of saga and drama around the
resignation and the Rights and Wrongs of
it from Dominic Robb's point of view I
think that the sort of attacks upon the
Civil Service when there is a government
that needs civil servants to process
migrant claims and help cut backlogs in
the NHS and make sure people can get
their passports and their driving
licenses and basically make the business
of running a government work
um do you want to go to war with the
Civil surface if you're prime minister
and your whole thing is about
deliverability you see that that would
be
think there's a sort of there's a sort
of immediate level political row going
on about dominant Rob's treatment and
the processes and maybe the Prime
Minister brings forward reforms but
there's a kind of a cultural issue about
is this a government that goes wants to
go to war with the Civil work service in
the way in which Dominic Cummins when he
was running down the street the hard
rain that you know and and Liz trusted
as well in terms of you know there was
an Institutional bias against her an
Institutional uh resistance to implement
her reforms which she sunak has not
fought that war he needs to get stuff
done and it's interesting here that
Dominic Robb seems to be ready uh for
that fight a fight that perhaps the
prime minister with an eye on a general
election next year with a hell of a lot
of work to do in terms of improving
Public Services before that it might be
around he doesn't want to have
um does the Practical matter I mean he
has lost probably his most loyal Ally he
needs to replace doesn't he a Justice
secretary a deputy prime minister and
law Chancellor he does so you know in
terms of the Justice secretary there's a
few names around this Victoria
Apprentice she's the Attorney General at
the moment there's uh Victoria Aiken
she's at the treasury of close Ally of
um thought to be very competent and
she's a trained law as well and of
course Alex chalk who we've spotted
going in I mean Alex chalk was so
delighted when Richard sunach was made
prime minister I remember seeing him on
the steps of number of cchq conservative
party Campaign Headquarters as they went
in and he was almost in tears I mean the
you know he's such a close Ally and
supporter of Rishi suno so yeah is this
the moment that Rishi kind of gathers
some of those closer to him together and
puts them into their job so those three
in the running for that I think it's
interesting to see if he'll you know who
if any healer Point DPM yeah if at all
I'm just hearing Beth that we've got
pictures of Dominic Robb leaving his
house let's just uh have a look at that
now I presume this is his constituency
uh Isha and Walton which is in Surrey
there we're told that that is Dominic
Robb in that car which could be anybody
take our word for it
there we go that that's all we've got to
show you
um
I'm afraid but uh yeah we have heard a
fair amount from Dominique Rob um
although he clearly wasn't looking to
say anything to our reporters just there
um we can bring in Deputy political
editor Sam coats he's been pouring all
over that report from Adam Tolley QC
since it was released just a short while
ago let's bring in Sam now uh Sam I saw
that you had highlighter aplenty all
over that document what have you pulled
out of Interest
that's right Sam here it is it's the 50
page report it's taking five months to
do it was submitted yesterday April the
20th and it's by Adam Tolley QC of
Fountain Court London and it has ended
Dominic Ralph's career now I've
condensed down a lot of the stuff in
this report into just five or six into
just five or six elements to pick up on
some of the themes that Beth was just
talking about because this is a
complicated report I think we're going
to be talking about the issues raised
inside it for some time to come but
let's get down to the sort of brass tags
this
um really explains why Dominic Raab had
to go uh there were incidents and here's
a good one there's one at the foreign
office uh that Adam Tully heard about uh
which he felt crossed the line in terms
of behavior let's look at the wording of
the report the Dutch prime minister
Dominic Raab had formed a adverse view
in the way that his civil servants had
acted uh in relation to a particular
product so Dominic Robb wasn't happy uh
he uh as part of the process towards um
uh uh taking various decisions he acted
in a way which was intimidating uh he uh
in the sense of acting unreasonably and
persistently aggressively in the context
of a workplace meeting his contact also
involved an abuse or misuse of power in
a way that undermines or humiliates in
particular he went Way Beyond what was
reasonably necessary in order to give
effect to his decision and introduce a
punitive elephant which we understand to
mean he referred to the Civil Service
Code hinting that his civil servants
could be disciplined his conduct was
bound to be experienced as undermining
or humiliating by the affected
individual and it was so expensive there
you have an example where Adam toll is
absolutely clear he thinks that amounts
the kind of bullying that's unacceptable
on the workplace because Dominic Robb
had committed to resign if that had been
found he has now gone people will be
able to see what what is and what isn't
part of that complaint there was another
thing that that stood out in this report
the use of physical gestures now there's
no it has to be said and Dominic Robb
says this in a suggestion that he ever
touched anybody or there was anything
actively physical physical involving
contact it's interesting to look at this
I had a good deal of evidence about the
Deputy Prime Minister Dominic Robb's use
of physical gestures in communication at
the most extreme which would have been
unacceptable this was put as extending
his hand directly out towards another
person's face with a view to making them
stop talking about stopping somebody
talking by putting his hand in front of
their face or loud Banning of a table to
make a point so again Adam Tully says
that is unacceptable there are judgment
adverse judgments against Dominic Robb
that's why he has gone let's look at the
context of one of the incidents just to
start to sort of understand what was
going on a little bit more though here
it says that Dominic Robb has very
strong views I think we know that now
and should have he he believes strongly
that officials should prepare in advance
to answer his questions at meetings and
in the event that they cannot do so
offers largely unconstructive criticism
about the matter so Dominic Rob often
used to say what are the basics where's
the basic information you're trying to
give me and the and Adam Tully says that
the public airing in the context of a
meeting of a comment of this kind where
others are present or not maybe well
placed to judge whether the criticism is
well founded is likely to be experienced
as unfairly personal criticism by the
individual to whom the comment is
directed so so just take a step back
there he's saying there's a meeting
Dominic robbers crossed that what he
believes is civil servants not doing the
work in preparation for that meeting and
it's just as you haven't done the basics
and Adam Tolley says that that is wrong
and shouldn't happen in the workplace
because it unfairly belittles those
around the room now people have to judge
their own in their own with the
knowledge of their own uh workplace
situations and experience whether or not
they think that amounts to bullying same
type of interaction could also occur
when Dominic Robb was frustrated that
his policy objectives were not being
implemented uh with uh sufficient
commitment now this is where we start to
get into the sort of political
complications around this one of the
reasons why down the street took 24
hours to uh before we knew what was
going on the Deputy Prime Minister
Dominic Robb held the view that there
was what he regarded as cultural
resistance from within the ministry of
Justice to his reforms it's more likely
than not that this view was manifested
by the Deputy Prime Minister in his
comments in the other words perhaps
fairly perhaps unfairly Dominic Rob
believed that his civil servants were
working against him in some issues often
to do with the sort of Human Rights uh
stuff that he was doing worked against
him and that's one of the reasons he was
particularly frustrated now some people
will choose to believe what dominic Robb
says other people will reject that but
it's uh it's going to start a
conversation that is quite complicated
and this is where it gets really
complicated and potentially a little bit
toxic
this is a complaint that Adam Tully had
to weigh up he didn't particularly find
it credible but what he said about it
why he didn't find it credible is
fascinating he said that there was a
group complaint this group called them
the ministry of Justice group complaint
and we didn't know how many people were
behind this group complaint but we do
know is that um there was an informal
network of civil servants whose number
is uncertain but they made complaints as
part of this process and here's the key
bit only some of those individuals who
had any had any direct experience of
Dominic Raab some had never met him but
all were seeking to support their
colleagues in other words there were
people part of a group trying to get
disciplinary action against Dominic Rob
who had never met him that I think is
going to be a big part of the discussion
in the days to come
all right Sam thank you very much in
indeed um for your speed reading and
Analysis there of that lengthy legal
document let's bring in our political
correspondent Ali Fortescue Ali I know
you've been attending the lobby briefing
um what's come out of that that you can
tell us
yeah fascinating so we've got a bit of a
sense of the choreography how the last
24 hours have played out we know that
the Prime Minister spoke to Adam Tolley
yesterday and his independent advisor
Dominic Robb he spoke to this morning on
the telephone
um we didn't get any details about what
actually happened during that
conversation but that conversation
happened before we got the release from
Dominic Robb saying that he was going to
go so the Prime Minister and of Nick Rob
did speak this morning
um we also and this was fascinating
because in the prime minister's letter
he talks about shortcomings in the
historic process which
um I I found quite hard to understand
but the prime minister's official
spokesperson confirming that the
Kavanaugh office are basically going to
look at the process how historic claims
are raised this I understand is about
making sure that civil servants and
ministers can challenge each other
robustly but clearly some concerns over
the time the timeliness of complaints
being raised so that was interesting
um interesting too that the Prime
Minister spokesperson wouldn't say
whether or not they thought that this
report was fair and said that the Prime
Minister did not regret appointing
Dominic Robb to such a senior role
because of course now there are some
questions about why Dominic Robb was
given the big job of Deputy Prime
Minister under Rishi sunak when some of
these rumors were swirling at the time
of course Dominic Robb has not gone
quietly has says that he supports the
government but he's clearly not very
happy with how things are played out
with this report saying effectively that
the bar is being set too low for
bullying complaints
um of course the attention now turns to
who might take over his job um certainly
his job as a Justice secretary I suspect
we will be hearing about that fairly
soon and we did see Alex chalk walking
into number 10 earlier today he of
course used to be the attorney general
who currently a defense minister his
name has been touted around as a
potential successor he was a long time
Rishi suno backer I remember speaking to
him on the day that Rishi sunak got the
job eventually as prime minister he was
absolutely delighted um some other names
that have been doing the rounds Victoria
um Atkins who's been a long-serving
minister currently in the treasury
Victory Apprentice who is the attorney
general in cabinet at the moment her
name has been in the mix as well Lucy
Fraser the culture secretary Robert
genre Robert Buckland so lots of names
um that have been that have been doing
the rounds but I suspect it won't be
long before we do actually know who
takes over from Dominic Robin that
important job of Justice secretary
remains to be seen whether or not the
Prime Minister will appoint a deputy
prime minister of course that has not
always been a role that has existed so
we will see whether there'll be another
person that will take up a job obviously
a very important job of deputy prime
minister it may well be that the PM
decides not to do that but instead just
to point someone to the role of Justice
secretary so plenty of questions still
we did get that letter from Russia sunac
Today number 10 spokesperson saying that
it is right that the findings of the
report be upheld that was Downing Street
a spokesperson confirming to the Prime
Minister spoke to Dominic Rob this
morning before Dominic Robb released
that letter saying he was going to
resign deciding to go really by the
sounds of it before he was pushed
all right Ali thank you very much indeed
we'll bring you any news of possible
replacement appointments as and when we
get them but joining me now is Mike
Clancy General Secretary of the prospect
Union which represents technical
Specialists and managers in both the
public and private sector including I
understand uh very many civil servants
as well good afternoon to you
um I'd imagine that the Civil Service as
a body has quite mixed feelings about
the turn of events from today
well I think the report uh will repay
detailed reading I've had a chance to to
scan it like others
um I'd make three initial points first
of all that this is a reflection of the
toxic culture of the previous
administration in which such behaviors
uh can uh what were allowed to flourish
um uh frankly secondly it may come as no
surprise that those people who've read
um some of the views of Mr Rob in the
past when he was part of a co-authorship
of a pamphlet in 2012 called Britannia
on chains where the authors along with
pretty Patel trust and Kwa Tang
described the British Workforce as the
most work shy so that's another
important piece of context in terms of
how we may feel about the people who
work from them but perhaps the central
thing is that the government has been
acting without clear ethical core and
indeed this this report is uh in itself
a demonstration of that because
um the decision making was left at the
Prime Minister it was about fact-finding
but but that but the Prime Minister had
to make the decisions clear Mr Rob has
gone before he was going to be the
subject of that decision so I think just
the really interesting thing is Where Do
We Go From Here Mr Rob has issued a very
combative resignation letter where he
clearly intends to pursue the issues as
he sees them describing the reporters
applying a low bar by contrast the Prime
Minister said he's going to learn the
lessons it's going to be interesting to
see what happens from here yeah well any
agitation he's going to be doing is now
going to be done from the back benches
but he describes the whole process as
kafka-esque and the report itself from
Adam Tolley does outline a few aspects
which are curious such as some people
who were either
substantiating complaints or indeed
adding to the context of of complaints
um apparently hadn't ever met Mr Rob
well I think for Mr Rob the best thing
can be said at the report is that it may
not be as bad as it could have been but
it's bad enough and clearly he's taken
the decision that it met his own
self-imposed thresholds that he was at
fault and in a report of this complexity
there will be things that we'll want to
explore understand how they've come
about but what we need to do is find use
this as a way of improving the processes
whereby ministers and civil servants
interact whereby advice and guidance is
given to ministers and how they then
conduct themselves so
um it's not surprising that there'll be
things in here which will Point more
than one way but as I say it's met Mr Mr
Rob's own test that he should resign
all right uh Mike Clancy thank you very
much indeed for your time on Sky News uh
we're cutting that interview uh a little
bit short because uh coming back into
the studio uh is our political editor
Becca Beth Rigby who has some breaking
news for us Beth yes as I understand it
I'm hearing that Alex chalk as we were
talking about earlier is going to be the
new Justice secretary so the defense
currently a defense minister a key Ally
of Rishi sunak um I think he's inside
number 10 with the Prime Minister and
he's expected to be announced as the new
Justice secretary to replace Dominic
Raab interesting we did have that
footage of him going in there so I
suppose it's not totally not totally
unexpected and what about the position
of Deputy PM so I'm just going to grab
my phone sorry can you pass me my
okay I'm just trying to grab my I've
just got to try and grab my bat phone so
I can give you the information so this
is the reality of live breaking news
folks yeah so as I understand it um I'm
hearing that he is Alex Chalk's going to
be
um the new Justice secretary he is the
MP for Cheltenham he's on the sort of
liberal Wing uh of the party uh he is
currently a defense minister he's a
close Ally of
um the Prime Minister
and so this is a sort of appointment if
you like for Rishi suno where he's
really Shoring up losing a close
Lieutenant an ally and replacing him
with someone who is in his Circle and
whom he trusts so Alex chalk coming in I
mean Alex chalk is kind of in that gang
of people such as Mel stride the work
and pensions Secretary of State and also
uh John Glenn who works at the treasury
um Grant Sharps there's there's a number
of them
um who have been kind of key figures for
Rishi sunak in recent week so he's given
a promotion putting into cabinet someone
that as he loses someone he really
trusts putting in someone that really is
one of his people it's interesting isn't
it because the worrying thing for any
prime minister when they lose a key Ally
who's been part of government key member
of cabinet is if they take with them a
whole cohort of other people as well but
Mr Rob was almost a lone wolf wasn't he
so he loses he loses a key Ally but he
doesn't lose a whole group of people
that that came with dominant round yeah
and I I think the thing is that that Don
Bob
um was resilient in the sense that he
became a kind of key Ally for Boris
Johnson he was Boris Johnson's Deputy
Prime Minister obviously put out uh to
pasture by Liz truss and back in with
um with Rishi sunap but you know Dominic
Robb did have a bit of a base because he
did try and run for leadership he didn't
get that far but he did try and run to
be the conservative party leader back in
2019 uh one of the many Runners and
Riders when really there was only one
horse in that race wasn't known it was
Boris Johnson who you know very very
comprehensively beaten up uh Jeremy Hunt
um so he is
um
in terms of Dominic Rob and Dominic Robb
going back to the benches you're right
that he doesn't sort of he doesn't come
from a wing of the party in which
there's a he has a base in that sense
but I also think that doesn't really
matter in this case for the Prime
Minister because you can tell from uh
Dominic Robb's letter that he does not
blame this predicament on the Prime
Minister and you can tell from the prime
minister's letter to dominate Rob that
he at the moment is not trying to
distance himself and sometimes what
happens in these instances Sam is that
the Prime Minister might say to Dominic
Raab or Dominic mob might just offer it
up you know like I this is not tenable
that I stay on if the complaints are
upheld but there's a period of uh being
on the back benches and and Dominic Rob
could perhaps come back into cabinet
at the next big reshuffle or after a
general election if uh Rishi sunak uh
did win another general election so
given that he has a good relationship uh
with the current prime minister uh
Dominic Robb is not going it does
there's no sense that he's going to
agitate but I do think it's interesting
that in replacing him he's put someone
into his cabinet that is genuinely one
of his key people and he's rewarded that
loyalty of Alex chalk and and given him
that big promotion I mean Alex talked be
absolutely delighted I'm sure from you
know back bencher for many many years to
a defense minister and now you know into
cabinet it was one of the things that
the Prime Minister probably needed to do
today to appoint his replacement at the
department
um of Justice
um he also needs to answer to a lot of
charges from opposition politicians that
his judgment over having Dominic Robin
the government in the first place was
flawed you know just like his
predecessors that he was he was showing
uh lack of Integrity yeah and I would
say there's there's
two sort of strings that will flow out
of this story and get pulled more as the
weekend goes on beyond the sort of hair
that Dominic Rob this morning set
running around the civil servant his
treatment this was a coordinated you
know a coordinated effort to unseat him
with these coordinated uh complaints
being put in as he put it and and some
of his implications in his letter that
other civil servants were working
against him while he was imposed so
that's kind of defined the way in which
this story has broken the tolly report
is broken but within the tally report
there's two elements here there's one in
Bob castlake uh the former Palm SEC of
the Civil Service the most senior civil
servant was making earlier on Sky which
is that the rather to quote him
graceless letter uh issued by uh Dominic
Robin the rebuttal is going to upset
civil servants at a time when the
government needs them to be on board and
delivering policies so there's a sort of
there's a there's a sort of backlash
that could be come in uh from the civil
servants over this kind of sort of
attack uh by Dominic Robb on them and
then there's a another very very
important question in all of this which
is about Rishi sunak's judgment because
he put dominant Robb back into cabinet
aware of some allegations and rumors or
dissatisfaction with how he conducted
himself
in office
um you know one source told me when we
were doing some reporting into this that
Dominic Robb was a character that you
know uh behaved differently when he was
managing Arts so people on his level are
more senior to him than he would with
Junior officials like I have to say to
be clear he has said that he behaved
profession at all times and he has
apologized clearly in his letter if he
unintentionally upset people but you
know even if Rishi sunak didn't see it
personally it's not the case I don't
think that he wasn't made aware of this
in which case why did he put him back
into government so there is a question
about the PM's judgment there is a
question about whether or not labor can
now try and put on to Rishi sunat that
he's just like all the rest because he
let these people resign rather than sack
him he says one thing you know he's
Janice face he says one thing out of one
side of his mouth and then he's doing
another thing out of the other and that
will be the attack lines and you know
when you see primaries questions it's in
the interests of Labor to kind of say
he's just like the rest of us also run
up to the local election I'm just going
to say just ahead of the local elections
what Rishi sunak doesn't want is well
articulate a well-articulated arguments
um questioning his judgment uh and the
other thing he doesn't want is a row
with the Civil Service and to not have a
smooth functioning government exactly
and I just have to say sam I've just had
from from one of my um sources quite
close to the Prime Minister uh that they
they personally don't think that he will
appoint another deputy prime minister
now I don't know if he will or not but
some of those politicians that work uh
with Rishi soon I can understand how he
thinks they don't think he'll
necessarily appoint another deputy so
you know it's you know always have a
deputy prime minister so we'll wait to
see I mean he's appointed Alex chalk as
his Justice secretary as I said he's one
of uh the key allies that Rishi sunak
has relied on
um so you know there's a number of them
now kind of around him but I do think he
will feel quite acutely the absence of
of Dominic Rob that has clearly
positioned himself as a key supporter
backer and advocate of where she's
seeing I can now you know it's another
big beast back on the benches I mean
Dominic Robb has extensive experience of
government he was the foreign secretary
he was the brexit secretary he was the
Justice secretary twice Deputy Prime
Minister you know during the covid you
know he's he he stood in for Boris
Johnson that's when we saw the
importance of the role of the Deputy
Prime Minister so so it's quite a big
you know it's that's quite a lot of
experience leaving government but you
know as I said earlier
we've heard a lot from Dominic Robb and
his perspective on what's happened the
counter argument to that as one former
senior Civil Service put it to me that
when you have a weight of claims in this
way across a number of departments a
number of people and a number of years
it suggests a body of evidence that is
to quote this person rather exceptional
that this doesn't normally happen and
the fact that it even got to this point
where so many people were prepared to
come forward and make formal complaints
not an easy thing to do when you're a
junior civil servant you know it for
many it would have been potentially they
would have feared career ending for them
um that this isn't uh this is this is a
body of evidence that has moved against
Dominic Raab and while he insists that
he feels that it was
um unfair
um
there is a case to say that there were
two complaints which were upheld so he
goes back to the back benches he's MP
for Isha and Walton which is a highly
marginal seat isn't it exactly a very
marginal seat and one which on the
current projections of how a general
election might play out uh one which
he's likely to lose I mean I have to say
to the lib Dems and that seat Sam was
one of the back in 2019 you know we were
watching that scene it was a key lib Dem
Target
and it might be that he's now reflecting
about whether or not he can even hang on
in as a as an MP uh at the next general
election because if the um if the polls
go carry on the way they are with quite
a big lead for labor I mean it's typical
that they narrow in the run-up to a
general election uh Dominic Rob could
well uh lose his seat in the swing away
from the government and and the lib dams
could take that seat okay well I'm
imagining that he's not going to go back
to the legal profession and work with
Adam Tolley
all right Beth thank you very much in
indeed let's bring in some of the
reaction as you can imagine it's been
coming in thick and fast too Mr Rob's
resignation let's listen into the labor
leader kistama
I don't know why Dominic craft thinks
Dominic Robb in the middle of a cost
living crisis
thinks that anybody wants to hear about
his whining about having to resign what
I think everybody wants is strong
leadership and that has been palpably
absent here why on Earth was Rob
appointed in the first place one Earth
didn't the Prime Minister act more
quickly why on Earth isn't the
government laser focused on the cost of
living crisis
well joining me now in the studio is
Dave Penman the General Secretary of the
FDA Association of first division civil
servants his organization represents
some of the complainants who have been
involved in that report good to see you
this afternoon Dave
um first of all it's been quite a
dramatic day hasn't it particularly for
those who've raised the complaints
because this morning it was being
reported that they were going to work
not knowing what was happening yeah I
mean the interesting thing about this
whole process is they have no rights in
it so you would have thought process
which is about dealing with complaints
of bullying and harassment protection
there's nothing there's not a single
thing laid down so the the raise a
complaint through the ministerial code
the only way they can they have to raise
that essentially directly with the Prime
Minister who decides whether it's
investigated and then decides how to be
investigated and then decides on the
outcome so for the last 48 hours they've
been sitting watching the television to
find out what happened to their
complaint to only find this morning that
actually Dominic Rabb had been afforded
the ability to get his defense in to
resign rather than be sacked to even put
an opinion piece out in a newspaper
before they even knew what the outcome
of the investigation was and all they
had to do was watch Sky News or another
news channel they find out what was
happening so it's just wholly inadequate
and demonstrates that this is a process
which is actually about the Prime
Minister and politics it's not about
protecting civil servants looking at
that report too out of the eight
complaints were upheld
um Dominic ra is asserting that the
process has been kafka-esque and that
some of those complainants actually
colluded in an effectively in an effort
to take him down what do they say to
that well it's quite extraordinary what
he said I mean it's you know it's
starting to stretch and taking of
conspiracy suggesting that the union was
and presumably my union was involved in
this as well people who suffer at
bullying at what quite often talk to
each other if they're if they're working
in a team where they're all experiencing
the same thing that's what will happen
and if they're going to raise a
complaint a complaint that's really
difficult to make in the Civil Service
remember these people have to
essentially if there is a complaint
completed prime minister they know
they're going to be named to their their
Minister it's no surprise when people
will talk to each other so the idea that
this is some sort of conspiracy remember
the person who's adjudicated on this
complaint is the prime minister the
person that he supported to be a party
leader the person who appointed him as
Deputy Prime Minister is he saying the
prime minister is now part of this
conspiracy as well because the Prime
Minister has conclude included on this
evidence that he was a bully and if you
look at some of the evidence that's
there even in the cases that were
dismissed as bullying you can read the
behavior of an individual about
intimidating about humiliating about
being overly critical
um I did dismiss six of them um your
read of the report and indeed some of
the people that have contributed to it
do they think that the report itself is
fair I think they would probably want to
have their own opinion columns and
criticize the evidence that's what
happens people will take different views
of it
um but ultimately that report did
conclude that it was a bullying the
Prime Minister I mean actually it wasn't
Adam Tully who concluded that he was a
buoy Adam told me was only asking I must
evidence it was the Prime Minister
because the Prime Minister refused to
involve his ethics advisor which he
could have done and it would have been
the independent ethics advisor whose
judgment it would have been about the
evidence and whether amounted to billing
or not but the Prime Minister wanted
that role himself so if Dominic Rams get
any criticisms it's about the prime
minister not about Adam Tully or the
civil servants
um it was fairly scathing Dominic Rob in
particularly in the telegraph article
which which I think that that you've
read
um the Civil Service don't really get a
say in this do we don't really get to
hear
their version of events and how how will
morale be how will the sense of uh
justice or Injustice be sitting with
them well they don't get to to speak
publicly they're not allowed to the
Civil Service Code precludes them and
ministers including Dominic Rabb know
that so he knows when he writes his
opinion column
um and the Daily Telegraph almost
identifying the people who have uh
complained against them he he knows that
they cannot defend themselves we
conducted a survey of our members in the
last couple of months the senior civil
servants who work closely the closest
with ministers one in six said they'd
reported misconduct amongst ministers
including bullying harassment in the
last 12 months that was across 23
government departments seventy percent
of them said that they had no faith in
the process for raising a complaint and
those who'd witnessed misconduct half of
them said they now didn't feel they
could speak truth unto power so the
result of this building and in
Temptations is inefficient because it
drains resources it's ineffective
because inevitably the Civil Service
loses good people and no civil servants
don't feel they can do their job part of
their job is to speak treated power to
give the facts the evidence they
ministers and if ministers create a an
intimidating atmosphere and then they
they don't feel confident in doing that
and that's not good for government as a
just briefly that this last question um
have things got any better under Rishi
sunax Premiership because the the
relationship between government and
Civil Service really was Rock Bottom
under the past two I think everyone had
High Hopes but he appointed Dominic Rabb
and has refused to say on five occasions
when he was asked whether he was aware
of any concerns of a dominant Rob's
behavior when he appointed them and I
think that speaks volumes he appointed
an Ethics advisor in December and
refused to allow that ethics advisor to
independently investigate complaints
despite the recommendations to do so
from the committee for standards and
public life and he has over the last 40
hours created a system sorry an outcome
where not only is Dominique Rob writing
opinion pieces and criticizing the whole
process but civil servants are going to
feel further undermined and less
confident raising complaints so whatever
um recession act says about the
government they all leads we have to
look at what he's actually done and I
don't think at the end of today anyone
will think actually this is a better
system where I have more confidence in
leading working in a government of
Integrity all right Dave Penman good to
talk to you thanks for coming in
uh let's go back again to our Deputy
political editor Sam Coates who's going
to talk us through those letters from
Dominic Robb to the Prime Minister and
the reciprocal one from the Prime
Minister back to Dominic Robb Sam over
to you
thanks we've had a huge day to dump
today and actually it's all about
reading the nuances reading the finely
balanced language both from Adam Tolley
the author of the report that's ended up
forcing the exit to Dominic rub and from
Dominic Robb himself in this letter and
the prime minister's reply so we heard a
bit earlier about the report now let's
look at Dominic Robb's case for the
defense of his behavior so he admits in
the letter to the prime minister in
which he has resigned uh that he had to
go he said um I called for this inquiry
it was five months ago that he did so
and undertook to resign if I may if it
meant any findings of bullying
whatsoever I important believe it is
important to keep my word
but there's not much sign of Contrition
after that while I still feel Duty bound
to accept the outcome of the inquiry it
dismissed all but two of the claims
leveled against me and I believe that
it's two adverse findings are flawed and
set a dangerous precedent for the
conduct of good government and this is
at the heart of what dominic Rob is
going to argue I think from the back
benches certainly also in an article of
the telegraph he's going to claim that
Adam Tully's report was unfetched it set
the bar too low he believes that his
conduct as he was Secretary of State in
the justice department and in this
foreign secretary was appropriate in
those roles in order to deliver high
standards for the people he thinks that
he's been damned far too easily by
people who are effectively mounting a
campaign against it he talks at length
about the things he didn't do in office
Mr Tony concluded that I had not once in
four and a half years sworn or shattered
to anyone let alone thrown anything or
otherwise physically intimidated anyone
nor intentionally sought to belittle
anyone and it's that word in 10
eventually clearly Adam Tully found that
he did belittle people the way in which
he would offer criticism that wasn't
constructive time again to officials
that he didn't think had done a proper
job but he doesn't accept it was
intentional it's all about the feelings
of the people who were in the room with
him uh it's gonna be quite a fine line
for people to decide whether or not the
behavior itself was wrong because it all
depends on how you uh how you took it
I'm genuinely story for an unintended
stress or offense uh that any officials
felt that's normally what's referred to
as a qualified apology but he says in
setting the threshold for bullying so
low this inquiry has set a dangerous
precedent it would encourage spurious
complaints against ministers and have a
chilling effect on those driving change
on behalf of your government and
ultimately the British people if we go
across to page two he goes on to say
this includes um he he thinks that there
should be an inquiry into the people
making complaints about him and he is
upset about the systematic leaking of
skewed and fabricated claims to the
media in breach of the Civil Service
Code by the way there wouldn't be any
inquiry whatsoever unless leaps had
emerged about Dominic Rob's Behavior
triggering the need for an independent
inquiry so people can take their own
view on that and then this which is
trigger out he claims that civil
servants were coercively removed from
his office by senior officials which he
thinks was wrong and he hopes his
inquiry into those uh Whitehall sources
deny completely that there's Eddie sent
that people were coercedly removed they
were removed uh basically uh as a duty
of care from senior officials but there
was no coercive Behavior by senior
officials and a short tribute to the
prime minister at the end so you get
that sense of bitterness almost sort of
Angus some ironic given the subject
matter of this whole investigation but
how does Rishi sunap respond what side
does he come down on does he completely
back Adam Tolley or does he actually
have some sympathy for his now ex-deputy
would he get some clues in his letter uh
he says thank you for your lesson
notifying me of your decision to resign
didn't sound like he was Keen or
resigning domitra but that's uh the way
this politics have uh has played out it
is with great sadness that I've accepted
your resignation so that's really seen
that not running a million miles very
fast away from Dominic Riley's accepting
the verdict but not uh uh not not gladly
in the way that uh some prime ministers
has done with some resignations
um he said I have pledged integrity
professionalism and accountability
um now this is the key paragraph when
formal complaints about your conduct in
different ministerial posts were
submitted last year I appointed that
your request an independent investigator
to do a full investigation Adam Tully
has now submitted his report and I've
carefully considered uh the findings as
you say you had rightly undertaken to
resign if there was any funding of
bullying you have kept your word but it
is clear that there have been
shortcomings in the historic process
that have negatively affected everyone
involved we should learn from uh from
this how to better handle such matters
in future all the rest of the letter to
be honest is uh fairly boilerplate
tribute to his time in in office but
this paragraph is fascinating
um there have been negative effects for
everyone involved now let's see everyone
involved that is Rishi sunak saying that
Dominic Rob as well has been negatively
affected by shortcomings in historic
processes I'm quite sure what he means
by the word historic but that is albeit
in code a nod to the fact that actually
he's not desperately happy desperately
uh clear about the criteria that Adam
Tully has used uh perhaps had to go
along with it because that's the
Judgment of an independent
well-respected QC but just a little hint
there from the Prime Minister he's not
um he is not entirely uh uh comfortable
with where We've Ended up in that report
and that I think with that we will
trigger what probably is quite likely to
be something of a national debate about
standard in work Sam I need to interrupt
you now because I've got some breaking
news to bring our viewers and I have got
Beth Rigby back in the studio
um the Prime Minister has not hung
around he has made a series of
appointments Beth he has I don't know if
I can be heard though because ah okay
well we'll get you my sorted out and in
the meantime I can tell our viewers
certainly that the Deputy Prime Minister
has been announced we weren't sure
whether the PM would actually appoint a
new Deputy Prime Minister that is uh
Oliver Dowden yes
um breaking news again the Prime
Minister has just appointed Oliver
Dowden as his Deputy Prime Minister now
Oliver Dowden again a key Ally of Rishi
uh sunak he is currently running the
cabinet office so the Machinery of
government and you might remember Oliver
Dowden because he was the party chair
yeah who back in I think it was June
after the conservatives lost two key
local elections I remember it because we
were in Rwanda for the chogum for the
people around him that morning yeah for
the Commonwealth um Summit uh and Oliver
Dowden that morning as Boris Johnson had
tried to brush off these losses sort of
blew the whole edifice open
um when he said that he was resigning
and when everyone talks about the
resignation process
um that triggered Boris Johnson's uh
departure everyone tends to talk about
it being Sajid Javid uh Follett who was
then the health secretary followed by
Rishi Suna but actually it was Oliver
Dowden he was the first cabinet
resignation and it was Oliver Dowden
that many felt had become you know the
outlier uh for this is Alex so I should
say this is the new Justice secretary
leaving Downing Street after his
appointment Former Defense Minister yeah
Alex chalk off he goes there he is the
MP for Cheltenham he's definitely on the
kind of one nation wing of the party
defense minister under Rishi sunaka key
Ally promoted today to Justice secretary
so in a way um the DP um the Prime
Minister has kind of lost his DPM but
he's kind of circling the wagons in the
sense of putting Oliver Dowden in as his
new Deputy someone who trusts a very
very close political Ally and then Alex
chalk becoming Justice section as I was
saying Oliver Dowden you know fell on
his own sword uh as a way of
destabilizing Boris Johnson you know at
a quite a delicate time for Boris
Johnson in a way that was undoubtedly
beneficial
um to the fall of Boris Johnson from
those such as Rishi sunak that mahaps
wanted to see that happen and say he's
someone that has just like Dominic Rob
if you like he's someone who has
politically
helped out
um
he's a former culture secretary yeah
there's knee Oliver down which is
interesting at a time when the Prime
Minister also has to make a decision
about the future of the uh of the BBC
chairman
yeah that's true he he was actually
though was he culture secretary when
that decision was made I can't remember
but he is the cult he was a former
culture secretary uh he was as I said a
party chair he didn't much like that job
I don't think but you know Boris Johnson
put him in as party chairman and as I
said he was instrumental in the
destabilization of Boris Johnson uh back
in uh June last year that began that
Cascade of resignations that saw uh
Boris Johnson uh moved out so Oliver
Dowden who already has a huge job in
government running the cabinet office
which basically coordinates between all
the Departments and is if you like the
operation room of government is now
stepping up to be DPM it's interesting
actually because one of us I was saying
earlier one of his key sort of political
allies sort of said to me I don't think
he'll necessary you know appoint a new
DPM but obviously he wants that
um that role and actually Oliver dowdon
doing it doesn't surprise me there's
Oliver Dowden there's Mel stride the
department of work and pensions you know
there was Dom Raab all of those were
very very uh close allies uh to Rishi
soon I can also kind of run the campaign
if you like to try and get him into
number 10 not once but twice okay so
he's got a couple more allies with him
now around around the cabinet table some
further appointments as well which we
should probably update our viewers on
Gareth Davis going to exchecker
secretary to the treasury and James
Cartledge presumably replacing Alex
chalk at the mod yeah so what he's done
there is he's you can see the kind of
choreography of this by the government
so they get the report yesterday there's
obviously a lot of to and fro about how
to handle it Dominic Rob clearly
sees that given that two complaints were
upheld against him for bullying has no
option but to resign whether he wants to
or not and then there's been quite a
coordinated sequence of events from
number 10 this morning number one
dominant Robb getting his resignation
letter out before the tally report comes
out in order for Dominic Rob to frame it
as favorably as he can you know get your
argument in fast
um then the tally report comes out in
the sympathetic letter from the Prime
Minister and then the appointments done
you know by 2 p.m done and dusted by
um you know just after the lunchtime
news
it's clear that number 10 just want one
cycle of this I guess the issue is Sam
as we were talking about earlier is
Dominic Robb uh feels clearly very
aggrieved all right Beth thank you very
much indeed for joining us on uh Friday
here and what has been uh political
pyrotechnics taking place on normally a
quiet day in Westminster uh but it was
started with the resignation of Dominic
Rob this morning
um after two out of eight of the
complaints against him for bullying were
our pelder he's not going quietly he has
also written an article in the telegraph
describing a kafka-esque process and
describing a concerted effort by civil
servants to bring him down he has been
replaced on the Justice brief by Alex
chalk who is leaving the mod to take up
that that promotion effectively and
Oliver Dowden is now Deputy Prime
Minister two key allies of Rishi sinaka
now joining him around the cabinet table
stay with us for plenty more on this at
two o'clock
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
's the top stories Dominic Robb resigns
as Deputy Prime Minister and Justice
secretary after a report into bullying
claims accuses him of unreasonably and
persistently aggressive conduct
almost a Rob criticizes the process
saying the country will pay the price if
the threshold for Billy Union government
is set so low
admits shortcomings in the process as
opposition leaders accuse him of
weakness
Oliver Dowden has been appointed as the
new Deputy Prime Minister
and Alex chalk will replace Mr Rob as
Justice secretary
also ahead today the UK puts military
planes on standby to evacuate British
citizens from Sudan's conflict
and all of NATO's allies officially
agree that Ukraine should become a
member
plus climate activists are warned not to
break the law as they begin four days of
protests in London
[Music]
hello good afternoon from Westminster
where Dominic Raab has resigned from the
government it's after an inquiry into
bullying allegations that were made
against him
well the 47-page reports into dominant
rather's behavior when he was in
government has now been published and it
details five months of Investigations
into eight accusations of bullying have
a little bit more a bit of a closer look
at what it found it said that Mr Rob
acted in a way which was intimidating
and persistently aggressive at meetings
he's also said to have described the
work of officials as utterly useless and
woeful while he was just a secretary
well Mr Raab also made unconstructive
critical comments about the quality of
his co-workers work
and the report also found that he was
involved in what it describes as an
abuse or misuse of power in a way that
undermines or humiliates
well Mr Rob left us home in Surrey a
little earlier this afternoon but he did
release a letter in which he took issue
with the report's findings in the letter
that he published he called the inquiry
flawed and he then went on to say well I
feel duty-bound to accept the outcome of
the inquiry it dismissed all but two
claims leveled against me I also believe
that it's two adverse findings a flawed
and set a dangerous precedent for the
conduct of good government
or the Prime Minister responded with
this letter where he accepted Mr Ram's
resignation with great sadness and he
promised to look again at the
disciplinary process
as well as pointing to Mr Robb's record
of delivery in both this government and
previous administrations Rishi sunak
said in his letter it's clear that there
have been shortcomings in the historic
process that have negatively affected
everyone involved we should learn from
this how to better handle such matters
in the future
while The Replacements have been
announced pretty swiftly Alex chalk is
going to be replacing Mr robbers Justice
secretary which you see Nick had made Mr
chalk a defense minister last year after
he backed the prime minister's campaign
for the leadership
and we can just have a look at the
latest pictures because he has arrived
at the ministry of Justice there's Alex
chalk there walking into his new offices
so has a legal background at someone who
was a supporter of Richard Cena in his
campaign to take over the leadership
Oliver data has been appointed as the
new Deputy Prime Minister as well
another key Ally of Rishi sunak
previously he was the chancellor of the
duchy of Lancaster
let's bring in our Deputy political
editor Sam Coates for a bit more
analysis shall we it feels like reading
those two letters from Dominic Robb who
clearly feels very wronged by this home
whole process and also when she's sunak
who perhaps saw the resignation as
inevitable but something that he pounds
regrets
this wasn't something that they wanted
to happen
no I think this has been immensely
painful process it was just 48 hours ago
that Richardson was sitting next to
Dominic Robb in Providence questions you
might have taken that as a subliminal
sign of backing at a point that they
already knew that Adam Tully's report
was going to land on the prime
minister's desk yesterday morning it's
hard to overstate how important Dominic
Robb has been for Rishi sunak now back
in 2019 when there was a leadership
contest that's when Dominic Robb stood
but last year when there was another
leadership contest he didn't in order to
throw his weight behind Rishi sood like
he was the person who often went out to
bat for Richardson neck in that really
rather testy at times ugly contest and
the two individuals work very closely
together it was only what three years
ago that Dominic Robb was effectively
running the country when Boris Johnson
was in hospital with covid uh in a very
unwell state it was felter Dominic Robin
his then role as first secretary of
state so this is somebody who has been
at the absolute top of British politics
yet today off the back of a report about
his con that he is now out and learning
street trying to move on with a series
of appointments to very close friends
and allies of the Prime Minister Oliver
Dowden and Alex chalk taking the roles
that Dominic Rob leaves behind but I
think the pain involved has been quite
something I remember
um when we were trying to get interviews
during that campaign with Liz trust the
momentum all behind her and it was so
easy to get you know former cabinet
ministers or senior figures to come out
and bat for Liz truss and Dominic Rod
was the person basically being put
forward every week by the Russia Cena
account because their support saving
away
she'll have a little bit of a look at
the report in a bit more detail what
exactly is the accused of what does it
say so the report today is about 50
pages I think we can bring it up on the
screen behind me and we've been waiting
for this since November it's by Adam
Tolley who's a respected uh QC it was
submitted yesterday as you could see and
it's a report into the conduct of
Dominic Raab now it's important to say
that this report found against Dominic
rahl but the contents of this report I
think is going to be quite controversial
for lots of different reasons so I'm
going to take you through the case
against Donald perhaps also some of the
complicating factors but first of all
let's begin here
this is effectively uh one of the worst
allegations about Dominic Robb uh that
uh Adam tolly are upheld so if we if we
zoom in here uh the Deputy Prime
Minister formed an adverse view as the
way as the way that some of his civil
servants when he was a foreign secretary
had acted in relation to one of the
major projects this is from his time as
foreign secretary and it goes through
the way that he uh operated with civil
servants that he was unhappy with
um as part of a protest towards
implementing uh some changes Dominic
Robb he acted in a way which was
intimidating in the sense of
unreasonably uh and persistently
aggressive in the context of a workplace
meeting his contact also involved an
abuse or a misuse of power in a way that
undermines a human it's just pause on
those words very aggressive words to be
using about the second most important
politician in the conservative benches
but there it was misuse of power
determining uh determined which
humiliated individuals and it was not
reasonably necessary in order to give
effective his decision and he also
introduced his language here introduced
a penis development in other words
threatened the civil servants in the
eyes of the civil servants I think what
he was doing was to say well that's
outside the civil service code and I
think by doing that he was threatening
that they could be uh uh disciplined and
that was bound to be experienced as
underbining or humiliating and so it was
experienced like that
um now the report goes on to talk about
lots of different elements of behavior
and at a point the report could be a
little um confusing there's a section
here on physical gestures now it talks
about claims of physical gestures uh at
the extreme uh this was put as extending
his hand directly towards another
person's face with the review with a
view to stop them talking he said that
would have been unacceptable but in the
end Adam Tully comes down that that
wasn't quite what happens we're getting
a lot of this is where it still wants to
get more interesting Sophie we're
getting some accounts which Adam Tully
is telling us he ended up not believing
it I was not convinced that the Dominic
Rob's physical
gestures were in a threatening way for
those unused to this style of
communication multifunic disconcerting I
did not consider that there was any
basis for legitimate criticism in this
in this respect now I'm going to take
you to another bit of the report where
perhaps it gets even more complicated
so here it talks about some of this from
the Deputy Prime Minister of Dominic
Rob's point of view Dominic rob it said
had a strong view that officials should
be able to answer his questions at a
meeting and should come prepared and if
they didn't he would offer what he would
do what Adam Tully thinks is wrong he'd
offer unconstructive criticism he would
go on about the lack of civil servants
being able to answer the basics or give
him basic information
now in Adam tolley's view that is
unacceptable if you are to criticize
somebody for not being across the basics
in front of other people who might not
know whether or not you should know the
answers to the question he's having Adam
Tolley comes down on the side of
thinking that this is an unfair personal
criticism uh uh to whom the contact uh
comment is directed and so it was
experienced by some uh individuals and
um
now I think actually what's interesting
is we'll get viewers will take their own
view about the extent to which a
minister can get really quite grumpy
when officials turn up and unable to
answer their questions in a way that
they think uh is acceptable now uh we
there's a lot we don't know but that in
itself is interested but you come down
here the Deputy Prime Minister had a
view that there was a cultural
resistance within the ministry of
Justice to his reforms he didn't like
his political agenda and that's the
context in which he was getting across
now again we don't know whether that's
fair or whether that's unfair because we
don't know what he was experiencing but
that's the allegation I suspect that
will be seized upon by some in this uh
in the conservative party uh as to
evidence of a campaign by officials uh
to oust on it Robin this is where it
gets really serious this is the most
potentially I think the most toxic bit
for Whitehall this is amazing this is
the Adam Tolley basically dismissed one
of the complaints because there was a
large group of civil servers he doesn't
even know how many uh who were pushing
complaints about Dominic Robb what's
interesting about them
only some of these individuals had
Direct experience of the Deputy Prime
Minister Dominic Raab some had never met
him at all but were seeking to support
their colleagues and their highlight a
bit down there I mean they actually were
launching complaints in March and then
again in uh in November uh uh and
basically the same content twice ever in
other words there was there was a
concerted campaign inside Whitehall in
order to undermine Dominic Raab and
actually Adam Tully took those
complaints less seriously so I think in
all of that context yes there is
behavior that clearly suggests that
Dominic Robb was difficult to work with
but at the same time officials he thinks
weren't delivering he thinks that he was
criticizing a lack of preparedness and
he thinks that some of them were
politically motivated against him it
does certainly feel doesn't it and that
those people who are already supportive
of Dominic ra perhaps are going to feel
Vindicated and those who think that yes
he's bullied that he was right to be
found against him will also be found
Vindicated the letters as well this is a
big part of it too isn't it because we
really find out about Dominic Robb's
reaction and the prime minister's
reaction in the letters what what do
they say we have an enormous data dump
today at Sophia and uh it's a lot of
time at screens and this is one of the
most extraordinary resignation letters I
have ever seen because I mean
Dominique Rob is sticking it in all
directions so first of all he says I had
to resign because I promised I would if
there was a finding of bullying he's
following through on the property meant
to you on your program that he would go
if there was a threat to quit but he
doesn't at all except what he was a
judgment against him is not comfortable
uh about it he says whilst I feel Duty
bound to accept the outcome of the
inquiry it dismissed all but two of
these claims leveled against me and I
believe that it's two adverse findings
are flawed and set a dangerous precedent
for the conduct of goods government it's
a direct attack on Adam Tully a direct
attack on the report that's ended his uh
political career he says look if you're
a minister you've got to be able to
criticize engage civil servants in a
respectful manner but nevertheless you
have to be able to do that
um uh and he then goes on to do
something quite interesting which in the
context of the Tully report is actually
a little bit more explicable but he he
starts to go on about things he didn't
do just to make clear uh some of the
allegations that have been flowing
around in the media aren't aren't the
case Mr tolly concluded that I had not
once in four and a half years sworn or
shouted at anyone let him know and
thrown anything or otherwise physically
intimidated anyone nor intentionally
sought to belittle anyone and this is
really interesting he said if
effectively Tully does accusing of
belittling but Dominic Robb says it's
not intentional and relies on the
testimony of those who say they are
victims in order to reach that
conclusion we're having a bit of a
national conversation in the in the
light of the departure of the head of
the CBI about what is and what isn't
acceptable workplace practice uh Dominic
Robb saying well I didn't mean to do it
I was upholding uh standards other
people have different standards am I
responsible for that Adam totally says
yes Dominic Robb says no a lot of people
are going to split either way on that
it's setting the threshold for bullying
so this inquiry is dangerous person it
will encourage spurious complaints uh
and um I will have a chilling effect uh
on uh things for the the British uh for
the British public uh there's a little
bit on page two of this he actually
wants an inquiry into the people who
exposed his behavior I want an
independent uh review onto the leaking
by civil servants against him and onto
the decision by senior civil servant to
the ministry of Justice this is not
taken by Antonio Romeo the permanent
secretary you just saw with Alex George
but one of her under to on don't return
to the ministry of Justice when Russia
Sunnet became prime minister to remove
Junior civil servants uh from that he's
called that coercive very uh cross in
the ministry of Justice I suspect about
the use of the world a brief tribute to
the Trump to the Prime Minister uh uh to
conclude that letter very angry very
unusual he's slamming the door on the
way out of the office so let's
you've got one account from Adam tolly
you've got Dominic Rudd completely
rejecting it but the critical question
Sophie forgive me for a long sequence
here but the critical question is where
does the Prime Minister come down
and much of this letter is perfectly
formulated he talked but he does start
by talking about his great sadness that
he's had to accept the resignation
that's just the first little hint uh
perhaps that the premise has some
sympathy uh for uh Dominic Rubble let's
see come in here uh big to the most
important sentence
you had to resign he said because you
promised to if that's what the report
said you have kept your word but it is
clear that there have been shortcomings
in the historic process that have
negatively affected everyone involved we
should learn from this how to better
handle such matters in future it's a
little bit unclear a little bit vague
but if everybody has been negatively
affected that includes Dominic Robb he's
saying Dominic Rob's been a bit hard
done by that's quite a thing on today
given that report and what's happened
yeah it certainly is and as you say it's
all about the prime minister's reaction
to it and now isn't it Sam thank you
very much for talking us through as you
said the Big Data dump today with the
report and the letters as well well Sam
was just touching there on what it means
for the Prime Minister for Rishi sinak
and how he handles the resignation of
one of his closest allies well the labor
leader stammer has said that his
handling of the affair in his words
highlighted the prime minister's
weakness
I don't know why Dominic craft thinks
Dominic Robb in the middle of a cost of
living crisis
thinks that anybody wants to hear about
his whining about having to resign what
I think everybody wants is strong
leadership and that has been palpably
absent here why on Earth was Rob
appointed in the first place one Earth
didn't the Prime Minister act more
quickly why on Earth isn't the
government laser focused on the cost of
living crisis
okay summer there at saying the
government should be laser focused on
the cost of living at crisis well our
political correspondent Ali Fortescue is
in Downing streets for us we've been
talking an awful lot about Dominic Raab
and those complaints against him but
let's talk a bit shall we about Rishi
sunak how do you think people are saying
that he's handled this situation
well look unsurprisingly you've got the
live Dems and labor you heard there
accusing him of dithering because he did
get this report yesterday morning at
about 9 00 a.m and all day yesterday
total silence we heard that he was
carefully looking through it and this
morning we now have Dominic Robb
effectively going before he's pushed we
now know that Dominic Rob and Richie
sunac spoke for the first time since
yesterday morning today this morning on
the phone before Dominic Robb released
that statement we don't know what
exactly they spoke about but obviously
you know this has implications for the
Prime Minister we're talking about one
of his closest allies the person that
was out batting for him when he went up
against Liz truss for the leadership the
person that was resurrected after being
put in political Wilderness by Liz truss
when Richard finally became prime
minister the deputy PM resigned this
morning that is a big thing so of course
it has implications for Russia there are
questions about what took so long and
spokesperson for number 10 today
standing by um the fact that the Prime
Minister needed to carefully go through
the detail
um but questions two I think that we
will talk about over the coming weeks
about why um Dominic Robb was appointed
in the first place if there were rumors
about his behavior at that time why was
he given such a big job as the prime
minister's Deputy so those are the big
questions but I think what we are seeing
is a prime minister very keen to move on
quickly and we have had some pretty
Swift appointments we saw about
10 20 minutes ago Alex drawk the new
Justice secretary being promoted into
cabinet he walked out of here I asked
him if he was happy with the job we got
a nod and a smile but not much else but
obviously a big day for him he now sits
around the cabinet table we also know
that Oliver Dowd and another close Ally
of British United someone who's been a
long time friend of Richie sunax he is
the transfer of duchy of Lancaster he
has now also been promoted to the Deputy
Prime Minister so he we expect will
deputize for the prime minister in uh
prime minister's questions if you can't
attend so that is obviously a huge job
the Prime Minister Keen to make these
appointments very quickly to move on
with this matter but make no mistake
this was a big deal this was not like
the case of Nadeem zahari where it was
pretty clear-cut the PM took quick
action not someone that was a long time
close Ally this was a someone in the
prime ministers Inner Circle really
someone who spoke to a lot and the
Deputy Prime Minister but he has gone as
we know and is making a bit of noise
about the process worth saying it was
interesting in the prime minister's
letter that he also mentioned
shortcomings in the process and it
sounds like the cabinet office are going
to look at the process itself how
historic claims are handled so that's
something interesting um that we'll look
at over the next few weeks as well but
for now rushi sunak has appointed a new
Deputy pm and a new Justice secretary he
hopes that means he can move on
yeah an interest in C's got two of his
closest allies in those jobs uh Ali
forsky thank you very much for your
analysis there Ali reporting from
Downing Street well we'll have plenty
more on the Ripple effects of the
dominant Rob resignation throughout the
afternoon but we can look now at some of
the day's other top stories for a moment
because Sky News understands the
government has put a number of military
aircraft on Readiness to move in the
event that Embassy staff and UK Citizens
need to be evacuated from Sudan now it
comes after almost a week of clashes
mainly in the capital cartoon between
the Sudanese Army and a paramilitary
group so far 413 people have been killed
in the fighting we can bring in our
Africa correspondent now user I'll be
gear thank you for being with us use for
us so just tell us more details about
these planes
I mean the planes are ready on standby
to evacuate any all the British citizens
that are currently trapped in the
fighting in Khartoum and other areas
they are not alone they're also American
planes uh in Djibouti their nearest Arab
base also preparing for for the same
thing these British planes Sky News has
been told uh haven't been they haven't
reached out to the ministry of defense
for support in any rescue rescue
missions but the ministry of defense is
prepared for that eventuality if that's
needed and so far neither country
neither the UK or the US has managed to
evacuate evacuate citizens there's
currently a forum on the government the
gov dot UK website asking citizens who
want to be repatriated to put in their
details there are all these preparations
but unfortunately as of now an actual
plan hasn't been able to be put into
practice
an user that's been as we were saying
earlier a week of clashes in Sudan
there's been talk of a Cesar any sign of
that happening
there are two ceasefires that have come
and gone and failed uh this does another
talk of a ceasefire that didn't hold
today is Aid it's the celebration of the
end of the holy month of Ramadan a month
of fasting and people spent Aid carrying
in their homes continue to continuing to
be trapped and in many areas their Eid
prayers the tradition were canceled
because of fighting so there's no sense
of normalcy around this situation
there's no sense of stability safe
passages that have been arranged for
people to leave are now closed down some
people have left through Egypt by bus to
through to the Egyptian border they can
no longer take that route because we're
learning that armed groups on that route
are now attacking people so things are
constantly changing and the the constant
is that there is no stability in that
fighting continues
coming and going thank you very much
indeed use for their reporting
on Saddam
back to the UK now and four days of
climate protests by Extinction rebellion
and other groups is now underway
the environmental campaigners claim up
to 50 000 people are heading to London
to set out climate demands
well Skies hey monitor Jason Farrell is
in central London Jason how are things
but I'm on one of the main roads that
runs between government departments here
in Westminster so behind me uh is the
Department of Education just around the
corner there and beyond that it would be
the department for energy security and
Net Zero and outside there for example
you have people who are protesting
against the expansion of oil exploration
then if you go around the corner here
you can see there are people outside the
home office at the end of Martian Street
and beyond that there's the department
for transport for example where they're
campaigning against hs2 outside the
department of leveling up there's
another group of campaigners campaigning
for example against the expansion of
coal and the introduced introductor of
coal mining in Cumbria I'm joined here
by what one of the co-founders of
Extinction Rebellion Claire Farrell
Claire what's the idea of this weekend
because a whole weekend of protests
isn't it yeah so the whole point of this
is to bring as many people as possible
together we've got over 200
organizations I think they've got a of
you know somewhere close to tens if not
100 million memberships of people so
there's an awful lot of people now
coming together to organize and to
commit to doing this demonstration this
weekend but also working together I
think an ongoing way now you haven't
brought your super glue no uh you're not
going to stick yourself to anything I
understand are you not going it's going
to be more discourse than disruption is
that the right way to put it yeah that's
that's the idea I mean I think we're
looking at the moment at a bigger
ecosystem of change than when we first
set out obviously XR is like five years
old there are people in the mix just
stop oil insulate Britain people that
are doing more radical campaigning and
is that putting people off I don't think
so I think it's very helpful I think it
brings urgency I think they bring a
youth voice it does loads of really
important stuff but we also need a
bigger movement yeah you were saying to
me when you started this up you expected
more of your friends to join in when
what you were doing yeah and they didn't
yeah and that you think might change now
it just just talked me through that well
I was surprised because when we started
it it's obviously a shock right when a
social movement takes off you go well
that's quite surprising that it's that
it's worked invert commas I presumed a
lot of my friends who understood what I
was saying would show up and they
actually didn't but this weekend loads
of them are coming those people that I
was surprised didn't turn up and we know
there's like a latent support for all of
the things that we say and a lot of the
people don't come we need them to start
showing up is that is that because this
is a bit more grown up you know the
other stuff is a bit immature and it's
disruptive and people don't like it I
don't think immatures the right word
there is a it takes enormous amount of
maturity to actually go out and do Civil
Disobedience and face arrest and lose
your Liberty so it's not about a lack of
respect for that work but it's an
understanding that you know there are
people engaged in different layers of of
participation in our in our efforts and
you know the lawyers recently who've
refused to prosecute climate activists
that's their way of doing Rebellion
there's going to be more of that I think
across different professions different
groups of society need to work out what
they can do to be maximally effective
okay Claire thank you very much for
talking to us the one thing that the
actors here have said that they won't be
doing for example is disrupting the
London Marathon this Sunday they do say
this is a peaceful protest there will be
a lot of noise throughout the weekend
but of course the question really is is
the government listening
that is the question certainly uh Jason
Powell I thank you very much indeed
now all NATO allies have officially
agreed that Ukraine will become a member
of the alliance Secretary General James
stoltenberg says that once the war ends
Kiev must have the deterrence to prevent
new attacks
well the military analysts retired Air
Vice Marshal Sean bow joins us now
thanks very much for being on the
program so what is the latest then
between Ukraine and NATO
good afternoon Sophie yes uh although
Ukraine is not part of NATO against
stoltenberg's visit to Kiev yesterday
was the first time he's actually visited
and he re-emphasized Ukraine's rightful
places within NATO and he also charged a
course for the for Ukraine to actually
uh graduate into NATO ownership but it
was interesting today that the Kremlin
has also made clear that one of the
reasons they invaded Ukraine was to stop
Ukraine from joining NATO but today
stoltenberger has increased the rhetoric
even further as you say he's said that
all NATO members now agree that Ukraine
will eventually join NATO this was on
the eve of the Ukrainian contact group
that's happening in Ramstein uh tomorrow
this is the U.S led Coalition of the
Willing that the coordinating military
aid for Ukraine it's not just NATO it's
NATO plus really
um and is interesting isn't it how
significant do you think this moment is
the fact that Noto moving towards
accepting Ukraine as a member it's very
significant
um but I think for me the real question
is how whether actually Ukraine is being
looked to be fast-tracked if you recall
that Finland was fast-tracked into NATO
uh the fastest nation's ever been and
Sweden likewise they're expected to Fast
Track that through two
um but of course both those Nations
already met NATO requirements but they
wanted to remain neutral as soon as they
decided they didn't want neutrality it
was almost like they were pre-approved
whereas there are very strict entry
requirements for entering NATO we don't
have the time to go through them now but
one of them is the ability to make
meaningful and significant military
contributions to Nato it'll be quite
some time before Ukraine manages to meet
that requirement and also it's worth
pointing out that at the end of the war
between Russia and Ukraine there will
need to be a negotiation uh it's very
difficult to see that Russia would agree
to any negotiated settlement that saw
Ukraine join NATO so the real issue
there is what are the security
arrangements for Ukraine at the end of
the conflict and almost certainly
president zlenski will not accept accept
a spoken word or written bit of paper
given that in 1994 The Budapest memo was
signed that guaranteed the sovereignty
and the security of Ukraine which Russia
ignored completely 30 years later that's
really interesting all the different
consequences of this uh to be worked out
and whenever we have you on Sean I
always like to get a bit of a sense
about what the latest situation is on
the ground in Ukraine what can you tell
us
well I think the most fascinating story
today is the Russians admitting that
last night an su-34 one of their
state-of-the-art Fighters actually
bombed one of their own cities up at
Belgrade which is only about 30 miles
away from the Ukrainian border
um interestingly the there's a big
crater made in the middle of the city 20
meters wide it upturned a car as well
and apparently we've got reports of at
least two casualties only injured
although if you see by the state of the
devastation it's hard to imagine that
won't increase the su-34 is actually a
state-of-the-art relatively modern
Soviet aircraft uh about 10 of these
have been lost since the start of the
war it's about 19 platforms the real
question is how on Earth did this happen
initial Reports say for the Russians
that they had jettisoned uh the weapons
well as a former fighter pilot myself
you have the ability to Jetson stores
fuel tanks and weapons but when they
leave the aircraft they leave in an
unarmed State they cannot possibly
explode whereas these blew up when they
hit their targets almost certainly they
were were intended to be released the
challenges did the pilot misidentify a
Target 30 miles away from enemy
territory so it looks unlikely well
looks most likely is that before this
fighter pilot entered into Ukraine
airspace he was probably doing some
training getting used to the switchery
practicing attacks on uh on targets
without actually intending to release a
bomb made his switches live and it
inadvertently released a bomb which
caused such Devastation on the ground
the Russian fighter this is a very
capable fighter but it just illustrates
that equipment alone is not military
capability their pilots are good but
they don't get the flying hours they
don't have the simulator time and this
is a very embarrassing incident but it
also highlights the relative
incompetence of some of the Russian Air
Force pilots yeah certainly does uh Sean
Bell thank you very much indeed always
good to uh have you talking us through
the latest on Ukraine
you're watching Sky News coming up we
were going to have more reaction to the
reservation of Dominic Robb and that
extraordinary resignation letter as well
where he takes aim at well just about
everyone
[Music]
foreign